good morning everybody it's Friday
[Music]
that's good news yeah that's the good
news that's the good news
the other news though is that you need
to look at the calendar for coming up
next week and in that calendar there's a
number of our bills that are listed in
that calendar for everybody sitting here
at the tables
um there are at least I would say close
to 10 10 bills on consent
and then we have a host of bills that
are coming on on the regular calendar so
if you haven't looked it over look it
over be be aware that that is coming up
um and it's it's it's going to be a
lengthy it seems like a lengthy day but
there's uh it's a day also when there's
a lot of other stuff going on with it
with it with the governor as well
so
um I think in both of the caucuses which
we'll have you will be discussing that
uh going on into the first item on our
docket for today
on Executive session we have an
executive session for 577. this is
relative to state aid for special
education pupils uh representative call
upon you for a motion yeah I would do a
move to retain this bill and I'll second
that
speak to that
you have it you're you're are you ready
to go over there
if it's right out of the shoot I know
it's pardon me no one wants to okay
um so once again the motion is to retain
for 577 the Motions made by represent
Myler and second by representative Ladd
uh the the issue is relative to state
aid for special education pupils
represent Milo you're recognized uh
thank you Mr chair I mean this this as
we in the testimony we we discover that
this is a very important bill
and but it has uh multiple kinds of
issues related to it
uh to Move It from three and a half
times one and a half times there
obviously is a cost benefit on this and
also how it would be applied uh to
special uh special education services so
my sense is that we we just need to have
a little more time to look at this
because it has a major ramification for
uh special education students and
parents thank you Mr chair thank you and
I will offer a little bit of discussion
on it as well by reducing from three and
a half times to one and a half times or
two and a half wherever we may go we've
had this bill come before us before but
then when you have this type of Bill
come in you're also discussing the
eighty percent twenty percent which is
The Next Step Beyond and you have to
take into account the students which are
now going to be qualifying for that and
a number of new students which are going
to be coming in and qualifying for the
the at the special education Aid and
there is a a Glide path there we just
don't have the information on numbers of
students or even potential numbers of
students
um and how that would impact the
delivery of services the whole nine
yards so there's a lot to this
um we have it's also uh very much a part
of this discussion we're having on how
we're funding education
and this is a huge portion of one aspect
of special education that needs to be
looked at seriously and I think we all
agree upon that I brought the bill
forward last time trying to reduce it
down too and we hit that same wall but
however now we need to really dig in and
resolve how we're going to fund this
aspect of special needs further
discussion
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair I just need a little
more understanding as a freshman rep
so when it's retained is a study
committee formed or how does the work
happen and what is the timeline likely
to be when we retain a bill we retain a
bill and next time we take that bill up
we'll be in November and and so in
November the Motions can be ought to
pass I itl or interim study in the
interim what we do is we put a and and
this is one of those bills which we
won't have just a work session it will
be a subcommittee whether it's a
subcommittee that's developed
with so many people on it or whether
it's a subcommittee of the whole if it's
of the whole it means we have a
subcommittee here with all folks on this
particular body right here participating
in that study by doing so we also invite
technical support in to offer us
assistance and that is exactly what we
further discussion yes
thank you just to follow up so that
study committee whether it's partial or
whole
would be meeting in the summer
we start meeting on that as soon as we
unload our bills and we have oftentimes
started in the late spring side uh when
we get rid of the Senate bills we are
restricted at times as far as how when
we can start the subcommittee in the
past when we've had a bill like this
I've always been able to you know convey
to leadership that this is a bill which
we're wasting time we need to get on to
right now and we have done that uh we
don't do it with many but uh the area of
this where it's a policy implication and
a finance implication
it's oftentimes we will bring in people
from Finance as well into this
discussion as we did with the Medicaid
direct
last year we had a subcommittee with uh
chaired by Karen umberger at the time so
yes we would get going probably
somewhere in the latter part or when we
get into the spring months and we have
less going on here and I say less but
that doesn't mean we don't have a lot
so that's what we try to do and we don't
meet during the summer months
um unless you're on a statutory
commission and the statutory commission
will continue working right through as
you will know with you know the the CTE
stuff and all that we keep going public
school infrastructure we keep going on
that however this type of study we pick
it up later on in the fall and that
gives us you know when you're talking
about September October then November it
gives a significant amount of time there
as well
another discussion
not seeing Madam clerk would you please
call the roll
foreign
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis
not here okay
um
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yeah representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno
nothing oh okay sorry uh representative
Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
ha is not here representative Balboni
yes
representative Damon yes
17 EAS zero Nays
thank you so that bill will be retained
and we will work on that through
subcommittee uh either of the
subcommittee a few or of the whole that
will be decided alrighty so we don't
have anything else on the dock here to 9
45 and what we got to do is that we're
going to break into caucuses here and
we'll pick that up at 9 45 with 6 6 51 I
would just remind everybody the bills
which are on consent
that the person who made the committee
report needs to be ready if somebody
pulls a bill we've got to respond to
that and we'll let you know as soon as
we know that anything's been pulled uh
but be prepared for that let's break for
caucus
um do you have a room you're going to go
to represent mileage you're going to
find one just wander the halls there
we are a little smaller sub or
that's right we should that both of the
bills which the speaker will basically
just call for a Voice vote and move on
uh that's where it's at 20 to 0 or 17 to
3 or something like that so we don't
have to sign up to speak again they'll
just move right to the wakeboard yeah
that that's that's a good question
so you know when you have something like
it's a 17 or 3 or a 1901 or a 20-0 we
hopefully will move on on that without
having the great Kaka
yeah
um
that's right okay
and
yeah I heard that was um good like yeah
so we'll yeah I'm going to talk about
this yeah good so we are moving into we
are are moving into caucus here in the
room right now so we'll have to have the
public go outside until we finish our
caucus
librarian my first task is to put them
foreign
I'd like to go ahead with the hearings
for this morning I see we have the prime
sponsor of this bill
up there he's not on Deck he's right at
the at the table uh welcome to all those
that are attending today's hearings uh
this this house bill we're addressing
first today is 6 51 authorized in the
Department of Education and local school
districts to contract with
Transportation Network companies to
provide School transportation services
welcome representative cardelli uh thank
you Mr chairman and honorable colleagues
for the record Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro Wolfeboro and
Ossipee in the beautiful Lakes Region
um I'm sure we're all familiar with Uber
and Lyft and the other Rideshare
companies uh at this point uh but there
is a movement growing Across the Nation
to provide a similar uh facilities and
um it's they're not meant to be
replacements for those big big yellow
buses or even the medium-sized yellow
buses
um these are knit Niche Transportation
Alternatives and we'll get into some of
that some of those
um there are a number of companies that
are doing this nationally I've talked to
several
um the information that's going around
is in relation to one of those companies
called hop skip and drive they're in
over 12 States at this point and they
are interested in coming to New
Hampshire I talked to another company
that is not interested but um I think
this is something more that we'll see
around the country
and
in particular I think that
um this type of service fits in very
well with some of the problem areas for
transportation we have talked about in
New Hampshire
um
homeless children
trying to arrange bus transportation for
them where they are
foster care children you could have a
foster care child placed in a home at
seven o'clock at night
for that school then to try and arrange
transportation for them it might take a
week or so with a service like this
they'll have transportation the next day
to get to school
um
there are
the CTE Alternatives we've talked about
trying to get a small number of in many
cases of students from ascending
school to a CTE Center and the cost of
transportation for those CTE Services
these services are primarily for
vehicles that are eight passengers or
less so they can handle
um and
provide a lower cost alternative to what
many districts are having to do now
the other one that came to my mind was a
special ed services
when this IEP related Transportation
needed but in particular we've talked
about
charter schools and special needs and
we've dealt with issues for several
terms
related to where if the student is in a
charter school has an IEP the resident
school district is responsible for their
services the service question is where
are those Services provided do they send
the child back back on a big yellow bus
back to the sending District the sending
District send someone to the Charter
School
um these Alternatives I think are a
perfect fit for those scenarios
and one of the nice things about these
services and this one in particular that
I know of
they have an app on your phone so you
can go in as a parent and schedule
recurring rides or a one-time ride if
you're transporting your child most days
but you need a ride tomorrow because
you're not going to work or something
you can go into the app and schedule a
ride for your child the next day
um
one of the
Hallmarks of this company I think is
um
one their safety but also
um they call their drivers care drivers
they take very seriously
um the service that they're providing
and the
fact that they are transporting school
children
um
I don't have copies for everybody but
I'd be glad to provide a copy of their
uh 2021 or 22 safety reports they're
like this thick going over their safety
record
they go through an extensive extensive
series of
background checks
investigations
checking the vehicles and so forth
I have also talked to the uh Department
of Motor Vehicles and I I think uh I
think someone is here in fact I know
someone is here from them today and I
think uh he'll talk about uh how they
what is going on now is we know what DMV
requires of vehicles to transport school
students and
DMV will be talking to people from hop
skip and drive to work out arrangements
and the processes for those requirements
for instance that's very possible that
some of the equipment
required for the transport Vehicles
could be waived and we've talked about
that with a DMV
but we're uh we all want to make sure
that the background checks and
everything else are done and that's part
of what hop skip and drive does and
they're anxious to work out all the
arrangements with our DMV people
but I think that this has a great
potential for solving some of our
transportation problems here in New
Hampshire and
um uh it's it's seems to be coming from
the west coast to the east coast as as
many things do
um but I think we can uh be a leader on
the east coast in terms of
rectifying some of the transportation
problems and costs that we have for
these Niche areas here in New Hampshire
so thank you
thank you very much representative
cordelli uh are there questions from the
committee yes representative Miler uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative cordello for bringing
this before us uh two related questions
uh we in this committee have always been
concerned about uh safety of children
not just from a vehicle standpoint but
from a driver's standpoint
how does this uh how does this bill
guarantee that there are appropriate
background checks etc for those drivers
that's the first question the second
question is how do we know which
vehicles are appropriately equipped to
deal potentially with disabled children
who would have unique kinds of needs
both from a wheelchair and from a
mobility of getting in and out of
vehicles thank you for answering my
question sure thank you
um
I I think some of those questions will
be answered by the uh by the trooper who
is here today
um but um
uh this is just a checklist of some of
the things that
um hop skip tribe does in other states
um and they've as I said they've worked
with at least 12 different states and
are very accustomed to working with
local officials to make sure that they
are
um in compliance with uh local
requirements and so I I do not see that
as a major issue going forward
but things that they require for
instance at least five years of
caregiving experience being finger
printed
scanning for child abuse or neglect in
human services databases or local
databases
good driving records age requirements
proof of registration Insurance Etc as
well as the fingerprinting and
background checks so safety is um
Paramount in what they do and
um it's something that I've talked
extensively with them about unfound
follow up yes and the uh the vehicle
issue how how is that dealt with
um uh I uh
I I think that um that is arranged with
the
um uh the matching of the driver and the
vehicle with the person who is
requesting the uh Transportation so that
would be worked out
um uh between
um the company and the person as to what
type of facilities for transportation
are required thank you further questions
representative Tanner
the question is uh and thank you for
taking it is how is this going to be
paid is it is it uh the person that
requests the the vehicle or is it the
school district or who actually ends up
paying the money for this
um depending on um the type of service
and
um who's requesting that it could be um
uh all of the above uh so it could be a
parent requesting uh Transportation
under special circumstances
um it could be the district
um especially in some of the instances
we talked about in terms of having to
provide transportation to a CTE Center
or Transportation related to special ed
services for a student at a charter
school I would see those as being a
yes
understanding because I worked in a
district that almost everybody got bust
well everybody did get bust to school
that there is there is an issue with
Contracting with the busing service
and then having smaller vendors do uh
you know at will uh runs for them that
that the school generally contracts in
bulk and then the Contracting Services
provides
the appropriate boss whether it's a
wheelchair you know
um accessible or whatever
um that's part of their contract
how do you think how do you see school
districts being able to
um
deal with with those kinds of issues
I think would be on a um District by
District basis based on the terms of any
contract they currently have for
transportation services the length of
the contract
um vehicle situations
um so I don't think there's uh one size
fits all answers that question but I
think it's a district by District issue
to be looked at
representative cascaden
thank you
um representative Vlad and thank you for
presenting the bill and uh for taking my
question representative has uh nhsta
weighed in on this bill or one of the
Troopers here representing that agency
yes uh I uh had a meeting with the
commissioner and troopers at DMV uh a
couple of weeks ago so they are here to
uh talk about it as well thank you
yes represent McDonald thank you
chairman and thank you for bringing this
forward
this bill is not specific to HUB skip
drive and that company is not mentioned
within the bill correct is there a
potential for another company to
contract or are there to be a
competition between them without
question right that's why it was
um I wouldn't put a specific company in
in to legislation
um but there are several companies who
are doing this
um it's just that uh
um the one company I talked to was not
interested in New Hampshire and and hop
skip and drive was very interested and
they are doing it already in multiple
States thank you
further questions from the committee yes
representative woodcock
thank you chairman good morning good
morning
um on the particular Bill uh do you
envision I'm thinking of my school
district when I see the lodge all of us
ago go out and come back with three kids
go out and come back with three kids
um but they have to make their run to
Jackson about all the places do you do
you envision saying this at some point
in the future replacing the lodge school
buses in rural areas
um I I I I doubt it
um but uh I'm not sure again I think
would be a district by District base
basis as to what their runs look like
and the number of uh children in those
runs
um but um in your area I know
um of uh for instance uh Hale's location
which is now faced with the question of
uh uh transporting uh to elementary
school students
um and um I think this would be a
perfect solution for them
um so I I you know I don't know if
there's um one boilerplate answer to
that
yes thank you
um not a fall of a different one uh
representative do the vehicles that
these uh smaller programs use are they
all the the uh standardized vehicle like
a bus or I guess I'm trying to decide if
I if I stop my own company can I just
use my car if it meets the DMV
regulations or are they all different
are they all different pieces of
different types of vehicles
um yes as long as it uh passes uh muster
with a DMV for transporting children
um it could be your van of some sort
anything okay yeah all right most likely
apparently written on my car thank you I
pass it every morning coming down the
interstate thank you represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for daily
um given them would this bill um help
not just public school students but
would also be available to things like
um
homeschooling centers and private
schooling or is is not is none of that
involved in this yet
um thank you for the question
um yes this company does provide those
types of services elsewhere
um as well for instance a uh homeschool
student
um wanting to go to a Cooperative
program or something like that
I believe they're also involved in a
Pre-K programs in transportation in some
states as well
follow up thank you just so given so
given our move toward greater
educational Freedom allowing parents to
send their students where they want them
to go would get the kind of education
they want them to receive does this you
do you see this as facilitating solving
logistical errors possibly before they
um I uh I would also always like to
solve problems before they occur
um but uh yeah I think that this has uh
great potential in a number of areas
that you mentioned and probably others
that we haven't even thought of yet
thank you Russell Woodcock you have
another question thank you there's one
final one
um I know we how I am but in the bigger
District we'll further over this thing
uh in our uh contract with the the
company that does our our transportation
there is an uh an allowance for small
vendors to do some specialized now to go
out and pick up those kids would that be
any different from this
the school district now had the right to
do that through the contract
thank you uh yeah I I think as long as
um that company is is meeting
um state requirements
um uh I yeah I think that that is an
option
thank you we do have the uh officers
here uh any more questions for
representative cordelli
thank you very much
uh officer Hildreth and Sergeant are you
coming up with him or
pardon me
oh okay thank you
all right
good morning okay my name is uh Trooper
first class Gregory Hildreth Alaska
spelled
h-i-l-d-r-e-t-h for the record I am
currently the supervisor for Pupil
Transportation at the State Police uh
working in conjunction with the
Department of Motor Vehicles
right now as written the state is
opposed to this bill uh the intent
however
and I'm going to go over it
can already be accomplished and
I'll go through it from the start so the
first question the state had when
reading this bill is you know is there a
need for this specific legislation is it
trying to accomplish something that
can't already be done there are two rsas
primarily uh 259 96 and 259.96 a those
are what give the department of safety
the authority and the oversight of the
current School Bus industry under 259.96
the breakdown on the synopsis of what
that law states is a school bus is any
vehicle that is being utilized
transporting students to and from home
and to school related activities or
School related activities in Louisville
contract the municipality or School
District so if a vehicle is transporting
a child from home to school and it's
being compensated in any way by the
school district or furthering the school
district's needs that isn't being
accomplished outside it's considered a
school bus in that time in operation
if it falls under 259.96 it falls under
the administrative rules the safc 1300
rules which regulate school buses that
regulates drivers background check
requirements it regulates their training
requirements it regulates the equipment
on board there's two different
breakdowns in sections uh just to take a
step back
most people when you say School Bus the
first image that comes to your head is
going to be a yellow bus out on the road
that is a fallacy because it's not
completely correct uh that is some of
them we classify them as Class A B C and
D buses those are how they're recognized
the yellow buses there typically from
the short bus all the way up to the
large flat nose bus however there's a
class 5 which is considered which is the
not the name of it but that's another
class of vehicle it's called an MPV a
multi-passenger vehicle and to answer
your question that's those Dodge
Caravans Crown
Victoria's whatever else is out there
that doesn't fit that by legislative
under the legislation they are limited
to carrying a maximum passenger capacity
of 10 to include the driver beyond that
we want them a kids in safer Vehicles
the bigger buses that are designed like
tanks on Wheels they have steel
reinforcement those black bars you see
running around the perimeter that hip
shoulder and foot level you know there's
all kinds of safety features that are
regulated under the administrative rules
in the 1308 section
1312 deals with all those other vehicles
the Crown Victoria's the Dodge Caravans
all that so there's equipment
requirements that are still required of
those via Vehicles so those are all
school buses when they're operating as I
explained before and this goes back to
my initial statement of what's the
intent what are we trying to accomplish
with this law because right now
if they're willing to follow those rules
that are currently in place and start up
their own company under the name of hop
skip and a drive they can absolutely do
that right now today and become a school
bus company falling under our 259 96
rules transporting to and from school
and home related activities in
Louisville contract municipality if
they're doing all that that's great so
where was this law coming from uh
if the intent was to circumvent those
rules and to essentially allow them to
operate just on this law alone and give
them the green light to now become a
school bus company go do transport
because it's written into the 376 laws
this is where the state objects because
at this point if the intent is to okay
they're going to follow the existing
laws and those safety measures in place
we need to have a cross-reference in the
current writing of the law that
references 259.96. if they're trying to
and in the back of this law it makes
reference to putting it into the same
category as 259.96 a a mixed use bus
this in a way hints at maybe taking it
outside of our oversight because under
259.96a I've already explained the
qualifiers of a school bus a mixed use
bus under 96a has three qualifiers on
its own if it is operated or owned or at
least by the school
it has to be driven for by any School
employee so someone has undergone the
fingerprint check at least once and if
it's in time it's being used utilized
for school activities that vehicle does
not follow the 1300 rules it does not
fall under oversight so it takes itself
outside of the rules and this is where
the concern is we're 259.96a is
mentioned in the latter half of this
bill where it says it could be a mixed
use bus a transportation Network company
could never ever be a mixed-use bus It
could only be because it misses the
first qualifier it wasn't owned released
by the school once you cross that one
off
259.96a no longer applies it cannot be
put into place that was only allowed to
be in place for a school willing to go
out and buy their own vehicle to do
those local transports for school
related activities and field trips and
the caveat of not having the driver have
to have a school bus certificate which
is regulated by 259.96 was that at least
hey at least they need to have been
fingerprint checked by the Department of
Education once and that was where
259.968 came in from so
again if we go back to what's the intent
of this if they're willing to follow the
process is there a need for this law uh
if they're not the concerns of the state
are if we're going to circumvent the
current oversight and regulation of
Pupil Transportation uh this would
basically allow all the safety checks
and walls and the criteria that has been
approved as far as what's acceptable in
a driver to be thrown out the window and
we're going to assume that a third party
fingerprint check is going to meet all
the criteria uh if it's approved this
bill would allow drivers that are
operating these vehicles no longer the
need to be rostered uh tracked with a
state as far as their training goes to
make sure that these drivers are
qualified and don't have any
disqualifying material in their
background and they don't have to
undergo annual training they don't have
anything that basically requires us or
gives us the authority to make sure that
they're complying with the existing laws
like we currently have and the ability
to go audit existing school bus
companies
uh equipment on these vehicles as I
mentioned in the 1312 section we dictate
that they have to have certain equipment
body fluid spill kits medical kits they
got to have a seat belt cutter they got
to have certain stop a sign on top of
the roof that gives us a four-way
warning system they have to have
markings now there is the ability for
certain companies under circumstance
certain circumstances to request waivers
so they don't have to go through the
expense of adding some of this stuff a
vehicle that's going to pick up kids
exclusively in a driveway especially
under an IEP if the IEP allows it and
then drive that kid to the
school but dropping them off outside of
what would be the normal loading and
unloading Zone where there's less
traffic if they're going to be doing
that there's no need for a roof sign
there's no need for markings on the side
this thing doesn't have to have that
equipment so the companies can actually
save money requesting a waiver from the
commissioner safety which we would issue
to the company but that vehicle would
still be required to go and do what's
called a school bus inspection so
everybody's familiar in New Hampshire
with the bottom left your windshield you
of your state safety inspection that's
compliant with the safc 3200 rules the
center sticker needs to comply with the
safc 1308 or 13-12 section which
dictates all that equipment that needs
to be on board if that inspector is
making sure again annually we got to
make sure this is being done
that this equipment is on board so we
have some oversight to make sure this
stuff is being accomplished if this is
passed as is with no reference to 259.96
and ensuring that they're put into that
same category we run the risk of having
that oversight gone
the follow-up issue is again drivers who
might have failed a background check
with our department you know something
that would have been hey this is a
safety risk we can't have this driver
this driver has too many driving
violations that would have barred them
there's no guarantee that that would be
caught in a third party only background
check so a driver theoretically driving
and a company for First Student that
gets denied from our office could then
just go and get a job at this
third-party company and potentially get
hired and do the exact same job in
transport with less oversight left
regulation which brings me to my final
point is if we're putting generally
these vehicles are going to be smaller
they're going to be smaller in size
there's going to be less passengers
potentially it could be one person and
if we don't have thoroughly vetted
drivers and we put them alone with kids
you're just opening a potentially a
recipe for disaster
going back to the uh one of the members
questions I believe you mentioned uh if
a parent wanted to do this they can
already do that today if this is being
funded by a parent if a parent calls up
Uber tomorrow and says I want my child
brought there and they're the ones
funding it that's outside of the 1300
rules that's outside of 259.96 it they
can do that on their own accord a parent
has a 100 absolute decision if they want
to pay for that themselves but if the
funding and decision is coming from the
school they must follow 259.96 and
that's a state's position
thank you very much officer Hilder are
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony I just it seems like most of
the the concern around it is based on
the the transferring of rule making
Authority
um the possibility that there might be a
need to generate more rulemaking
Authority
um but I guess I wanted to ask
that rule-making Authority was delegated
by this body in the first place correct
I'm not tracking what your uh the rule
making Authority for the executive
branch to create those rules based on
um the laws that you cited that
rule-making Authority originated in this
body and was delegated to the executive
branch so we could do that again if we
needed to with this correct that's why I
objective has written understood thank
you
representative Cornell Thank you
for your testimony
we have a list of those objectives to
this objections to this that you have
that that we could have a copy of I
could absolutely do a cleaner version
I've been taking some pen notes on this
so I don't want to present this one but
I can certainly do that okay thank you
very much if I could just grab someone's
contact I will make sure I get it okay
thank you just take one of those ticket
forms you have and just scratch it on
that
further questions from the committee I
have one for you officer um yes sir uh
the inspection sticker which I have my
car on the front left windshield
um is issued by a local station that's
approved by the state uh the if I'm
working for Durham or Butler or first
student or some other Transportation
Company where do they get their buses or
Vehicles even the class five you speak
of here which is much much smaller where
are those inspected through the same
person inspects my vehicle or do you
have a safety officer go out and inspect
these vehicles on a regular basis thank
you for your question uh that one is
easy they basically are not the same
person uh in order to give them a to
issue that left sticker on the bottom
left for your safety inspection sticker
they need to go and actually be examined
and prove that they can pass a test and
they know what the laws are looking for
they aren't trained at that level to
look for this the stuff that complies
with the 1300 section of the rules
they're only doing the 3200 third
section so in order to become and get
that middle window sticker which is your
school bus inspection sticker which is
the second sticker sticker required they
actually need to undergo a similar
training and evaluation so mechanics
willing to step up and do that are
tested the same way where someone will
actually go out and test them make sure
they know what criteria they're looking
for once they do that they are then
certified as a school bus inspector and
they can issue that sticker there are
Fleet stations that can do that so some
of those larger companies have their own
inspectors but smaller ones there are
plenty of school bus companies that are
more no more than one vehicle and
they'll have to go out and find a
mechanic and the Department of Motor
Vehicle can actually help those drivers
locate them
can I get one follow-up for you uh has
the department checked with other states
to see how this program may or may not
be functioning
we haven't the closest thing I can talk
about is a transportation Network
company would be the equivalent of a
taxi cab company which we have several
of in New Hampshire that do this
transport and the ones that we have are
com in compliance they're doing
everything they're supposed to be doing
a lot of them have waivers so you might
not even recognize it to be a school bus
when you're passing it in which case
they've been you know Exempted from
having the markings because the state
certainly recognizes the need for
transportation mckinney-vento was very
clear about that back in the 80s or 90s
that there must be a non-uh level there
can't be an undue level of hurdles
present preventing them but the need for
safety wasn't determined to be an unneed
hurdle it's kind of a mandatory
requirement so
um when it comes to those taxi companies
we certainly are willing to take them in
and open them up and help them get set
up and in fact I have a template for
every company in fact representative
cordelli and I spoke and I forwarded him
that information this is what I provide
to companies that want to start up a
school bus company from A to Z and this
is how you do it legally and this is how
you you follow the existing laws to
establish your company and what you need
to do as far as the department of safety
goes once they so but some of those
companies don't want to exclusively do
school bus transportation you got those
taxi companies so they don't want to
letter it up they don't want to put you
know the signs on top of the roofs or
anything like that so that's where the
commissioner of safety's waiver comes in
they send us an email simply asking hey
we don't need this equipment we don't
need this because we have no need to
control traffic and we'd like a waiver
for that so we end up sending that over
if it's approved by the commissioner of
safety it comes back they take that
waiver that's been approved go to that
safety or that school bus inspection
station and when the inspectors going
down that list looking for all this
equipment when they get to something
missing if it's on that waiver they just
bypass it the one thing we will never
bypass especially with those smaller
Vehicles is when it comes to lettering
they all must still have at least a
magnet or something visible to 50 feet
or greater saying that this vehicle
stops for all railroad crossings because
a school bus of any size needs to do
that and the last thing someone wants is
a Dodge Caravan that doesn't look like a
school bus is to stop in the middle of
the road so that is a required uh
sticker but beyond that they might look
like Fast cab tax year they might just
you know you wouldn't know what the
school bus
I do have one other question we have a
number of Interstate school districts in
this in this in New Hampshire sir for
example Rivendell
um and Butler bus does take kids onto
both sides of the river whether it's to
the five CTE centers all the way from
Kanan up in Vermont down to Brattleboro
we have New Hampshire students attending
these centers
is in approving something like this in
New Hampshire and then that contracted
service is transporting into Vermont
does Vermont have a separate set of
statutes which we must comply with if
we're shipping students in that state
which we do every day sure so any
company we're willing to work for a
school in New Hampshire is mandated to
follow our rules under 259.96 so anybody
that's transporting for a New Hampshire
school regardless of what the end
destination is most of all New Hampshire
schools if you have an out-of-state
school coming into New Hampshire to drop
off they and they're not doing anything
for a New Hampshire school they're
Exempted they can't we don't have any
oversight or ability to enforce our
rules upon them uh so I don't know if
that answers your question
sort of we have a lot of our elementary
kids are going to school in Fairly
Vermont
so that's a situation which I would you
know want to make sure that we're we're
have them in safe Vehicles so if Vermont
is the school where the kids are going
and they just simply live in New
Hampshire and the bus from Vermont is
coming into New Hampshire or Butler bus
in New Hampshire is being paid by that
Vermont school to transport the New
Hampshire student then no we have no New
Hampshire oversight as far as that goes
because of that contracts with an
out-of-state school they must have a
contract a municipality New Hampshire so
if it was vice versa with a Vermont
school is or school this company is
coming and picking up a student and then
bringing them to a New Hampshire school
for a New Hampshire you know that's
where the funding for that bus is coming
from then yes even though they're out of
in the location of Vermont they are
required to comply with our rules in New
Hampshire thank you
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question and thank you for your
thorough job trying to keep children
safe
it sounds to me like if the bill
included a requirement for
compliance with the statutes you noted
the 259.96 and 259.96a
that it would meet the concerns that
you've cited but that it still would not
be a necessary Bill am I understanding
that correctly I can't speak to a
fullness I don't deal with the 376 laws
frequently the transportation Network
company if it does something for some or
or agency or organization to have it
listed as an option that they can do
this under 376. that's fine the concern
came with because again 39 259 96a is it
can never apply to a taxi company you
can never comply to a uber company and
the fact that it's mentioned in that
latter half of the bill almost makes
someone assume that they're putting it
into the same category and 259.96a is
completely outside the oversight of the
state even though that tiny little Dash
a it makes all the difference because
Dash a there they can do whatever they
want basically outside we can't do
anything about it 96 is what keeps them
in to our laws and oversight and rules
and regulation to make sure that they're
complying with the safest possible
Transportation so it's more of if it
made a reference to you know it must
comply with 259.96 and then I'll throw
another one at you just because it's a
sub RSA but it's 263.29 which is the
school bus certificate that's what the
drivers require to become a school bus
driver in New Hampshire so you have your
driver's license for the proper class
whatever size vehicle you're driving for
those smaller Vehicles just an operator
license but you also have to have that
second document which is what's issued
from the DMV that's your school bus
certificate it doesn't matter if you
have a CDL license and it says School
Bus endorsement on it you can't drive a
New Hampshire school bus without that
second document that we regulate and
that's only regulated under 259.96 and
263.29 the 1300 rules it's 96a forget it
all they don't need that document it's
gone they only need is that license for
what they're driving and we can get all
the complaints in the world that these
kids are being driven unsafely and I
can't do a thing about it under in my
office so
it's that's basically it so if there's a
cross reference making reference that if
this is all well and good and there's a
note in there saying yep they have but
they still need to comply with 259.96
and 263.29 I that should alleviate the
concern of the state with this bill
because like I said in the beginning
this is already something that can be
accomplished from my office's
perspective so thank you very much
represent Belcher quickly we have
somebody yes just one brief one
obviously I think in order to understand
the relatively any safety concerns that
exists we also need to understand the
efficacy of the current process
um so can you speak to do any knowledge
of Statistics or anything like that
involving incidents or injuries
involving school buses on a yearly basis
perhaps or anything like that
I actually can I can't write now because
I don't have it uh in front of me but I
did do a project similar to this about
the safety of school buses uh
specifically with uh seat belts and you
know the the desire to put seat belts on
buses and what the need for that is and
what the statistics showed and stuff
like that that's a close approx thing I
can show you
um but I can't provide it right now okay
I appreciate that so thank you are there
further questions
not seeing anything thank you very much
thank you thank you for the thorough
discussion very good Sergeant I'd make
on this one
no so we're going to close the hearing
that we have on 651 and we will get
ready for the next hearing which is 3
49.
okay we'll uh open up the hearing on
House Bill 349 relative to a special
purpose school district for Bridgewater
Hebron and Groton
and
um
will introduce the bill
foreign
representative cortelli and cordelli and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rick Ladd I'm representative
from Haverhill the Haverhill New
Hampshire not the Massachusetts
and representing a number of communities
around Haverhill as well today I'm here
to introduce uh the bill which we have
before you 349 this bill deals with uh
Bridgewater Hebron and Groton and talks
about discusses the possibility of a a
school district that would be formed I'm
not going to take a whole lot of time in
this presentation seeing I know we have
a crowd behind me that's probably most
likely wanting to talk on this
particular Bill however I did hand out
to you one sheet that I want you to be
aware of that back in 1997 this
legislature
provided and I'll read that language
that's on that front page there I don't
have the whole statue copied for you but
allows the establishment of a village
special Village District
for the towns of Hebron and Bridgewater
to construct own and maintain a public
school facility
so was this legislature that approved
this particular Community to have a
Village School
however
the legislature never authorized that
particular Community to be a school
district
the village now has constructed does
maintain and has a facility for
elementary students
It's a Wonderful it's a beautiful
facility
good property around it safe secure
modern the ability to add on to it if
necessary but at current time I don't
think that's necessary but if you we
extend it to a middle school it would
probably need some additional classrooms
which the the uh it's already built into
that current facility how to add on and
tag off the the structure and
infrastructure within the building so
looking at this school uh the district
that's uh possibly would happen here
there's a number of questions which we
want to look at what does this bill do
it provides Bridgewater Hebron and
Groton that already have in this school
to own and owned by the Bridgewater
Village district and by the way that
whole building is leased to the Newfound
school district for one dollar a year
and the responsibility for maintaining
that building is that a Bridgewater not
Newfound
and so the citizens of Bridgewater and
Hebron are are really maintaining and
operating that building
uh at their own expense not that of the
expense of the school district
how does the creation of the new school
district take place well this bill
stipulates that the three towns up gives
the towns up to three uh four years on
which to study and plan for the
potential of creating a new school
district it's not something by passing
this bill something automatically
happens
how will children be educated well the
students are currently educated in the
elementary school for the Elementary
grades and then they go to the
Newfoundland school district for the
middle school and the high school years
the intent of the the where the end zone
for this particular bill would be is
that the high school students upon
coming out of a middle school in
Bridgewater and a elementary school
would then be tuitioned and tuitioned
either to Newfound and that would be
negotiated or tuition to another school
that's nearby just a few short miles up
um going down what are the benefits of
creating this new school district well
it's basically going to give local
control to that local facility the new
school district also presents Revenue
opportunities to Newfoundland area
school district
if Newfound is willing to enter into a
fair tuition agreement it will have the
benefit of a revenue stream that will
allow it to move forward with its
desired capital projects and needs that
they may foresee using that tuition rate
that comes out of the possibly of a new
form District by the way this is a
highly unusual situation in our state I
believe the only one in the state where
the Village School is owned by The
Village not the that the Cooperative or
not the school administrative unit it's
owned by that Village
what problems does this bill solve it
allows a greater local focus on
educational quality and I believe this
is the whole intent of the bill
the intent of the bill is to have
achievement and growth of the students
the way those people in that Community
are looking to see that occur
by right-sizing the two resulting school
districts if this occurs it allows for
an equitable apportionment of District
operating costs in both districts it
pertains potentially will strengthen the
Newfound Area School District by
allowing for tuition Revenue as a
potential offset to taxes incurred by
the remaining towns
does this bill mean that we are
withdrawn from the Newfoundland area
school district we meaning the bridge
now uh Bridgewater in Hebron and Groton
no
the bill authorizes a unique opportunity
for the three towns to vote to create a
school district there's a long process
spelled out in this in this legislation
which would for afford this process to
begin
won't this bill require that we hire new
Administration not necessarily
other school districts have successfully
no get negotiated contacts with a
neighboring SAU to provide
superintendent Services if you also look
in statute there's another area within
statute which allows them to have a
principal slash administrator take on
the responsibilities of the
superintendent that's current statutory
law
foreign
detrimental to other Cooperative school
districts know this bill deals with a
very unique set of facts where the
students who comprise the district will
be educated in a school that is already
owned by the two or three towns through
the Bridgewater Hebron Village District
no other towns in New Hampshire have
such a situation and this bill does not
apply to any other Cooperative school
districts this bill has nothing to do
with Cooperative disillusionment has
nothing to do with apportionment as far
as you know how many votes once uh one's
district has first another District in
The Cooperative it has nothing to do
with all that statutory uh references
and issues we've discussed in past this
is a unique Bill associated with that
particular Village district and has
nothing to do it's tearing apart or
trying to shred our concept and
structure of Cooperative school
districts I won't talk anymore because
we have a boatload of people behind me
that want to talk about this and uh I
would be willing to take questions but I
prefer that you if you're looking for
issues such as Financial costs bonding
all that uh Transportation etc etc uh
you can ask those people that are
following up behind me
thank you thank you any questions
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman thank you for taking this uh
just two pots
in the legislation you're talking about
the three towns and the peace that you
gave us as the handle they talked about
the two is there any how does Groton get
in here in this I think that's a good
question the Groton has it's very small
and yes you're right Hebron and
Bridgewater are the folks that were
spelled out in that legislation back in
97 uh Groton is a community which would
be there in the garage relationship with
Bridgewater and and Hebron you should be
asked to the folks which are coming up
there's knowledgeable people that are on
the select boards School
Etc is sitting behind me in the the
follow-up thank you um how many students
are we talking about that's another good
question from
okay yeah I'm trying to get off the hook
here so they can get in because you're
going to get specifics behind
representative Damon rather than me
giving approximations I could give you
an approximation
thank you
I just want a clarification on the two
words special purpose
what that means it seems like the bill
reads so where it says relative to a
special purpose School District no it's
not it's not a special purpose School
District it's a municipal Village they
have their Commissioners they were but
they also own their building and they
raise the Monies to maintain and equip
that building
but they don't they're not school
districts so they can't go any further
than that
follow-up yes
so
special purpose bill this District on
line two of the first page but on the
front page it says special purpose
School District so that was my confusion
are you looking at which Roman numeral
so on
the face page
analysis
where it says an act relative to a
special purpose School District see this
act right here that you see it's a
combination of Exeter and others as well
so it's it's
no nothing else Omnibus bills that we
had as a house
or you're looking in the
the bill right there that would be a
good question for them when they come up
thank you yeah
see no further questions thank you thank
you very much
mm-hmm
I'm handing around is what was
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Terry Murphy and I
enthusiastically support
House Bill 349 built supporting me in
this process of selectman Mars genus and
Wesley Morrow I'm a select board member
from the town of Bridgewater swimming
since 1977. I'm also commissioner on the
Bridgewater heatman Village District
commission since its Inception in 1999.
I was a faculty member at Plymouth State
University for 45 years and its Outreach
programs over 10 years assisted the
pemmy baker school district for its
financial and student Management Systems
in full disclosure my spouse is Virginia
Barry former New Hampshire Commissioner
of Education
the Bridgewater Hebron Village district
is a separate political subdivision
created by Statute in 1997.
and is comprised of the towns of
Bridgewater and Hebron the statute
authorized both towns to build and
operate the Bridgewater heatman Village
School the three elected Commissioners
oversee the school facility and grounds
The Village District continues to own
debt-free the Bridgewater even Village
School building surrounding athletic
fields furnishings and you have a photo
of it it leases the school to the
Newfound area school district for a
dollar a year teachers staff curriculum
management are provided by the Newfound
Area School District the school was
built to alleviate overcrowding in sau4
Newfound Area School District at a
multi-million dose cost of the
Bridgewater in Hebron in 1999.
since then Bridgewater and Hebrew are
responsible for maintenance repair and
Capital Improvements Bridgewater and
Hebron students have been among the
minority in the schools enrolled in the
school children from other towns have
always been welcome to attend and do
this build is designed to expand in our
legal status as the villages we can
explore Over a four-year period they
established with a three-town special
purpose School District
this is a multi-price steps process the
first step is to hold a vote in
Bridgewater Hebron and Groton to
determine if the citizens want to
establish a K-8 SAU
our vision is to improve educational
outcomes for our children with an
Innovative alternative to traditional
Middle School our goal is to reconfigure
the Village School to a K-8 Studies have
shown that fewer number of transitions
children's make before high school the
greater the improved student performance
in fact all seven towns in pemi Baker
SAU 48 use the K-8 model
Hill New Hampshire also formed a
separate School District after
withdrawing from Franklin School
District they operate their own
Elementary School and tuition into the
new Pond area school for grades 7
through 12.
the Bridgewater even Village school
education performance has been
consistently performing in the top 20
percentile for the in the state for Math
and English reconfiguring
um to a K-8 allows us to continue our
proven how to prevent The Proven High
academic standards with a coherent
curriculum effective instruction
um strong leadership results-based
accountability and sound discipline
through the eighth grade it would allow
more effective local control better
managed educational costs and give
parents an Innovative alternative to
traditional Middle School today's
parents are becoming more engaged in the
educational outcomes for their children
there is a growing Trend towards
alternative education options and in our
local case a trend towards the public
a28 model given this bill given this
climate the bill gives us the authority
in this and the time to thoughtfully
think this through
we would seek to stay closely aligned
and work cooperatively with the Newfound
Area School District to support quality
education for the children
we would support space-based
reciprocity agreements for grades uh K-8
by inviting students from other towns to
intend we would offer parents a choice
between traditional middle school and a
k-28 program we would seek a Cooperative
relationship
this bill gives us an option to create
our own district and to reconfigure to a
k-28 we have four years to research and
determine if this is the best choice for
um
in the end our voters will decide House
Bill 349 provides a narrow singular fix
that would realign us with the state's
Publications a publication model this
bill is a turnkey solution that our
final education plan must be improved by
the Board of Education finally we as
citizens have a responsibility to
provide our children's public education
this bill provides that opportunity
thank you thank you now questions from
the committee
yes representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I just want to make clear that
um does this create another SAU a
um probably yes
ultimately it's gonna it's gonna emerge
something really special purpose that
was a term that spun off from the
original legislation ultimately what
we're doing is basically taking and
going to the next step to be able to be
thank you uh see no other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you did you mention this time yeah
um Gary riddle
and if I could just cast we have quite a
few cards up here so if you can limit
your testimony to three minutes
I'll try but I have a letter from um
Virginia Barry that is mainly what I'm
going to read and that is a little more
than three minutes so
but thank you for the opportunity to
speak and support of house bill 349. my
name is Jerry riddle I'm a resident of
Hebron I've been an elected commissioner
of the Bridgewater human Village
District since its Inception about 25
years ago
where I've had the privilege of being
part of the construction and management
of the facility of our local Bridgewater
Hebron Village School
I was the first president of the
Parent-Teacher Community organization
and a volunteer in various capacities at
this school plus others throughout the
new found area school district one of my
sons attended the Bridgewater hearing
school and recently my grandsons have
been students there
where they've thrived in a nurturing
atmosphere supporting Mike by caring
teachers staff parents and community
members
I've been on numerous committees
addressing public kindergarten
technology the vision and mission of the
school district the greenhouse at our
school
and the building and Facilities needs of
the Newfound area schools
with your support of House Bill 349 we
have a unique and exciting opportunity
to create a positive K-8 learning
environment for our local students Mr
chairman may I please use my remaining
time to read into the record a letter
from the former New Hampshire education
commissioner Virginia Berry who is
unable to attend today
dear chairman Ladd I strongly support
the establishment of a special purpose
School District as proposed by the towns
of Bridgewater Hebron and Groton
as the former Commissioner of education
for the State of New Hampshire from 2009
to 2017. I had the pleasure of visiting
many excellent schools in our state
New Hampshire has much to be proud of
with its continued ranking in the
nation's top five states for educational
success as commissioner I was often
asked to explain our success to the
public of course we have many
outstanding teachers and leaders
committed to our children families and
communities
however there is another critical factor
in our state's national achievements the
movement of school choice options
available to Children through bipartisan
leadership has helped Define our state
as one that supports parent choice New
Hampshire is one of the only states that
supports traditional Public Schools
public charter schools public magnet
schools private schools online academies
and homeschooling
all these choices are available to
families to choose what is the best
interest of their child's needs family
values and sustainable communities
New Hampshire places great value on our
small towns and their role in the
stability critical of the economic
health of our state our residents know
that our governmental structure cares
what they have to say Bridgewater human
and Groton have demonstrated their deep
Devotion to Quality education and the
desire to have a school that reflects an
understanding of the importance of
family values in their schools
a sense of Pride and conservation of
small town togetherness and daily life
the school of these community members
Envision is another example of choice in
our state with a serious commitment to a
sense of the future and everyday safety
and fellowship so needed in our society
perseverance is especially evident when
in 1999 the communities of Bridgewater
and Hebron joined to construct a modern
School building open to all towns in the
Newfound Area School District
the building was separate from their
existing Cooperative School District
obligations and since 2000 the towns
leased the facility the school district
for one dollar per year
the maintenance and building upgrade
costs are the sole responsibility of the
Bridgewater Hebron Village District
concurrently the facility is open to
many local agencies for community
activities to support extracurricular
Sports and boys and girls Community
clubs
the school presently houses a Pre-K
full-day kindergarten program and first
through fifth grades children from other
towns in The Cooperative School District
constitute 55 percent of the Bridgewater
Hebron School enrollment the proposed
legislation will not impact other
communities enrollment if the K-8
expansion is approved fiscal constraints
in the sau4 prevent the adoption of this
enhanced program configuration
Recent research on Pre-K and K-8 school
configuration has continued to grow
focusing on the importance of children's
social emotional needs in our current
Society intuitive leaders in our state
might consider looking at the multiple
benefits for K-8 students in the same
school setting the benefits include
improved student social emotional skills
positive attitudes about self and others
connections to school and town academic
performance and reduce conduct problems
and emotional distress
a school with community support and a
belief that citizens owned the school
with an intense commitment to success
and a healthy mindset is the best we can
offer our children
The Proposal seeks to promote a
community K-8 school to enhance learning
and social emotional competence based on
the three towns choices to support these
critical years of development a K-8
school program has proven to improve
academic performance and Greater
Community involvement when Parents
Choice is acknowledged
in closing this proposal supports the
spirit of New Hampshire's history
encouraging Choice community
connectedness and success for all
citizens I urge the house education
committee to consider this
forward-thinking proposal the potential
outcomes of success for the students and
recognition of the people's desire to
protect and educate their children only
strengthen our state thank you for this
opportunity to share my thoughts on this
worthy proposal despite the challenges
facing our nation I believe that New
Hampshire will continue to leave the
country in educational success and
promote and Safeguard our children and
communities respectfully submitted
Virginia M Barry PhD
thank you very much for your time
okay I'll take over but I don't ask any
questions or anything like that seeing
that you know I presented the bill are
there any questions from the committee
representative miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and sharing uh Dr Berry's uh
comment she was an outstanding
Commissioner of Education
the concern that I have is I'm a little
confused I understand the movement of
five to eight uh or Pre-K to eight
rather than Pre-K to five could you
outline for the committee what is the
current status
what it looks like and as you deal with
this proposal how would it change what
would it what would it look like
differently
well right now it's pre-k through five
and it would be I'm not sure Pre-K or k
through eight of course this has yet to
be determined this there's going to be
if this is passed then it will be looked
at very carefully as to how it is
exactly going to look going forward I
know that the facility though was built
to house a k through eight because I'm
on that committee
and we kept that in mind when we were
building that school thinking that a K-8
model would be great right now A K-8 is
not something that the Newfound area
school district is looking at doing so
that is one of the big reasons why we
want to do that ourselves
follow up please yes I guess my concern
is is that I don't know from an
administrative standpoint
how would it change I understand that
the children the students who currently
go six to eight obviously go to another
another area that I understand that but
I'm just how does what's the
administrative piece look like with this
proposal vis-a-vis what is the current
administrative structure
I'm I don't know that I can necessarily
answer that the best um it is I can tell
you that it's yet to be determined
exactly how that will look the options
need to be are the options are out there
and it needs to be looked at right now
that school is under the sau4 so the
superintendent of the entire School
District
um looks after that school and we have
our own principal at Bridgewater Hebron
Village school but how that exactly will
end up being is as far as I know you
have to be determined but others can
answer that better than than I can very
good so I hope somebody can answer my
question on that thank you very much
further questions
representative woodcock thank you
chairman good morning good morning just
a couple follow-ups I had to share all
that he said that someone would be
helping that would be you I guess
um just how many youngsters in the K-5
system now in your building and how many
edition of youngsters would be taking
from six to eight if you expand
I don't have those numbers in front of
me I wish I could tell you that but
and man
and so what I'll read it that way what
was six to eight look like
well anymore
thank you both
thank you thank you uh if anybody has
written testimony too yeah we'll get
more questions but if you have written
testimony if could you submit it to the
clerk so we can make it part of the
representative Tanner
thank you I just was wondering how many
elementary schools are in the uh SAU for
currently there are four is that correct
yes including Bridgewater human Village
School thank you we have the
superintendent well here we'll get that
further questions thank you very much
thank you very much I appreciate it
welcome again good morning and uh thank
you for allowing me to speak I'm going
to speak against the bill today
um so I just want to first uh
representative lad you and it's been
mentioned a couple times that the
village district is responsible for all
of the maintenance of that building
that's not true it's shared uh the
village District takes care of the
larger items like recently they put a
new roof on the building things like
that but we hire the custodial staff and
we maintain it that way we clean the
building it's a shared class it's not
fully
um funded by The Village District so
first uh to speak to what is obvious to
me about one of the troubling spots of
this house bill is to me it looks like
it's going to set a precedent and it's
going to circumvent
um RSA 195 which we already have in
place uh to allow towns to explore the
possibility of withdrawal from from
Cooperative districts
um this
um this was already done once in 2014
with Bridgewater and Hebron and they
they followed the RSA 195 and it was
determined at the end of the study to
remain in the district
Bridgewater Hebron and Groton have been
part of the Newfound area school
district for over 60 years
collectively they have about 15 percent
of the students that attend our schools
people should remember that the
Cooperative District was formed to
create efficiencies that all seven
pounds and those students would benefit
from and to provide greater educational
opportunities for their students so this
is clear clearly the point of
Cooperative districts across the whole
states students from the small towns
have much more to gain than students
from the large towns because they're
able to attend schools in in a larger
setting a larger high school because
they they belong to the Cooperative
District they that they would otherwise
not benefit from and with those larger
schools comes greater programming the
students benefited tremendously by being
part of Newfoundland they've attended
larger schools they've been able to
access academic programs Athletics and
co-curricular programs that they would
not have been able to access if they
weren't proud of the Cooperative
District these programs and efficiencies
have been guaranteed if if these three
towns leave the Newfound school district
those students may lose that guarantee
to have that access when your part when
you're locked into a Cooperative
District you have those those guarantees
there's a risk here as the Newfound area
school district is planning their future
we now have an architectural study and a
building committee that are looking at
three of our elementary schools that are
aging and need either to be replaced or
to be renovated so as this would leave
if this bill was passed it would leave
that Committee in a really difficult
position how do we plan going forward
not knowing if there's a four-year
process as described today for the
um for this group to study that
personally I'm frustrated that the house
bill was written in isolation
we just it just appeared to us it was
never
discussed or presented at a school board
meeting I attended several meetings
throughout the summer on the funding
formula with Mr Murphy and Mr Piper
who's here today and neither of them
mentioned it to me and that that is
troubling that we could have been part
of the process
um some of the things that have been
shared as supporting documents for this
house bill include negative uh comments
about Middle School our Middle School is
doing great I mean that was a a
narrative that was in place in 2014.
that's really old news we our middle
school has new leadership and they're
um performing at or above the state
average the district has also made huge
investments into that building
putting in a new uh state-of-the-art
HVAC system and LED lighting recently
and we have a facilities committee
that's continually looking at improving
that facility there was in the
supporting documents speaks about one
the fear of losing or change of funding
formula within the district that issue
was resolved last year with a petition
Warren article which was modified to
form a study committee and we spent the
summer and some of these people behind
me were on that committee and it was
found that we weren't going to change
the funding formula so I I don't see
that as a fear
um if so currently there was a question
about the enrollment uh currently at
Bridgewater Hebron we have on our books
as a 121 students
Alexandria or Bristol so if this house
bill was the past and Newfound Area
School District could pull those
students back into our own buildings
that would be a 35 percent decrease in
enrollment and put you about 77 students
also as part of our planning for our
district moving forward we've haven't
had an enrollment study by the New
England Council of school development
and they're predicting a 12 decrease in
enrollment in the next 10 years so based
on those declining numbers it's really
high to imagine that adding more grades
to one of our smaller schools really
makes sense
um
let me see that's all I have to say a
little bit of that thank you very much
superintendent are there any questions
from the committee representative Tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question so there's there's four
elementary schools in the district
including the Village School
um if they
they all follow
um a lot of the same guidelines as far
as curriculum and uh we are all yes we
uh before elementary schools use all the
same curriculum and assessment tools I
mean essentially when it comes to
instruction they're essentially like one
school and and as a follow-up and you've
uh hire all the employees for for all
four elementary schools at this point
that's correct everybody that works in
that building from custodial staff all
the way up through the teachers and
administrator our Newfound
um employees thank you representative
cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
superintendent for being here
um you talked about the projected
enrollment decline do you have any idea
um what this school the high school
capacity is right now in terms of space
utilization at the high school yeah it
was built for about 500 students and
currently we have about 380 okay thank
you follow up yes
um
uh you talked about the four-year window
also
um and I understand from previous
testimony that
um if this four-year uh
planning period results in a new school
district
um they would be looking to tuition
students
um to back to Newfound or to Plymouth or
some other place would Newfound be open
with especially with the declining
enrollment and excess capacity uh be
looking to accept
students from the new District as
tuition students well that would be a
school board decision not my decision I
mean I can tell you that there's a lot
of frustration with the other towns
about this house bill and you know the
feeling like you know they're not we're
not good enough for them now why would
we accept them back type of thing but
that would be really up to the school
board to decide and in the matter of if
it came down to three or four years how
would um it could be an entirely
different you know school board at that
point but so it's really hard to tell
but it really puts us uh the building
Committee in a difficult position as we
move forward and make plans trying to
decide whether Bridgewater Hebron and
glottner with Newfound or not
thank you further questions from the
committee representative woodcock
thank you chairman come on
superintendent welcome
um I have two two questions that they're
distinctly different uh just at the
onset of your discussion you indicated I
think he said it was determinist that
the conclusion one is determined to stay
it's not of the district the study that
we're done right
it determined the state is part of the
district right that was in 2014 okay my
question is by whom
they formed the committee which is
required by the irsa and I think some of
the people sitting behind me weren't
part of that committee I saw the
documents and markets this one and made
the second part yes go ahead thank you
um is the pay scale for the teachers and
the Four elementary school districts all
the same yes thank you thank you Mr
further questions representative miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here I'll ask you the
administrative question how do you see
from your perspective the administration
of this particular proposal vis-a-vis
what is currently there
well uh they would so if they succeeded
and and formed their own District they
would need a principal which they are
you know we already have that we pay we
pay for 2.6 million dollars every year
for the budget for that school Newfound
does for Staffing it and maintaining it
so they would need a principal and
certainly one principle would be capable
of a k to eight but as you know
um the school the school would be
required to have
um to acquire superintendent services so
they would either have to hire a
full-time superintendent or find some
other way to to fulfill those services
follow up yes uh then other services
that are currently provided by the SIU
would they continue to do that to this
new this new entity well that would be
up to the to the school board to decide
that
that's not a guarantee thank you
further questions from Europe
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you who who makes up the school board
how is that divided up uh the the school
board is has one representative from
further questions
uh next person is which will is this the
topic sir
foreign
Mr chairman and committee members my
name is John messino I'm the chair of
the slight Board of town of Groton I'm
here to speak enthusiastically about the
bill today
with me is my fellow selectman Tony
Albert we represent a town of 569
residents
Quran is a small tight-knit rural
community
up roughly over 40 40 square miles and
extremely and we're at the extreme
Northern end of the seven Town
Newfoundland School District
we're situated between Romney and he uh
Romney and Hebron
and just about equal distance from the
two large school districts located in
Bristol and Plymouth
we have 48 students enrolled in Newfound
School District K-12
2 of those students attend the
exceptional K-5 Bridgewater Hebron
Village District school
The Village school education performance
is outstanding ranked among the top in
the state through K-5
the teachers and staff are excellent and
the kids thrive in that school
parent involvement is high
and across the entire system
our kids and students love that school
I'm very excited about this bill and
feel it will set their children up for
continued success as a father myself I
understand the importance of stability
in the educational system
establishing a three-school district and
will will create a more effective
control over the school system
a stronger tight link between the
parents and schools
less transition for the children
and expand the Village Schools
successful proven educational model for
an additional three years up to grade
eight our parents are becoming more
involved in education of our children
and as you know there's a growing Trend
towards public education Alternatives in
our case the trend is the public K-8
school
smaller is also better we're situated at
the far end of the largest school
district our kids spend several hours on
the school bus each day and as they
drive past the Village School on their
way to the Middle School
establishing a three-town school
district and reconfiguring it to three
through k-8 will help alleviate that
challenge for our children
I also support this bill because it
gives us four years to thoroughly engage
our citizens and thoughtfully think
through the reconfiguration
I seriously take responsibility to
provide the best public education for
our children this bill is unique
Innovative and an Innovative opportunity
to do just that thank you for listening
thank you questions represent paternal
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm not sure if
you're the correct person to ask this
but I'm wondering what some of the
benefits of K through 8 as opposed to K
through five might be because that seems
to be a significant change from what the
school is currently there's two things
one
the school is doing exceptional as far
as the testing so it enhances it gives
them another three years for just that
and also our children do spend several
hours on the bus because that only goes
to grade five so it's three years that
they're going to middle school
um it'll help
them spend more time in the school less
time in the bus
and it also there's less transition for
the students so they'll have more time
with stability being in that same school
for an additional three years I think
they'll greatly benefit from from those
things
further questions representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I'm sure you've probably studied the
financial part of this but I'm I'm
wondering what it actually does to the
to the tax rate
um in in particular your town will make
a difference one way or the other and
also the increased costs for the
uh and narrow's Nation Eric can speak
better to that but um this is not about
uh lowering taxes or anything that's
strictly about the education for those
students and making sure that they
succeed in in life
not seeing thank you very much thank you
well thank you for having me and uh I
want to say I have great respect for the
process here and I'm interested in in
participating I was on the 2014 study
group if that helps
I don't have that in my presentation but
I'm happy to answer questions
um I'm here to represent the town of
Hebron I've been a select board member
for 10 years I have two other members
with me in the back Rich James on this
side and Paul Hazelton here
uh the town of Hebron and the select
board we support this bill
uh personally myself I want to State I
grew up in a low-income household my dad
was a pow and a fully disabled veteran I
lived in public housing and attended
Public Schools so I'm a strong advocate
for public schools and consider
education provided critical to the sex
success of the students our state in in
the entire nation in fact
my public education public school
education got me a scholarship to
Northeastern University where I
graduated with honors and after military
service I completed a master's degree at
Babson College
uh for the past 20 years I've been a
trustee for the Mayhew program I hope
you've heard of Mayhew it's an important
non-profit we serve disadvantaged youth
in the state ours is actually a boys
program I'm now the treasurer of the
Mayhew program so I work on a daily
basis on Youth Development in the state
of New Hampshire
the people of Hebron are aware of this
proposed legislation and are in favor
the people of Bridgewater and Hebron
paid for the school and maintain it on
an annual basis and we have great pride
in the school it's important part of the
community I'll stop for a second because
you mentioned Groton and I want to say
Groton children as you heard
attend our school K-5 now they don't
participate in the funding and we don't
ask them to for any funding and I'll
just tell you we would never leave out
the children abroad they will always be
included we share ambulance and fire
service with Groton on a Cooperative
basis I mean there are neighbors are
friends and they are part of the
equation here
um
the school is an important part of the
community as I said it's also our
emergency shelter I think which should
be mentioned are police protected our
police do the safety checks they run the
bike safety program we provide these
services along with the athletic appeals
without any outside financial support
the townspeople understand this proposal
to establish our own school district and
reconfigure the K-8 will require
additional costs this question has been
asked a couple of times what we've told
our citizens is it will probably cost
more money but they still support it and
I think it will be important for
education
we're fully intend to form a Cooperative
relationship with sau4 for high school
sports and activities
our only goal is to improve public
education for the children in more local
control
I want to comment and I heard what the
superintendent said he came and spoke to
our select wood and I have great respect
for everything they do at the SAU but
our SAU is
almost 300 square miles I believe it's
the second largest in the state
um
and seven towns it's very difficult to
manage I think as you heard the
superintendent say to move the children
and balance classrooms and size and age
it's very difficult for them I think
this would
help him do that The Far Side of Groton
measure her it is more than an hour's
drive from the other schools in our
district our three towns are North
on the North End we border more Plymouth
Dorchester Romney if you're familiar
with central New Hampshire then Bristol
and I bring up the example of Route 104
which runs from Danbury
to Meredith actually and passes through
virtually right through the other four
towns in the district so it's a state
road maintained all the other schools
actually sit on 104. and so the ability
to move students as the superintendent
said and they have a study group and
their approach which he told us is
probably to consolidate an elementary
school
somewhere convenient in the district and
I just look at the geography for a
minute and think that that 104 Corridor
is a perfect perfect place for that but
we lay to the north of that and Groton
farther to the north so I think that
this proposal will actually work well to
to make it stronger and better and less
expensive
um I just want to finally say our goal
is to improve educational outcomes for
the children the bill allows for greater
local forces and quality and establish
the three-town school district and
reconfigure the K to Aid allows parents
a choice between a traditional middle
school and a K-8 program I hope you're
in favor I just want to say one thing
when you heard about the distance the
students have to travel I have to think
about the parents who have to care for
the kids after 2 30 after three o'clock
and the school is an hour away that's
one way so two hour ride to provide for
students or daycare or take care of them
after school hours is is difficult in
our area so thank you for listening
thank you very much other questions
represent Tanner thank you I'm I'm thank
you for taking my question I'm still
kind of confused about the funding do
you have
a separate funding
within the Bridgewater
um
Hebron district is there a separate tax
for that particular school and an
additional tax that you pay to the
Newfound Cooperative district is that
what's happening yes correct and and
how's that going to change
well we'll be funding
one school rather than contributing to a
district we'd continue to maintain the
school
I think but with them we'd have to
find access for high school and we
assume we'd pay tuition to the high
school some may prefer Plymouth to the
north all the Plymouth School District I
should add is K to eight and each town
has their own school board so as you go
further north I think and the area
becomes more Rural and travel is
difficult I just want to point out the
district next to us in Plymouth already
operates on a K-8 model so we would
tuition students I mean our approach
from the select board in the town is to
work as cooperatively with sau4 as we
possibly can
go ahead so on Transportation do you pay
for the transportation or does the
Cooperative District Newfound have the
contract with the buses currently they
pay for it okay thank you but you think
we're the furthest ones out so we're
probably the highest cost the other
towns lay conveniently I think right
along 104 and I think their ability to
move children would would be a big
advantage
further questions representative Damon
thank you Mr chair I have two unrelated
questions
I believe you said you were on the 2014
study committee for a similar endeavor
yeah if that's correct similar is okay
word yeah could you reflect on what is
different now from then that brings
something similar back before the
townspeople and before us
um well that was unsuccessful we'd like
to be successful we still would like to
have the
we'd like to have the K-8 model I mean I
was on the committee
I learned a lot
I think it was flawed in some ways the
the SAU wasn't cooperative
we tried to for example negotiate on a
price for tuition in and out and they
told us they would not
speaking honestly here and Pierre was
not part of it
um they would not discuss tuition in
high school students
at that same time they were in
negotiation with Hill and completed a
negotiation to bring the who Hill
students into their High School
so I I felt that was disingenuous to be
honest because they said no we don't
we're not going to talk about tuition at
the same time they were holding meetings
with Hill and they have since moved the
hill students into the high school so we
were unsuccessful
as I said we tried the process
that was a failure I think if we tried
it again we'd probably be unsuccessful
the Voting is balanced against us
there's four towns maybe on one side and
three towns and the other Groton did not
participate in the prior a 2014 study so
we basically railroaded
thank you for the questions
I had another one go ahead thank you
um
break cramp now I can't remember what
the other one was oh
has this current effort
talked with Plymouth about their
receptiveness to tuition students I have
not participated in that I did in 2014
and they were receptive
they also as the kids get older whatever
they have excess capacity as you heard
the superintendent says he has excess
capacity in his high school so and I
know the hill students got a have a what
I would consider a favorable
favorable tuition rate into Newfound
they pay less per student than we do as
a town for example so I think Plymouth
would be receptive to it and for Groton
students and maybe Hebron were on the
North side that would be really
important to students and parents
thanks very much any further questions
thank you very much all right thank you
is represent Carol Brown here
let's see it is here thank you to ours
and two L's like Archie Bunker Carol
O'Connor
uh representative Carol Brown Graft in
District 10 so I have Bristol and
Bridgewater in my District
representative sellers is also here in
the back who also has a number of these
talents and more of his towns uh in his
district
uh I hadn't prepared any statement and I
thought it would be worth my bringing
your attention to something I think is
part of this conversation
and for those constituents behind me who
who wish I weren't saying this please
talk to me later
um
I am this is I'm not speaking for or
against this I'm hoping to provide you
just a little bit more information
um I'm not disputing anything that's
been said there's been a lot of great
things said it's it's it's compelling
testimony from the people behind me to
move ahead with us
and and I'm not disputing that in any
way
one of the things I think that is
important for the committee to
understand here from completeness
is and this may go to your question I'm
sure someone behind me could
correct it or dispute it there has been
an ongoing conversation in the school
district about changing the funding
formula for the district
it has been extremely contentious
it's been going on for a number of years
in
the past year there was a committee
formed with representatives from each of
the towns to have a conversation about
this funding formula in the district
um it was so it was contentious enough
to the point where there was yelling and
swearing at a number of these meetings
or at least one
um it's it's a big issue
there are those that believe the funding
formulas will be changed and and I will
I
I will
um ask if anyone else in behind me has
they have much more specific information
if the funding formula there are those
who believe the funding formula should
be changed
to include more property valuation and
this is a very simple explanation of
this if that were to occur the towns are
Bridgewater and Hebron and Groton who
would pay a significantly larger amount
into the school district than they are
now
I'm I'm a little
disappointed that no one has said that I
don't again I do not dispute anything
that's been said to this point I think
for completeness for you all to know
that that is a piece of this if you go
downtown uh if you go downtown in
Bristol have a cup of coffee and we talk
about this topic there's no question
that that piece of the funding is going
to come up that this is part of the
conversation
so I that's
um and for those behind me again I have
a number of people I know back here and
a number of constituents that I don't
know back here and I'm sure I will have
to the end of this meeting and that
would be great
um I thought it was important to bring
that little piece to your attention that
you did hear the superintendent if you
caught it he did say that there was some
funding discussions and at this point
there was no plan to change that funding
mechanism
um uh and that was due to this
commission this committee that was
formed over the past year they sent out
a report that said this is what we
discovered and there was no decision to
make a change to that so I it's um I
probably can't answer specific questions
about the funding but I thought it was
an important piece of this puzzle for
you all to know so thank you thank you
very much representative Brown
um represent cardelli uh thank you Mr
chairman um thank you representative for
being here
um uh in terms of the funding formula
and the area agreement
um
um the articles of green I mean
um it's my understanding that some
articles of agreement for some co-ops
include a provision so that if the
funding is formula and funding formula
has changed it allows towns to withdraw
um do you know if there's anything
provision like that in
um this SAU or articles of agreement no
I don't know that I'm sure that uh the
select board member Murphy and or the
superintendent have that answer about
the tip of their tongue but I don't know
that personally thank you
thank you further questions
[Music]
good morning
members of the committee thank you for
listening today to testimony
my name is Jennifer lower shell and I am
here to testify in support of house bill
349.
I graduated from the University of New
Hampshire with the BA in psychology
followed by a master's in reading and
writing I have a certificate of advanced
graduate study from New England College
in educational leadership and I taught
for 25 years in the new found Area
School District
I'm a Hebron resident and my son
attended the Bridgewater Hebron Village
School
I'm here today to talk
about children and families
in my years in the classroom I've seen
tremendous changes in children families
and Society
the impact that comes from those changes
has affected our children in ways that
are sometimes visible
and sometimes not
even prior to the pandemic our children
were struggling
the CDC reports from 2016 to 2020
5.8 million students were diagnosed with
anxiety and 2.7 million were diagnosed
with depression
research suggests that the K-8 model
helps to combat those struggles our
children face
message of this bill is critical to our
vision for our students
think back
acne awkwardness hormones
sixth graders are vulnerable
switching schools at sixth grade
increases Stress and Anxiety
having served on transition teams from
fifth to sixth grade I can assure you
there are students who believe older
students will stuff them in lockers
it's a reality our children face
the K-8 model offers no such transition
instead children remain in a nurturing
familiar environment where they can
continue to grow both academically and
socially
warranted or not
Middle School does not have a great
reputation
and it's often a reputation that keeps
parents away
parents are important to their
children's education
Purdue University rights when parents
are involved students get better grades
and score higher on standardized tests
what's more children of involved parents
have better attendance records drop out
less often have higher aspirations and
more positive attitudes toward school
and homework
fewer transitions for students and
continued parental involvement indicate
to me that the K-8 model is good for our
children and our families
that same familiar nurturing environment
that supports our students supports our
families
the Bridgewater Hebron school has a
20-year history of providing strong
educational opportunities for students
and strong parental Community
involvement
House Bill 349 grants us the opportunity
to continue that tradition for our
community and our families through
eighth grade
I ask that you help us guide our
students by supporting this Bill thank
you thank you very much other questions
yes representative
accordion I thank you for taking my
question
um everyone keeps referring to this K to
eight model and it sounds like you've
done a bit of research
uh I uh I know that Catholic schools
have predominantly followed that model
so I wonder if in your research you have
read anything about that and the
benefits uh you know the benefits from
that because if you know that is their
structure but I did not come across any
of that in my research
thank you further questions
thank you very much
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members
um my name is Bill Ludy I'm a retired uh
career naval officer and I'm now living
in Hebron and I too support this bill I
grew up right here in Concord where my
father was a teacher and running coach
at Concord High School
I attended Bishop Brady High School here
in Concord
um a very long time ago
where for the past five years I've
served on the school's academic advisory
Council and two years as chairman I
volunteer my time in our local drug
community drug prevention Community with
my uh in with my town selectman on
education issues and I'm a member of the
state's veterans advisory Council the
Bridgewater Hebron Village District
Commissioners asked their legal advisor
for or an opinion on whether HB 349
constitutes a lawful Act of the
legislature and I've been asked by the
Commissioners who have spoken here today
to read the brief letter into the record
Mr chairman if if that's appropriate
okay and I have 20 copies of the legal
opinion here that I will make available
to the members after this hearing I'm
not an attorney so if you have questions
I'd be happy to collect them and ask the
legal advisor to provide written answers
and this is from the Wadley star and
Peter's Law Firm in
Manchester Dear Mr Murphy you asked us
to review House Bill 349 and act
relative to special purpose school
district for Bridgewater Hebron in
Groton and in particular you have asked
us to opine whether the bill constitutes
a lawful Act of the legislature
in our opinion the answer is yes and we
reach that opinion for the following
reasons number one
the legislature retains the authority
over the formulation of public school
districts
New Hampshire is a not a home rule state
moreover while school districts are a
separate corporate entity they serve as
a subdivision of the state
as a result the legislature has
exercised its authority over the span of
its history to create school districts
through enabling legislation
in the past 30 years the legislature has
self-regulated that authority to create
and establish school districts by
voluntarily subordinating its authority
to local control
in other words the legislature has
passed enabling legislation
but has made the adoption of such such
subject to the will of the citizens in
the local towns
cities or school districts
for example recently the legislature
adopted a bill with regard to the
Manchester School District
authorizing certain Charter amendments
and the establishment of further
Independence on the part of the school
district however that legislation was
contingent upon adoption by the local
legislative body
this bill follows that model and if
passed is a lawful exercise of the
general Court's legislative Authority
but with due deference to the local
decision of the voters
number two
the bill repairs a unique flaw in The
Cooperative withdrawal statutes
in this case the Bridgewater Hebron
Village District owns the school
attended by the students in the
Bridgewater Hebron Groton area
this is a truly unique fact which
deviates substantially from the norm
the adoption of this bill provides a
pathway for the Bridgewater Hebron
Groton towns to normalize the
relationship with the village district
and create their own District which more
aligns with the fact that the ownership
of the building in which the children
are educated reposes within the local
community
the general court is well aware of the
challenges presented by the withdrawal
provisions of a Cooperative school
districts
while one can argue on either side of
the issue in regard to the correct
manner in which to approach withdrawal
on these facts there is little or no
doubt that the local Act of the
legislature will provide an opportunity
to cure a model which deviates from the
norm
number three as a local act this bill
does not modify the general Provisions
pertaining to other Cooperative school
districts
at first blush there may be reluctance
on the part of some to adopt this bill
due to the fact that it creates a more
nuanced withdrawal process however this
bill applies to a local situation where
a separate municipality owns the
building in which the children are
educated it is not capable of repetition
and represents a truly unique set of
facts for the reason set forth above it
is our opinion that this local
legislation is consistent with the
legislators Authority very truly yours
Dean B Eggert
and I have copies here that I can thank
you provide yeah
are there questions from the committee
to Mr Ludy
good not a lawyer well just pass it
thank you very much
thank you for hearing my testimony
honorable members of the committee and
fellow citizens thank you for this
opportunity today
my name is Thomas Curran I'm a resident
of Bridgewater New Hampshire I wish to
testify enthusiastically in support of
House Bill 349 and act to support a
special purpose school district for
Bridgewater Hebron and Grand
in 1972 I began working as a guidance
professional assigned by the
Dartmouth-Hitchcock Mental Health Center
to work with parents and children in the
Mascoma School District
later I went on to become the family
treatment specialist at Spalding Youth
Center in Tilton
in those roles I work extensively in
schools and homes with parents of
special needs children particularly
those with behavioral challenges
later I was appointed as vice president
of the crotchet Mountain Foundation
where my responsibilities included
Admissions and discharge planning for
students and their families
in scores of districts throughout the
state and the New England region I I was
on the road about 50 000 miles a year
visiting the districts and parents
I had that position for eight years
after which I was asked to join the
board of the trustees of that
organization
I've lived in the Newfound region since
1975 and my daughter graduated from the
Regional District High School
in the late 1990s I was elected to serve
as a member of the Bridgewater Board of
Selectmen that worked to create gain
approval and fund the Hebron Bridgewater
Village School District so I was in at
the at the ground floor of the uh of
this effort
my support of HB 349 stems from my
experience as a parent and educator a
selectman and most recently as a town
moderator
as an education professional I became
aware of a number of difficulties
confronting children throughout the
state the first of the challenges
involved in unreasonably lengthy
commutes that came to be measured in
hours spent by children in school buses
many of the behavioral problems we
frankly learned we had their initiative
or started on buses that's a part of the
um
children's lives it's unmonitored and
sometimes open season for the younger
kids
additionally as a parent from a
developmental standpoint I was concerned
about exposing Elementary age children
to troubling teenage social and
behavioral patterns the sort of burdens
and dynamics that the youngsters are
ill-prepared to handle the mix there the
difference between a sixth grader and a
ninth grader is enormous developmentally
the younger kids don't have the impulse
control don't have the capacity to
resist temptation think out the
consequences of behaviors and a lot of
those kids at that age end up heading
for the rocks and never getting off them
when I wrote the town history oh finally
as an elected official I've heard
repeated expressions of frustration on
the part of citizens who felt a lack of
connection with far-flung school
districts
when I wrote the town history of
Bridgewater in 1987 Old-Timers spoke
with a deep sense of loss that occurred
when local children were removed from
the town
a general sense of loss of control of
the schools on the part of the small
towns that are de facto outvoted by the
large towns is
um is a source of a lot of frustration
was
in my estimation of basic duty of rural
education is to assure that the
legitimate organizational needs of Lodge
districts do not override the core
mission of providing a nurturing love of
learning in children at the local human
level
it was for that reason including the
prospect of increased volunteer
involvement in the local school district
that we put forth the effort to create
the Hebron Bridgewater Village District
more than two decades ago
the results in the ensuing years I
believe have proven out the hope for
strengths of this logical and local
approach
children parents and Educators have
consistently expressed their
satisfaction and their pride in this
model and test scores have worn this out
over the years
focusing developmentally on the needs of
younger children is a major strength of
the K through a calimentary model
The Village district is a sensible
tradition-based innovation
that we feel has amplearned the support
of this enabling legislation
thank you for your consideration thank
you very much other questions
represent Damon yeah
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
I think you've answered a question that
I've been thinking through here it's not
that there would be fewer transitions
for the students but that the timing of
the transition would be more
developmentally appropriate that's right
correct that's right and the
surroundings would be familiar
they're going through so many hormonal
changes anyway having the same physical
space and the same human connections of
the counseling role of a teacher is
really important
[Music]
further
questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you all
for the committee we have about 14 more
minutes of testimony and then we've done
these cards so we can wrap that up right
now uh Eric Piper
foreign
my name is Eric Piper and I'm the
elected budget committee representative
from Bridgewater for the sau4 I've
completed four budget Cycles uh on the
committee I have two years remaining on
my current term in my professional life
I have a master's in finance and I've
spent the last 30 years in budgeting and
profit Center management for Fortune 500
companies
I support this bill because I believe it
brings some Innovative educational
options to the entire Newfound area and
it can do so in a real cost effective
manner
considering the creation of a new school
district presents overall Revenue
opportunities for the Newfound District
the sau4 and as outlined in the bill if
the district is willing to enter into a
fair tuition and administrative service
agreement it will have the benefit of a
revenue stream for ongoing capital
projects and something that we haven't
discussed today is we believe that we
will have the capacity particularly if
we add an additional four classrooms
um for K-8 reciprocity so we would bring
Innovative schooling options to the
entire region as opposed to just the
three towns
the current student count of Bridgewater
Hebron Groton is roughly 15 percent of
the overall SAU as was previously
mentioned our corresponding budget
contribution is about 16 percent of the
total budget
when I run the numbers and I estimate
the reduction in the elementary and
middle school expenses coupled with
potential SAU 4 gains in tuition and
administrative service Revenue
there'd be little to no fiscal impact to
the current District
the bill should also not adversely
affect District jobs or teachers if
anything this bill should create jobs
not reduce them an expanded Bridgewater
heben Groton School will need to hire
several additional teachers for the
sixth through eighth grades the
legislation also contains a provision
offering current teachers and staff a
transfer of pay benefits and pension
again tuition and service contracts
should support the current Staffing
levels at sau4
I envisioned that one of those tuition
agreements would also provide for sports
and extracurricular activities
specifically for the grade six through
eight which is a critical component of
modern education
establishing our own school district and
reconfiguring the K-8 will come at a
cost to Startup costs for us
we anticipate the construction of
additional classrooms for K-8 hiring
teachers support staff and of course the
cost of the tuition agreements and the
administration and extracurricular
agreements
these all come with the attendant
startup costs which we're well aware of
the infrastructure for providing the
local elementary education is already in
place we own the building the athletic
Foods fields and fortuitously we plan
for additional
um
future expansion so we'll simply shift
those operational costs
there are many components to running a
school districts we've operated and
maintained our school probably about 90
percent of the uh the ongoing costs for
22 years
many of our citizens have been involved
at multiple levels in the school
district from school board and budget
committee members to teachers and staff
you've heard some of them today
including a former New Hampshire
Commissioner of Education we have a very
deep pool of resources and experience to
draw from
outsourced functions that would require
special expertise or need economies of
scale the overall intent of the bill is
to provide the same or expanded
opportunities
with tuition agreements with a larger
District if required
this process needs to be thoughtful and
considered that's why the bill contains
a four-year planning and review
provision we don't have all the answers
right now we'd like to explore them in
the end the voters will decide again our
situation is unique no other town has a
similar structure we're dealing with a
set of circumstances where the students
of Bridgewater Hebron and Groton will be
educated in a school that's already
owned by two of our towns
finally this bill will increase
educational opportunities for parents in
the entire area and ensure elementary
and middle school education that is
local and locally controlled overall it
allows for a greater focus on
educational outcomes thank you thank you
very much are there questions for our Mr
Piper
thank you
good morning good morning my name is
Tracy steenbergen and I have always
lived in Hebron I have been involved in
hebron's town government for 32 years as
Town Treasurer the town's bookkeeper and
now his town clerk
more importantly I'm here today not as a
town official but as a grandmother
helping to raise her nine-year-old
grandson
my grandson Benjamin came to live with
my husband and me in April of 2022.
Ben's mother my son's former partner was
experiencing a family crisis
due to the shortage of affordable
housing Ben's mother has been unable to
locate permanent housing
my husband and I offered to have Ben
live with us Ben attended summer school
at the Bridgewater Hebron Village School
last July and August and was enrolled in
third grade there at the beginning of
the school year
Ben has some learning disabilities
particularly reading and has been
diagnosed with autism
before he came to live with us Ben was
enrolled in a larger School District in
the southern part of the state and had
never been in a mainstream classroom
at the Bridgewater Hebron Village School
Ben is in a third grade classroom with
his peers and is thriving in the small
classroom setting in large classroom
situations Ben is overwhelmed and
confused by all the stimulation Ben
would benefit enormously by being able
to remain in a small classroom setting
for as long as he possibly can he has
gained a strong awareness of school
community and the feeling of belonging
being at the Bridgewater Hebron Village
School in fact he received a growth
mindset award last fall and was so proud
when he brought that award home to show
everyone
the adage it takes a village to raise a
child is true
the small school Village environment
within the Bridgewater Hebron Village
district has helped Benjamin by
providing him with the education he
needs in a warm nurturing and Village
environment I asked the committee to
help Benjamin and others to continue to
grow emotionally and academically in
this small setting for as long as they
can by allowing Bridgewater Hebron and
Groton to form our own school district
and reconfigure our schools to a K-8
model thank you to the committee for
listening to my testimony for conducting
this hearing and considering Bridgewater
Hebron and groton's request thank you
very much are there any questions
thank you very much grandparent to
grandparent who has a child in the house
it's taken a lot of I'm getting up and
getting him on the school bus in the
good morning or almost afternoon my name
is Sarah Smith I'm a Groton resident I
work for the town of Groton but more
importantly I'm here to speak as a
parent I fully support house bill 349.
my son Caleb attended Bridgewater Hebron
Village School Newfound Memorial Middle
School and Newfound Regional High School
he actually graduated in 2022. prior to
attending the Newfound Area School
District my son attended a school about
45 minutes south of there and he was
there for the elementary school we were
very happy with elementary school but
the middle school and high school were
having issues receiving accreditation
so as a parent parent wanting my child
to receive the best education he can
this was a huge concern for me life
happened we found ourselves in Groton
New Hampshire I transferred Caleb out of
his current elementary school into
Bridgewater Hebron Village School as
with any transfer we had concerns
concerns about the education he would
receive how the teachers would be making
new friends and the support that he
would receive it didn't take long at
Bridgewater Hebron school to relieve us
of these concerns especially the concern
about him receiving the best education
he can this is where Caleb received a
great education where he felt the most
comfortable where he made some of his
best friends and felt the most supported
by the incredible teachers and staff
one of the main reasons I support this
bill as I do with Caleb I want all
students to receive a better education I
feel Caleb would have benefited even
more from staying in the Bridgewater
Hebron School District a little longer
K-8 models have been proven to be
beneficial and have many advantages
currently our students leave the
Bridgewater Hebron school after fifth
grade and go to the Middle School
a K-8 model would eliminate the
transition and allow them to stay where
they're more comfortable for a few more
years
the age that they attend Middle School
is awkward time for these kids
physically mentally and emotionally
they're going through so many changes
when they leave Bridgewater Hebron
school they're transitioning from being
the older students at the school to then
again becoming the younger students at
the middle school all of this can be
very tough on kids and can lead to
challenges while they're in the Middle
School
we live in a rural community in
Bridgewater Hebron Village school is
closer to our town than the middle
school and high school is our Groton
students are on the bus for about an
hour to the middle school and even
longer to the high school this is too
long especially grades k through eight
to be on a bus creating a k-3 model
would eliminate the extra time on the
bus then when they're older and can
handle the bus a little bit longer then
that would be more suitable for them
I also feel Caleb would have benefited
from being able to choose which high
school he attended there are high
schools that are actually closer to
Groton in high school our kids get their
licenses which is a very scary time for
us parents
we where we live also weathers are very
concerned we have a lot of snow and icy
situations and we are able to choose a
high school that he attended he would
have been able to choose one closer to
him with less travel time save on gas
money and less worrying during the bad
weather
he also didn't play sports but he jumped
into the workforce quickly he would have
traveled right from school to work each
day if he could have chosen a high
school close to where he works it would
have been more convenient and save money
on travel as well
I no longer have children in the school
district but I am still advocating for
all of the other children we had an
amazing experience at Bridgewater Hebron
Village school and I wish the K-8 model
was in effect when Caleb was in school
thank you for listening and I
respectfully urge you to pass this bill
so all of our students can receive the
best education that they deserve thank
you very much and any questions from the
committee
good morning chairman and members of the
um I will be brief as much of what I
said was said earlier by the
superintendent but I am here to speak
against HB 349
um as you may not be aware aft New
Hampshire
represents the Newfound teachers union
they're part of our our Federation
um so I've heard some concerns and
because of that I would like to speak
against this I must say though I've been
impressed by all of the passion I've
heard from the supporters of this bill
and
um
I think their involvement in their
education and you know the the Zeal they
have for seeing the right thing done for
their students in their school is
commendable I just am not sure that
creating a new process
to essentially undo a Cooperative School
District a Regional School District is
the right way to go about it that's
that's where my disagreement with this
is there already is a process uh which
referred to earlier RSA 195.
um
to withdraw from a Regional School
District
I do appreciate that you know there was
a four-year timeline talked about it's
not thoroughly described in this bill it
was more thoroughly described in your
presentation but it does talk about a
vote that would start next month on
starting this whole process
um and then the certificate of
withdrawal will be issued in about a
year you know if the three towns
approved I have members of the Newfound
teachers union who are also not just
employees of the district but also
parents and taxpayers of towns in the
district who are just hearing about this
so yeah they could be asked to vote on
it in a month things that will
significantly change their work life and
also if their parents change things
about their students school starting you
know possibly as soon as next year so
it's a great it's a concern what is this
going to look like and the concerns they
have that they don't have the answers to
and again some of the people here gave
wonderful answers of where they would
like to go
but that discussion has not been
as fully
gone through
um to members of the community as it
needs to because the questions are still
out there what's going to happen to the
students particularly the students in
grades five through eight
um in these three towns that was a
question that I had delayed to me that
is a big concern
um
so I I hear talk of well we can tuition
them into the Newfound area District
once we are declared withdrawn from it
if the three towns passed this on March
23rd
well that's presupposing that a tuition
agreement can be reached and that you
know everything will work out and it
probably will I mean good intention to
everyone's part but it's a very
unsettling feeling if you don't know
where your students going to school in a
year and that was your plan and your
choice and where you wanted them to go
um
the other question is what's going to
happen to the staff they are employees
of the Newfound Area School District
they are not employees of the The
Village School I I appreciate that it
says that the new district will
uh seek to offer employment
opportunities uh the collective
bargaining agreement is with the current
Regional School District so
there would be a whole process there
um
and that's going to
get into you know some questions of
making sure that everything is done to
make sure the employees retain you know
their current pay and benefit and are
made whole and we have great great
concerns about that we also know that a
school is more than just a building it's
a community of all the people who work
there and all the students who go there
so if you are not holding on to the
employees because maybe they don't want
to work for this new entity for whatever
reason
um
then what happens yeah just imagine that
your student you you have a child who
had a great second grade teacher
so they went into second grade and this
teacher was a perfect fit
yeah spark that Joy of learning ease
that anxiety about being in school I
went from you know the student went from
being kind of oh math is hard to being I
love math I want to do multiplication
I'm excited to go to school every day
marvelous
now we've got this huge change and Mrs
so-and-so isn't there and you're
four-year-old isn't going to have the
chance to have Mrs so-and-so when she
gets into school this is a big change is
being made really fast and we're
inventing a new process to do it
for those reasons I've got to speak
against this Bill thank you very much
questions from the committee
representative Woodcock thank you I wait
for someone that may have the
information which I forgot to ask before
so I hope we have can you tell me what
the average class size is at the current
K5 school at the current K5 school I
would have to ask so I don't have that
information okay you know at my
fingertips I would have to ask I
apologize okay but average class size
okay thank you thank you further
questions yes representative dry yeah
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking me a question
um we heard a lot about the bus ride how
would they solve that problem if this
doesn't go through
now would I solve that problem not you
okay
might that be solved how that might how
might that be solved
um
yeah
yeah that that is a great question and I
do not have a solution off the top of my
head
um again I think this is a commendable
effort behind what they want to do but I
also think the process they're doing
hasn't involved the whole the whole
Regional School District Community which
is what you need to do to withdraw from
a Regional School District you have to
involve all of the players
um because they are all one school
community at this point so I I really
think creating a law
because you couldn't get it done through
the other process
isn't really what we normally do is it
um
thank you very much for the questions
thank you I have one card left it's
right here Aubry Friedman
Aubry you put down more than the three
or four minutes
thank you thank you that's appreciated
so I'll just uh you said three minutes
I'll try to stick to three points thank
you uh Mr chairman committee members
Aubrey Friedman Bridgewater I speak in
support of this bill
um
that first I just want to preface by
saying when I come to the state house to
testify for against a bill I don't just
do it for my personal benefit or you
know how's this going to I think about
the principles and the bigger picture
but in this case I do live in
Bridgewater so you might think well he's
he's got like a vested interest and I do
uh but my reasons for supporting this
bill are still my lofty ones the
principles of uh and the the big thing
advantage of this bill it's an opt-out
for these three towns and they are stuck
in this big sprawling uh Co-op district
and they will not be able to get out
through this current process because
it's so obvious and I have friends who
are in the other towns the four other
towns and I hear that
they're never gonna you just get
outvoted so that's why they went this
route but the more important thing is
this is options for not only the
families in the three towns but the
other four towns because I think that
how this is going to work out because
the Bridgewater Hebron has got room for
other students so there's going to be
tuition tuition excuse me tuitioning in
and out of all these schools there are
also might be parents who are they're
happy with the Middle School somebody in
the Bridgewater Hebron their kid does
well in the middle school right now so
they might want to choose that so I
think there's going to be enough
flexibility here especially with
declining enrollment you're going to
want to get all the kids you want that I
think there'll be more options for all
the parents but of course mainly for the
three towns that are really different
from the other four so this expands
options as for K through 8 versus
traditional
there's a whole body of literature out
there as to the advantages or
disadvantages I say let the parents
choose and I think some parents might
just be very happy with the middle
school is and they'd rather have their
kids go there let them choose this way I
really think with the tuitioning in and
out there'll just be more options for
everybody so I think that's the main
advantage of this bill and to be able to
you can't get this believing I go to the
school board meetings and I know how
this sau4 works it's it's a big
bureaucracy and the spending is out of
control and the proficiencies are not
good at all and by the way I also wanted
to add uh they're not all that great at
the Bridgewater Hebron school but if you
compare there's four elementary schools
and I'm big on scores and proficiencies
and everything really the Bridgewater
Hebron does have better proficiency
results so they're doing something right
there and maybe the involvement of the
parents I'm not sure what it is that
causes that school to look better but it
does so they they're on to something
good and if they want to try a k through
eight and do tuitioning in and out here
and there I think it's better for
everybody so uh I I the only thing I
wanted to add just I wish this bill
could have been for all other towns but
I was told because it's a very specific
because two of the towns own that one
school it's a unique it has to be
written very specific I wish they could
have done this to all towns in New
Hampshire that are stuck in big school
districts that don't really work for
their families so I support the bill and
and that's it thank you thank you any
questions from the committee yes
represent cascadden thank you uh Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
questions I'm just looking for a little
clarifications a lot of emotion and such
a you know an event like this in the
communities can you just I think you
touched on it a little little bit in
your testimony but can you clarify for
me why the current 195 26 withdrawal
process that's on the statute in the
statutes does not work in this instant
well these seven towns are going to have
to if the three somebody wants to get
get out of this school district the
seven towns are going to vote you've got
the heavier populated on the other four
towns and is already tons of animosity
about the uh tax rates and all that it's
never going to happen and that's why
they did this thank you
thank you very much yes represent
Woodcock you know what this uh thank you
this is perhaps for you as the person
who submitted the bill and I know you're
going to adjourn at the last speaker so
I want to be able to get the question
and maybe answered uh I in my re I
thought I was reading this bill that
just the the intent of the bill was to
allow the school district to separate
and create their own new school district
but am I missing that does it say that
it has to be K-8 I thought I'd
understand this was a k it doesn't say
they can't go to K8 but as it's red it's
just the K-5 school district is that
correct
it's a it's a K5 right now and the
intent and I think down the road because
I I you could go k-6 okay you know not
usually don't go with K7 I had k-8s
right back in Rumford Maine and West
Peru and the K-8 sent the kids to
Rumford high school and of which out of
the top 10 graduates each year three of
those came from the small K-8 in West
not the rationale but it's it's I think
the intent of this bill is to move
towards Ka okay but the bill itself is
just K-5 separation
K12
okay okay thank you thank you we won't
be of course working on this and we can
look at the fine print in the bill
further questions
thank you very much
and that does conclude this hearing
thank you all for coming today
[Music]
foreign
for the committee we will pick up our
hearings at one o'clock
foreign
welcome back everybody or most everybody
um
our first bill for the afternoon is uh
House Bill 275 relative to schools
approved for school tuition program by a
school board
and I will call on chairman Ladd to
introduce his bill
thank you very much representative
cardelli and members of the education
committee for the record my name is Rick
Ladd I come from Haverhill
and the prime sponsor of the bill
within the area which I represent
there are a number of communities
there's Haverhill of course there's
Piermont there's Warren there's Benton
and landath of those communities there
are several which tuition their students
out beyond the Elementary grades
or beyond the junior high school middle
level grades and I'm here today to speak
to this bill 275 that's relative to
school tuition program by a school board
this bill is one that's needing some
resolution
we have had school districts all over
the state receiving advice from their
attorneys and the advice being provided
to those school boards is not always on
the same page
and so I'd like to go through and walk
through
just the overall concept of what we're
talking about here once you all get
these sheets that are coming around you
should have two right now
and there's another one which is the
tuition increased limits available high
schools which is an article out of the
does everybody have those sheets now
almost okay that's pretty good
my father used to say that you're almost
on the green I was in the forest
somewhere I couldn't find the ball
okay
okay I'm gonna go ahead first with one
with the arrows and just try to give an
overview of this tuition program I'm
talking about let's say you're a small
district school district of maybe 70
kids and it's k through eight
all right 80 kids
you have to figure out what you're going
to do with your kids the students once
they finish the eighth grade where do
they go
and there is a small community within
several small communities within my
district that are having to make this
decision
and so you're you you start with a top
box on the sheet here and you say yes
your your school district let's say k6
and then go down the second one it says
the sending District identifies and
contracts with a receiving school for
student education and grades not offered
in the residence School the resident
board approves these tuition schools so
in the small community of Piermont which
is a school district with 70 plus
students k through eight actually it's
pre-k through eight
they have to figure where we're going to
send our students
and the choices the way they make that
decision they take three neighboring
high schools which they have approved
for attendance
in this case it happens to be Rivendell
down in Orford which is an interstate
government District which in other words
it involves the kids from Corinth and
fairly Vermont
and Orford the other school district
they look of or at is Oxbow High School
which is located in Bradford Vermont
the other school which they look at is
Woodsville High School which is located
in which well Woodsville is part of
Haverhill New Hampshire
and they take these these average to
attend the three schools they add them
up and divide by three and they get the
average tuition rate plus an eight
percent fudge figure
so you get that it comes out a little
over what nineteen thousand dollars that
they're getting used for
tuition
so that's how that District does others
don't necessarily use that same formula
that's just how their policy states how
they're going to develop a formula to
determine
where they're gonna where they're going
to be able to send the kids not where
but the cap in which they're going to
spend on tuition
they may have approved other schools for
example Piermont at one time had miscoma
they had Deptford Academy in Vermont
coming up the river they had Oxbow they
had rivendale on the other side of the
river they had Woodsville and St
Johnsbury Academy today they have the
three I mentioned but they also have St
Johnsbury Academy
what happened now is that let's go down
the third box the tuition agreement
contract is signed by the receiving
school and ascending school so we know
you have a contract in place the
resident District made tuition to
multiple public or private schools
provided that the primary or the anchor
tuition School accepts all tuition
grades and meets a minimum Public School
approval standards and guarantees
placement for all students in other
words you provide a special education
services and all other related services
are needed by youngsters that are going
into the ninth grade
all the schools which Paramount has do
this
going down to the next blocks
consideration and selecting a receiving
school so now it's up to
piermont's approved for schools all four
that I mentioned from St Johnsbury
Academy St Johnsbury Academy is an
independent private school other words
they have their Board of Trustees which
are not elected but they receive public
monies from over supporting
approximately
I would say approximately around 700 uh
public school students from Vermont
and New Hampshire
the remaining of the ground off their
population of a thousand come from
private tuition all over the world
private tuition is approximately
61.6 thousand dollars and that's minimal
compared to some of the other schools
like a Kua or holderness or Vermont
Academy Deerfield Exeter Etc St
Johnsbury is rated very high amongst all
those schools as far as it's like
walking onto a college campus different
buildings just like a college campus and
they offer all the whistles and bells
that one would want their own child to
have if your child is interested in
mathematics they have high levels of
math courses
in mathematics courses above calculus uh
I saw one Advanced course in cursive
writing on on their menu and we've
talked about cursive writing but
all the schools offer certain things
that parents want for example I have
down there in that fourth box
considerations in tuitioning out
academic programming I just mentioned
some of that
performance outcomes you look and see
how the students come out of school
perform on the Statewide assessment
that's done in multiple places in the
state
you look at graduation rates what's the
graduation rate for students that are in
your high school
special education services and other
related type services that we see
oftentimes in differentiated Aid
co-curricular activities that's a big
one for parents when they're choosing
where am I going to send my my student
is there a wonderful theater program
offered in that particular building in
fact that's one of the choices that the
kids in Piermont have they I've always
heard for years that Oxbow has a
wonderful theater program so does St
Johnsbury
transportation is another issue
this this school district the sending
district is not required to provide
transportation for high school students
but they do do this for the anchor or
the school which provides all those
Services especially where you have a
special youngster that needs that type
of service
and you look at the Career Technical
education when looking at these
receiving schools you also look to see
if CTE embedded in that school of the
fourth Piermont has to have embedded CTE
in the program St Johnsbury Academy and
Oxbow which is where they have Riverbend
which is the CTE Center which accepts
all the CTE students from Orford right
up through Lisbon New Hampshire so they
all go to that school for the CTE
training
and you also look at the big one in the
bottom the tuition cost what is the
tuition cost
so going back down so you see I put down
the bottom of the sheet here there's a
tuition cap you have
a tuition cap of this the what the the
local district has done remember the
school boards approved all these schools
but they now have this cap in place as
well you have school district a b c and
d
these aren't the exact number sometimes
I just threw them in the other night
although the one on D is correct
so you have a saying well you can come
to our school for 18.5 thousand dollars
that's within the cap
B nineteen thousand one hundred dollars
and C you can see that is equal to the
cap so they're still in the game
but d as just in the last year increased
the cap but there's always students from
Piermont at that school
now during the pandemic out of that
class I graduated from Paramount not
many kids you know four of them opted to
go one direction through St Johnsbury
Academy but one then decided I'll go to
Oxbow
which was lesser but this is all done
when covid was here with us all and the
way they looked at these schools back
then was online they didn't have an
opportunity to get into buildings and
see what is this school going to be like
as eighth graders which they normally do
but because of the covid they didn't get
into these buildings three of them opted
one year later
Saint J upstiani tuition rate's going to
jump over a thousand dollars above the
cap
can that student that decided to go now
to Oxbow who has now decided this is
where I don't want to be I want to be
with the other classmates I came out of
eighth grade with up at St Johnsbury
Academy
well it's below the cap now so you can't
attend
St Johnsbury takes kids from lime they
take kids all the way up the river to
and there's an article you have there
which is put out by the Valley News just
recently you can see well not recently
in June
and it says St Johnsbury Academy a
private high school it's an independent
private school because it does receive
monies from uh various public schools
for tuition
in St Johnsbury Vermont currently
enrolls three or four of pyrmont
students another Piermont student had
hoped to enroll this fall according to
SAU superintendent
since this article we were able to
negotiate whether that's with the
Headmaster of CJ and get permission for
that child to attend but that's for the
next year we don't know about the
following years
going on down tuition will increase to
twenty thousand eight hundred fifty five
dollars so that went over their cap so
the question now for the Paramount board
are we going to allow the student to
attend
piermont's tuition formulas established
in District policy that board could only
change through a formal policy revision
process they went through to their
attorney and the attorney says well we
advise you not to do that
I'll take another District I have landaf
land app is a small k-3 and they after
third grade they send all their kids to
Lisbon
this is there what you call might call
an anchor school as they call it down
Croydon because this scenario is all
over our state with these kh3 k4sk sixes
so what land staff does they send their
kids they bus them in the land death
however
they also provide the ability for a
parent who so deems to have their kids
go to a profile over in Franconia
or over the mountain to St Johnsbury
Academy in in Vermont
this school district there in land app
allows the parent to take their kids and
they will pay the whole nine yards
there's never been a question other
districts allow the parents to pay the
difference
and some are doing that in the state
right now
so this is one of those issues in
statute that
that has been quietly kept underneath
the carpet because it's being done
differently everywhere you go
but now in this particular District I'm
talking about in Paramount there's
really question regarding it they're
saying other districts are doing it
why can't we have our parent pay that
difference why can't we have our
district pay our parent pay the one
thousand dollars if they're able to or
why can't we have a pot of money set
aside maybe it's from a non-profit of
some time for the kid that can't afford
that to do that
remember the transportation is provided
to Oxbow the transportation is provided
to Woodsville but not the St Johnsbury
Academy which is a 40-minute ride up
interstate 93.
so going on down in this one right I was
reading about the Valley News the
Paramount School Board Also may create
tuition contracts with those schools
which does public and private provide
provide the school's tuition rate Falls
within piermont's funding cap which is
set at the average of three receiving
schools plus 18 that shows that
piermont's tuition policy created seven
years ago prohibited support from
Contracting with School uh schools whose
tuition exceeds the district's cap
the policy does not permit the board at
its discretion to exceed the tuition
tuition limit for students who are
enrolled prior to tuition hike I was
contacted by school board members there
and say we're willing to do it if in
fact we can have stats to raise uh
language stating we can do that that's
what this bill does if you read the
bottom line where it's been added I'll
get to that in a second
on the backside of the chief from Valley
News which is gets all the news out of
the Concord Monitor many New Hampshire
districts which school choice including
Croydon and Cornish will split the
tuition burden with student family when
a school exceeds the sending District's
maximum allowance so there's another way
of doing it there too in these
situations the sending district will pay
the tuition up to its cap which is
typically the tuition rate of the
district's primary receiving school
system the student's family is required
to pay the remainder
going on down further in this article
this is all coming out of board meetings
which they've had the Piermont School
Board explored changing its policy to
allow families to pay the tuition
difference but attorneys consulted by
the school district warned that changing
the policy could result in District
legally having to reimburse families who
under the current policy had to pay the
full tuition to those same schools
so they're talking about back payment
now if we go ahead with this so now
they're saying to me
get it in that state law so we are
protected with state law
while New Hampshire law does not
prohibits districts from splitting the
tuition costs with parents so long as
the district provides at least one fully
funded education option which parent
does attorneys said that changing to a
policy at paying a tuition for families
that the district previously denied to
other families could raise legal
questions about fairness and equality
so here we are
and we have many different ways of doing
this throughout the state we need some
guidance from the in statute oh we can
just keep it underneath the carpet and
let these districts do what they want
but then we're going to be
discriminating it's the kids in one
District of doing one week and a kid in
another District doing another way
it needs to be resolved
and for these reasons I brought the bill
forward and in reading the backside of
that bill in reading it carefully in
lines 9 through 12 12. to enroll a child
in a tuition School approved by the
local school board so this only applies
for those receiving schools that have
been approved
by the local school board and by the way
all four schools that I've talked about
in Paramount are not just approved by
the local board they're approved by the
state of Vermont and also approved by
the state of New Hampshire they all
received letters from the commission of
education at Nabi Jenny Brown Jenny
Perry which was here harassment was here
earlier today she wrote a letter to all
these schools saying yes it's I have the
authority to approve you seeing that you
are approved in the neighboring state
because we have those Interstate
governmental agreements going on Whose
tuition cost is above the district's
established tuition cost per pupil as
determined and approved by the board the
local board may require the parent to
pay the tuition cost difference so this
allows
landaf to pay it because there's opting
we're not going to require the parent to
do it we're going to do it Paramount may
require or some other District may
require
the parent to pay that difference
because they are providing District to
the Anchor School
so I'll close in stating that I don't
have a list of all the k-8s in the state
but there are a lot of them there's a
lot of k6s we have some k4s
and and a K3
and do students go to another location
for the upper levels of Education that
they don't provide
but they're all done according to a
local policy and but the the thing
that's happening is we're having
attorneys getting into the game and
giving different signals in different
directions to haul these and that's
making it difficult for those who would
like to do something but they're hearing
maybe from an attorney he can't do it
well that's just an opinion
so we need statutory law to help us sort
this out thank you very much
thank you representative questions uh
representative Damon
thank you Mr Vice chair and thank you
excuse me thank you for taking my
question
I'm wondering if you could comment on
how we might approach a concern that I
have
which is that a school board might
choose as their
funding cap
a tuition amount that is not adequate
for the local public school
and I can offer for instance if that's
helpful to detail
yeah okay they did not do that they
didn't do it but they didn't yeah very
vulnerable so yeah we tuition to a
Montessori school public schools and
Mount Royal Academy which is a Catholic
School
for fifth grade and up some of those
schools do five through eight some you
know five to twelve
the Montessori school and Mount Royal
are half the cost or less of the public
I read this bill a school board and
correct me if I'm wrong
a school board can choose a tuition cap
that would not adequately fund
students going to public school and
parents could be paying 50 percent of
the public school tuition the the school
descending District you're talking about
has the responsibility to ensure that
all students provide are providing the
opportunity for an adequate education
that that adequate education has
delivered if they can't deliver that
education internally within the grades
they have they are responsible for
providing that in a receiving School
and they have to do that now they also
have to have what we call an anchor
school is not in the law but they have
to have a where you don't twist it at
school that's going to provide all those
Services when they identify that school
there's going to be a tuition per pupil
cost that may be their cap or it may be
some other number that they figured but
it's going to have to be equal to or
better than because they are obligated
to provide this service they have to
have an agreement to take care of those
students and I don't believe what
Croydon was going to say well you can
all do it online that is not what we
that's not the proper delivery of any
education what we want to do is we want
to have if you're back here when the
days of Jenny Berry was here we were
talking about competencies
and different students have different
areas that they want to be really
competent in so that's why we have this
program where you pick a couple because
if you want to be really competent in
CTE probably go to Oxbow Academy
Oxbow which is CTE school or if you want
to have Robotics and Sciences and the
foreign languages all maybe Saint Jay
but you're not going to get the
transportation to go to Saint Jay as you
would get the transportation to go to
Oxbow Rivendell if you really want to be
in a powerful Athletic program go to
Rivendell everybody has every school has
surpluses and that's what attracts
there's competency levels at it's the
best fit it's best fit so to answer your
question I hope I did that they're going
to have to provide at least the dollar
amount in the cap that the school that
they're sending the kids to to continue
grades four five and six and on up to
12. they're going to have to provide
that school's tuition rate as their cap
if they only want to cap one and then
they may find somebody else to lower
your cap and they could do that as well
if they provide all the services that
are necessary
uh representative Miler thank you Mr
chair
excuse me but I'm a little confused
see if I see if I got this right
we're talking about school districts
that need to send their children outside
their District because they don't have
um
so you're saying that the school
district would establish an anchor
school to use your term
and that anchor School let's say is
twenty thousand dollars a year
and that's the tuition that that school
district has with that anchor School
on the other hand
if I as a parent in that school district
if I want to send my child
to another school district because of
whatever the specialty you're talking
about that I want them to go to and that
tuition for that school district is
twenty three thousand dollars
this bill will then say well you can go
we're going to provide the money to go
to this anchor School
but parent if you want to go to school B
at 23 then you can pay the additional
three thousand dollars is is that what
we're saying here no okay no because
that the the school that the parent
wants that child to go is twenty three
thousand but if that school receiving
school is not approved by the sending
board then it's it's out of the equation
so what we have is if you have these
three schools right here four schools
piermont's approved all those as
receiving schools and and so at this
point in time you could but one of them
now has gone over that cap and this is
going to happen more frequently as the
cost of doing business are going to
increase
uh so um so then you could have you
could say yes I would like my my son or
daughter to go to St Johnsbury Academy I
will pay that additional twelve hundred
dollars whatever it might be well excuse
me if I may yes
so if I've if the school district
approves three different districts three
different School options right
I'm still confused about why wouldn't
the school district then
negotiate with the one that went above
what they wanted in the tuition why
wouldn't they negotiate a different rate
at that point in time my concern is is
the parent having to spend extra money
beyond what
the taxpayer budget is within that
school district that's my concern Rick I
I see what you have representative Miler
is that they've also they've taken the
average those three schools but they've
also added in the fudge factor of 18
which takes care of what they thought at
that time would be the cost for
tuitioning out to all these schools with
what the cost of business going on right
now in inflation Etc at the cost for
tuition are higher and so we have now
one school out there which is now above
the the 18 on 18 of the average cost for
those three schools which has gone uh on
top of the the nineteen thousand plus
dollars
so
that's how that formula works but they
all don't have formulas like that
they some don't have formulas they just
pick here's our cap number and this is
what we're going to allow you to and
here's the schools we approve you can go
to those approved schools
thank you would you consider adding to
this bill
um kind of what you were talking about
to give to make every school district
uh that actually only goes to a certain
level and has to tuition out their
student
to have one
option that was an anchor Public School
of which
the sending School District would pay
full tuition
would you you're looking at the issue I
think with uh Newport and Sunapee and
some of the others down there where
Newport was that anchor yes you had I
believe Sunapee was saying we're going
to take this student this student but
not that student
um so I
I just go back to statute where the
statute requires the school district to
provide an education for every child and
every every grade level with the way we
prescribe just as a follow-up to that
um you know our commitment as a state as
a taxpayer as a person in the state is
to provide a public school system
that's free
to the children in the state of New
Hampshire
and to me it was just
a terrible a terrible thing when when
Croydon actually set their cap on their
tuition
so that
there were families in that town that
had
three well one boy spoke he was a junior
at Newport High School they had been
paying for his tuition
he'd been there since fourth grade he
played on the football team he was in a
CTE welcome program he loved it he liked
his teachers and now because they set
that cap
and it blocked out that public school it
blocked out a public school option his
family would have had to pay five
thousand dollars over and above the
tuition over and above what Croydon was
willing to pay
I'm not sure that's the exact figure but
let's say it is and that he had two
younger sisters who also wanted to go to
Newport or were going to Newport so that
particular family would have had to
Shell out fifteen thousand dollars of
their own money
to go to the only Public School option
of that particular School District
that's why I asked you if you would
consider an amendment to this bill that
says that this whatever they took
whoever they tuition out they have one
acre school that's a public school a
nearby public school or whatever public
school can be in Vermont for that matter
that that school district will end up
paying full tuition
and then whatever they do beyond that
would be fine
um but I I support that concept 100
there should be the availability of a
student to go to a public school all the
way through 12th grade at no cost uh now
there are some that say well I want this
other choice because there is a program
up here in mathematics that it it can't
be is not offered you know beyond the AP
some higher level which some schools may
be doing that's that's that's a
different game we're providing at the
schools you're talking about all the way
through 12th grade all the requirements
of 8306 and everything that's in 193e
it's available at no cost I support that
and I have no problem with the members
of that sort okay
representative Damon
thank you
would you also consider an amendment
that would add the language that you
used when you were describing
um piermont's approval of the different
schools they would tuition to you noted
that not only does the school board
approve the schools they also I wrote in
quotes here and approved by the state of
New Hampshire
and the reason I'm asking that is I
think probably most of us would agree
that compositions and values of school
boards vary and change over time
and I think it would be good for the
statute to state that the schools that
are tuitioned to are approved by the
state for a perhaps broader look than
what some school boards might utilize we
we have language already in statute
which has been there for
at least four or five years when we talk
about tuition schools and it's
specifically written approved by the
local board and there are certain
conditions and criteria which they must
meet however if in fact you you
addressed an amendment the way that
representative Tanner is suggesting that
there be one K through 12 Pre-K whatever
you want to call it all the way up to 12
with a public school that meets 306 and
the statutes
and those schools are all approved by
our Department of Education some of the
schools that we're talking about aren't
approved by our Department of Education
they're approved by Department of
Education in Montpellier
and or in in Augusta with Freiburg
Academy and so and we have the mutual
agreement with those two states only
those two states and that agreement was
done by not us and the state it was done
by the Congress of the United States
we're getting into that type of language
inner governmental School agreements
interstate compacts
and so I I think that I think we have
really had this thing covered that you
know they're going to be going to an
approved school by the Department of
Education the State Board of Education
here in New Hampshire that
by inclusive of language that represent
representative Woodcock thanks um
so we understand this
the intent of this the intent of the
bill is to give local school districts
uh legislative RSA approval
so that so that it doesn't fall back on
them if something hits the fan legally
correct okay
um but as it now stands in your your
bold part on this bill local school
districts except the new palliative
local school districts could themselves
do this but this is more of a a cover
blanket for them that's exactly right
okay thank you thank you Mr Cornell
any further questions see none thank you
next will be uh representative Matt
Cullen
thank you Mr chair and thank you to
everyone uh on the board for your uh
attention today
um I'm gonna read a testimony I
represent uh craft in five HB 275
provides much needed clarification on an
issue important to my constituents in
Piermont New Hampshire
Paramount has no high school there for
students residing there have
historically had the ability to choose
which surrounding schools they'd like to
attend
however after a tuition cap was set in
the early 2000s students and Piermont
saw their High School choices begin to
plummet as prices began to Eclipse their
cap
even though surrounding towns policies
allow a parent to pay a tuition overage
as HB 275 would solidify the Paramount
school board and SAU 23 superintendent
have claimed that it violates New
Hampshire law I've heard firsthand from
parents in Paramount who feel
intimidated and obstructed by the
actions of SAU 23 wanting only the
option to pay the difference in tuition
for the education which Best Suits their
students HB 275 would establish
statutory language which supports
harmonious local customs and it's in
this interest that I ask you to consider
voting OTP and uh I'm open to any
questions thank you representative
questions from the committee
I've seen none thank you very much for
being here you're welcome
uh do we have any other cards
it was
was there anywhere else who wanted to
speak on HB 275
see none of close the hearing and in a
moment we will take up the next bill HP
640.
foreign
ahead now with uh 640 which is relative
to cost recovery for Vocational
Rehabilitation programs representative
you're introducing a bill I am
congratulations exciting moment for me
yeah it's first time especially a bill
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
committee I am here and for the record I
am Katie pedernal I represent Carroll
County District Six the towns of Topton
bro and Wolfeboro
hb640 is a bill relative to the to cost
recovery for Vocational Rehabilitation
programs
this bill repeals the state's right to
recover the cost of vocational
rehabilitation services from an
individual who receives a third party
settlement or benefit award
according to the New Hampshire
Department of Labor issues related to
workers compensation claims have changed
drastically over the years the
Department of Labor in New Hampshire has
a small Division of Vocational
Rehabilitation counselors that work on
workers compensation cases
for reference the administrative rule
can be found in section
281-a colon 25 for this program
due to the internal work that happens
within the New Hampshire Department of
Labor this statute language for the
state vocational rehabilitation program
is no longer needed hence the request to
repeal this section and I might add that
this bill is submitted on behalf of the
Department of Education thank you very
much are there questions for
representative yes
another first today move
thank you Mr chair
um I had trouble wrapping my head around
this one and it had to do with
um why it was relevant to education
perhaps that's the point of the repeal
but can you answer that or is that a
question better asked of doe I had
exactly the same concerns and I think
that's why the Department of Education
is here to take over thank you good
response
further questions
thank you very much
okay
for the record I'm Lisa Henson hatz I'm
The Vocational Rehabilitation director
and I'd like to thank representative
pedernal and representative Vlad and the
committee for this opportunity that's a
great question representative Noble
Vocational Rehabilitation has
traditionally been within the Department
of Education in New Hampshire it's in
all different places and different
states we feel that we're in a great
place because of our strong connection
to students with disabilities we have in
fact 15 percent of our federal budget is
set aside specifically to work with
students students with disabilities who
are eligible for our program or
potentially eligible meaning there's
some thought that they might have a
learning disability or something and and
need our help so
the reason that this you know that I see
that we're in the department of Ed makes
a lot of sense and we get that question
a lot so no worries
um
so I did want to just um say for the
record that
um we did a bunch of review of our
Statute in 2021 and this was a section
that we simply missed
um and so we're we're coming back to to
do this final repeal for this section
um I've been with the department and
with the Bureau of Oak rehab for 20
years and this particular section has
never been actually utilized
um so when someone has received some
kind of workers comp settlement
um this this uh recovery of costs for
any Services they may have already
received by Vocational Rehabilitation
just hasn't happened
and you know just a little bit of
background on VR at any given time we
have approximately 2 600 customers over
50 percent of those customers are
individuals on Social Security benefits
so we're talking about folks with not a
lot of resources to begin with it's the
it's it's it's very common in our
customers
um you know we rarely see a workers comp
case is what I would say so um and then
in addition to that I did share the
Department of Labor's information just
to share that we do have a separate
system and section for this within the
Department of Labor here in New
Hampshire so if I could take any
questions I'd be available if I I have
one question we oftentimes talk students
pupils I hear the word customers what is
what's meant by customer yes so
Vocational Rehabilitation is happy to
have two customers so our first customer
is our individuals with disabilities
which could be a student or an adult and
then our second customer are our
business partners because without them
it's really hard for us to help people
with disabilities obtain and maintain
employment and their chosen career field
so we use customers we also use
participants because we want really want
to make sure that they're they're
actively participating in their services
thank you are there questions from the
Department for the Department
I think that was the last card on 640 so
we're going to close this hearing on
640.
okay hb628 is requiring certain
non-public schools for Education service
providers that accept public funds to
perform background checks on all
employees and volunteers represent Linda
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee
um one of the most important functions
of providing public education or
education in general is the safety of
the students and one of the things that
we
get a lot of as we did this morning uh a
lot of different uh reports on is uh
situation for people that are going to
be working with our students
and
one of the places that um doesn't have
those background checks right now are
the ones where students are going out on
learn everywhere Extended Learning
opportunities and also with the um
the scholarships the tax credit
scholarships or the efas
and
um we can I think it's a dangerous
um
spot to be in where we're exposing
children to people who have not
undergone the background checks that we
have now in place for educators
so this bill extends the that background
check
um to all those areas and in most cases
like um people will say well they they
do do background checks and they may
even do fingerprint background checks
but if you look at our laws and we've
worked on them a lot the background
checks that Educators have
um have included about 20 different
crimes for those criminal background
checks that are particularly tagged in
the cases of people that work with
children in an educational setting
so this covers most contracted services
and or contracted services in non-public
schools and most contracted services in
non-public schools do do background
checks I mean it's risk management for
them why would they not do that and our
public schools and public charter
schools do do the full background checks
but I'm sure there are some that are are
missing um
in this this area and that that's what
this bill addresses and it also includes
volunteers and a lot of times the
questions that we've had in the past
about it was you know how do how do you
define a volunteer and why would you
know
um for example if I went into a school
an elementary school to to just as a
state representative and to talk to them
about you know legislation for one day
why would I have to get a background
check from that school district or or
background check for that and the answer
to that is that each um area each School
non-school contracted Services
can actually set up a policy where they
have designated volunteers and basically
designated volunteers from other
policies and probably are you know
probably the school boards Association
has a
directive on that that you could use or
there are probably many around that are
modeled
um designated volunteer lists but
basically it's those people that come in
on a regular basis that have
unsupervised Time by a certified
employee or those volunteers who
volunteer on a regular basis like an
assistant coach
those working alone in a one-to-one
situation and I'd say also those working
with two or three students in a private
setting or even online and we have a lot
of things online now and we know that
that can be a real issue as well
so that's why I put in this bill
um it's actually a bill that another
representative representative Porter put
in last term so thank you very much are
there any questions
yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm trying to understand the necessity
for this bill and I think I heard you
say that you're sure there are some
missing do you know for a fact that some
are missing background checks and have
you looked into that so the the our law
is written says that
um
non-public schools May
and and like I said if you're if you're
a non-public school
um and you are worried about liability
which most of them should be
um you've done it uh or if you have
liability insurance with you know places
like primex I'm sure they do a risk
survey and one of their
directives is that you have to have
these background checks the difference
is
between background checks that are you
know if you go to work for Walmart and
they say I want to do a background check
they're worried about have you stolen
before or arson or maybe
um you know have you killed somebody but
when you go into an education setting
where you're working with children we
want to know a lot more we want to know
if you have any um
you know child pornography cases or if
you've been arrested for assault so
there are and as I said in the statutes
there's about 20 different
um criminal backgrounds that are
actually specifically checked under uh
for educators or people that work with
children in an educational setting
so that's why I said that
further questions yes representative
bye
thank you very much thank you for taking
this question
um if we could go to number
three
and it looks like Roman numeral one it's
hard to tell on this text it it starts
with a receiving non-public school or
home education program that paragraph
yeah help me parse that the part that
says and that complies with criminal
history background checks under RSA 77
that phrase is modifying what person the
receiving
school or education program or the
students that benefit from scholarships
it's um speaking to it it's in context
with uh the second paragraph which talks
about the employees and volunteers of
non-public schools or providers that
choose to accept scholarship students
under this chapter so it's not you don't
background check the students you
background check the employees and the
volunteers okay so it's the and how may
I a receiving non-public school or home
education program that complies with
criminal history background checks is
foreign
this particular paragraph what it does
is it it says that the receiving there's
a lot of non-public schools some of
those non-public schools may choose to
take
um the uh
the tax credits grants or scholarships
and some don't
so what that paragraph does is it says
that this law only applies to those
accepting those those scholarships
grants or tax credits okay follow-up
questions yes and and how does that
apply to a home education program
there's some some at least
some home education programs actually
have situations where they have
um in fact we heard just the other day
that one of the schools had about 100
students
um that were homeschooled that
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for uh
giving the opportunity to ask these
questions this question of you
um I see that you're also on the bill
629 that we have coming up so I don't
think we have to establish that
um you believe obviously in the freedom
to assemble
what do you not think that represent
Belcher
I promise you this is on track well
let's when we get there we'll be on
track getting there too
um do you not believe they're requiring
a background check for instance for
parents who simply want to come together
with their children to assemble to teach
them
is that not an undue burden on the
freedom of assembly
I believe that with public funds goes
public accountability and part of that
accountability is making sure
that students regardless where they come
from are
as reasonably as we can
safe from people who shouldn't be
working with them whether they're
um whatever criminal background check
that pops up and it obviously that we've
had
instances in the past where it has
happened this doesn't preclude 100
guarantee there's no 100 percent
guarantee for all safety but I think
that's a function of what we do here
just just to finish that line would you
agree that there's nothing in this bill
that would exempt parents from having to
undergo background checks in order to
homeschool their children in these
little cooperatives or whatever they
have
um
yes again if they if if they're doing it
on their own and they're not using
public funds
that with public funds comes public
accountability and also the safety of
our children representative cascadden
thank you my question was along that
line as well
um if I want to homeschool my own
children and I don't attend a group
Center or anything is there language
here to protect me from having to do a
criminal background check I don't as far
as I read this Bill yes that you're
protected you okay if you're in your
home right doing your own kids and this
is for when there are homeschool parents
who might drop their kids off at a
center yes or assemble and work with
multiple kids other than their own right
okay yes thank you thank you
representative uh cordelli no thank you
thank you for taking my question
um just follow me up on that
um if uh home educating a parent
um with several kids in the home
um takes money from a tax credit
scholarship program or from the EFA
program and is defined then as a an EFA
student
with that parent who is teaching the
child have to get a background check no
that's just what I believe Dr castad
well I'm sorry I didn't hear the part
about that they're accepting public
funds because it says in here if they
are receiving public funds they have to
do a background check
right and if they're in their own home
with their own children
they're they're not under this
getting the background checks it's a
homeschool program home education
program
it may be that it it may need amendment
to that I mean this is what came from
all or less
um so yes you may follow okay thank you
um
I think one fundamental problem I have
with the concept
is that tax credit scholarship money
is not public money
it's been donated it's the courts have
ruled such
um and that money is going to a family
and then uh same with efas that money
goes to a family for them to use for any
one of a variety of
um uh valid expenses it is no longer
public money tax credit scholarship and
money was never public money
so the problem I have is
um all of this that says receiving
public money because these programs do
not fall underneath that
um that uh provision and I would go to
um
the state versus HR Supreme New
Hampshire Supreme Court says uh the
family and the rights of parents are
held to be natural essential inherent
rights within the meaning of the
Constitution part one article two
um which I can also read to you if need
be but I think that
this is not public money and you're
imposing
requirements on a family that has
natural inherent rights to raise their
children would you disagree with that
well it kind of sounded more like a
lecture than a question I must say I I
said would you agree with that no
thank you thank you further further
questions representative Belcher thank
you Mr chair I was just reviewing and I
know you already talked about this
briefly starting with line 15 and going
through line 18.
um by adding the by adding this part and
that complies with criminal history
background checks under the RSA shall
not be considered an agent of the state
or federal government as a result of
participating in this program
does that kind of imply that if they
fail to comply with the criminal history
background check that they're somehow an
agent of the state now
I don't get that at all
um that that's that's a reach I think
representative uh Balboni
thanks Mr chair and thank you for taking
my question
um if I am a parent of a public school
student and I want to go in as a
volunteer on a regular basis and work
with a small group of children that I'm
not in the costume but not in the
auspices of the teacher itself but in
another room working on a special
program would I have to get a background
check
I think you would
representative cascaden and
representative Ryan thank you just want
to ask you if this clarifies things and
I'm looking at line 15 I are receiving
non-public school or home education
program
if this language were added that
assembles with more than the parents
children
from scholarships grants or tax
creditors if that addresses
but your question was are you you
offering that as an amendment
represent dry
thank you
193a describes the home education
program as the program that the parents
set up for their children that's the
program
um are you thinking of something besides
that that doesn't find that definition
of program like a Cooperative or
something like that instead of this I'm
thinking are you using the wrong
language here I I maybe and that may be
a solution thank you
representative Ellison thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
some questions been raised about the EFA
program and where the money comes from
uh opinion on your part would you
consider the funding of the EFA programs
coming from a public entity and is
public money yes I think that's where
the money originates thank you okay what
are the questions representative Belcher
representative Miler thank you thank you
Mr chair is the intent of this bill
and I've not heard you say anything uh
against parents homeschooling kids but I
think we've had a couple of issues come
before this committee this session
that deals with a with a gathering in
fact we've learned we've heard a term
called Learning Centers for example
where you've got multiple children
coming in periodically to a center
is so is the intent here is to try to
deal with those individuals who are
working in that kind of a conglomerate
that they have some sort of a background
check rather than an individual parent
working at home with their child yes
that's your intent yes okay thank you
very much
further questions representative
thank you
um I'm looking at section five bottom of
page one and over to the top of page two
for
um Education Service Providers with the
EFA program
um first I believe Staples is a service
provider so I'm just wondering if
um
we would have to get a criminal
background checks performed on
retail
sales people from Staples Etc and
secondly it says indeed submit the
results of those checks who is Staples
going to submit those background checks
too
I think um if you go back to the intent
and you go back to the volunteers uh the
intent was that the the education
service providers were like prenda or uh
other educational service providers that
were being set up
um
for uh tuition programs and
perhaps that needs to be cleaned up a
little bit I'm sure Amazon does
background checks on all their employees
uh they probably do not do background
checks on um
the way that with the 20s specific
criminal background checks that we have
for educators and they're not in a
position where you know a distributor or
a warehouse worker or a salesperson at
Amazon certainly doesn't meet the
qualifications of a designated volunteer
as well
thank you
um just continuing with the language in
that
um
same part lines 26 through line three on
the next page
just wanted to note that it seems clear
that your intent in saying
uh any employee or volunteer providing
instruction in person to an EFA student
so I don't think and would you concur
that the folks at Staples are providing
instruction in person
what are the questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
clarify because I believe I heard the
possibility for an amendment floated
seemed like the sponsor may have been
someone amenable to it I just wanted to
clarify the outlines of it possibly
inserting a language that would exempt a
parent who wanted to teach their own
children
however if two families say neighbors
wanted to get together and collectively
teach their children then they would
have to get a background check
yes well I think that's opening it up a
little bit if if we
it depends on how we want to write that
um because then then you're going to get
into the nitty-gritty of how many
families get together you know that how
often all that
whether they're going to be alone with
the other children that sort of thing so
thank you further questions in the
committee
are those red lights on because people
no I guess represent Tanner's up there
okay I got it both places okay are there
any other questions so again thank you
very much thank you
uh represent our excuse me Michelle
Lavelle
foreign
thank you for allowing me to speak to
this bill today for the record my name
is Michelle Lavelle I am the director of
Granite State Home Educators
we are a new hampshire-based 501c4 all
volunteer non-profit across the state we
have about 14
000 members
last year this committee considered an
identical Bill House Bill 1664 and had a
subcommittee meeting in October that
expanded the bill to include traditional
homeschoolers those who follow 193 a the
families who do not receive taxpayer
sourced financial support and that is
exactly why I'm here today
because I believe hb628 is a slippery
slope and it can overreach into these
traditional home educating families
we've heard comments about that already
today
early in the subcommittee's comments
they discussed
pulling unfunded homeschoolers into a
pool of quote Bad actors
who supposedly may use home education to
hide child abuse
this was on the record there's a video
it's it's there this is an unfounded
accusation of families and reaches far
beyond the scope of last year's Bill HB
1664 and today's Bill HB 628
traditional homeschool families who
follow RSA 193a do not receive Public
Funding even if they utilize prenda
K-pop learning groups or classes through
vlax traditional homeschool families do
not have funds deposited into an account
in their names so HB 628 in no way shape
or form should apply to them
that absolutely needs to be clarified
because we're already hearing amendments
that how do you define co-ops or book
clubs or do you dare leave your child
with your friend for an hour while you
get your grocery shopping done this is
ridiculous
this is an unfounded Witch Hunt to
suggest that homeschoolers are hiding or
using educational options to remove
their children from society's long list
of mandatory reporters in New Hampshire
every adult is considered a mandatory
reported of suspected child abuse it's
in RSA
169-c and it has a long list of who is a
mandatory reporter and goes beyond who
the school Personnel or doctors or
dentists it says expressly any other
persons so that would include coaches
friends neighbors tutors your Co your
friends in a play group Librarians the
families you meet up with at the local
park anybody who encounters a child is
obligated to report it if they believe
that child is endangered
the new the national home education
Research Institute released a study last
March that examined research of abuse
associated with public private and home
educated students while there are very
few studies and many are quite old the
organization compiled results of all
available research and found there is no
empirical evidence to suggest that home
educated children are abused more or
less than students in other educational
Pathways so this bill can way too easily
turn into a Witch Hunt of parents
child abuse is abhorrent and a tragedy
regardless of where a child is enrolled
while the goal to protect all children
is universally supported expanding HB
628 to these unfunded homeschoolers in
RSA 193-a
simply because they home educate their
children and may use co-ops with friends
and other
similarly homeschooling families is
absurd and misdirected
if parents mistreat their children New
Hampshire law has mechanisms to remove
their parental rights and that includes
their Authority regarding education
choices
if this bill applies to homeschooling
families who are not mistreating their
children this is entirely absurd
unfounded and a gross overreach of House
Bill 628 and government intrusion
further if HB 628 is extended to these
193-a homeschooling families who do not
receive taxpayer money as suggested by
members of that subcommittee who are
still on this committee today
it amounts to a baseless inquisition of
homeschoolers and presumes they are
guilty until proven innocent
Granite State Home Educators
urges this committee to oppose this bill
and do not involve homeschooling
families in any way shape or form I have
one copy for the clerk and I already
have a electronic copy that should
arrive to you in just a few minutes it's
already scheduled so check your email
for your own personal copy thank you
Michelle are there any questions from
the committee representative Miler thank
you Mr chair and thank you for being
here and advocating for your
constituencies the question I'd have for
you that should this committee
be concerned
about uh bills that would provide safety
for kids in areas where they're going to
have their education and notwithstanding
the homeschoolers I understand your
position there but Beyond The Homeschool
activities kids that are going to be
going to these service providers should
we be concerned about their safety uh
and these kinds of backgrounds checks
for people who are basically sponsoring
and uh providing these Services thank
you for the question appreciate that
when parents are in charge of their
children's learning and they are when
they're homeschooling families RSA 193a
families
and I would extend that to pretty a lot
of these other options that are now
available families are choosing who they
work with as their service providers
families can find out if background
checks are done or not or if so by whom
and to what extent at some point do you
trust parents or don't you do they make
good decisions for their children or
don't they and I think at some point
you've parents do their due diligence as
to the music program they enroll their
children in or the uh
martial arts program
they choose are they comfortable having
their child there or not and I I believe
the parents make those decisions every
day so if and I don't know if it works
in your mouth but my my sense and your
your answer is that we sh we don't have
to worry about that because that's the
parents responsibility is that correct
I believe parents are the best ones to
know who these individuals are and what
programs are available and what they're
comfortable with thank you for the
questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you
good afternoon Representatives
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today my name is Christy Whipple
I'm the current head of school at the
Newport Montessori school we were
mentioned earlier I think indirectly and
I've been in that position for the past
17 years
our school is required to and does
conduct criminal background checks on
all of our employees we do this for all
employees regardless of whether or not
the employee provides in-person or
direct instruction for example our three
hour a day custodian is background
checked
by the New Hampshire State Police
just as our direct instruction teachers
are our school does not currently
um
you're good one more time sorry
um we do not do that we don't conduct
background checks for our parent
volunteers as this bill proposes and we
don't do this because they're never in
charge of students they're never
providing direct instruction they're
never alone in a room with students we
use our parent Guardians and volunteers
rarely however when we do it's for
things like our winter program which
just concluded yesterday on Sunapee
super fun
and the rain held off
uh let's see we used our help in
transporting to students to and from
because we don't have a large busing
ability at our school so we use their
help in transporting students to and
from the school in the mountain they
might be transporting their own child
and perhaps a friend or two of that
student however those students who are
not their child those parents have given
permission for them to ride in that
vehicle just as they would if they were
picking them up after school for a play
date or a sleepover
require requiring us to do background
checks on our parent volunteers and
Guardians is concerning for a fiscal
reason we're a non-profit school so for
each background check that we conduct we
provide that we pay for that for our
staff members so that would be a direct
expense to the school that we are not
budgeted for
um I thought I would also share in
listening to earlier testimony that I'm
a member of the New Hampshire Department
of education's non-public school
advisory committee and I've been in that
role for several years and I'm not aware
of a single approved non-public school
that does not background check are
people who provide direct instruction so
I think someone asked earlier if there
was anyone I'm not aware of any
in the example by representative Tanner
who may go into several schools to speak
to students then each school would have
to conduct their background check on her
at an expense to the school so if
they're speaking if it's something that
they do for a living and they're
speaking at five to ten schools all of
those schools would have to conduct
those background checks because we're
not able to share that information with
one another
it's all today
thank you very much are there any
questions yes representative thank you
thank you for finally meeting you it's
nice to meet you in person as well we've
heard a lot about your school here and
I'm glad you're here to finally put a
face with the with the school how many
students are in your school right 107.
is that your max 110 a 110 okay well
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you very much I have a question for you
because I also we've talked to your
school many many times
um if you're going to take a field trip
with some kids and you're using parents
as volunteer drivers do you have
background checks on those drivers we
don't background check the drivers but
we do require their insurance
okay that's something that our insurance
requires us to have a copy of their
driving Insurance yep thank you very
much
further questions
thank you very much all right thank you
good afternoon good afternoon
my name is Emily Van Patten I'm a
resident of deer in New Hampshire please
include this testimony in the Bill's
permanent record my husband and I
believe so strongly in the benefits of
homeschooling that in addition to having
full-time jobs we have chosen The
Homeschool our three children I only
mentioned that we work full-time to
underscore that I oppose hb628 so much
that I was willing to rearrange my
schedule and take time off to be here
today
as you consider hb628 please reflect on
the absurdity that I should have to go
undergo a background check to be able to
educate my children when my number one
priority is to protect them I didn't
need a background check to have them I
shouldn't need one to be able to support
their education and to nurture their
learning
HP 2 6 I'm sorry HP 628 should instead
mandate that government contract
shoulder the responsibility of
background checks for personnel who are
in direct contact with children if it is
not already required in conclusion I
oppose hb628 thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
welcome thank you for your time my name
is Abigail Belmore I'm from Chester New
Hampshire I'm in a unique position I am
a traditional homeschooler I do not
accept any funding at all never have
never will I also am in a unique
position I run a unfunded traditional
homeschooler co-op with six other
parents
I feel that this would apply to me in
terms of trying to run a Cooperative
educational system for our children
this is on the Fly I was not prepared to
write this because I am a very busy
parent
all right as a co-op leader I'm unfunded
I also am an unfunded homeschooler I
would feel that this bill would un
impact families that are co-teaching
because that's essentially what we're
doing we're building basis building
education for our children that maybe
I'm not really writing math as an
example maybe my friend is a math wizard
whereas I'm good in English we can
collaborate to make sure our children
get the best education possible because
what if one child is better in math in
English and we feel like we're losing
them and we don't feel that we can teach
them to a certain standard we can at
least have our friend that is wanting to
have their child get better education in
English where I need better help in math
so it's co-teaching we're not accepting
money or funding in any way or form
we are just building a well-rounded
education by supporting individual
strengths and weaknesses because the
parents are trying to build a better
education for our children by our
let's see the other position I'm in I'm
also a overachiever volunteer I
volunteer for several National
organizations and in my community that
all benefit my children's extra
activities an example would be 4-H I'm
extensively background checked for this
program I am also a representative for
our soccer Department league in our town
I am also extensively and fingerprinted
for this program I'm also a private
Carry I've been background checked for
that also to be part of my local gun
club
okay I get those right those background
checks but to teach my children in a
Cooperative co-parenting situation
I do not find that necessary because I
am choosing what my children's education
is even if I chose to use either online
programs whether I used to choose to
have easy access into my school system
to have particular subjects that my
children might need have better balance
in that I can't provide
I'm assuming that the public school
system is going to have some form of
background check for their children to
be taught by parents because they're
but for the activities that I do extra I
have been back around extensively
I find that those are necessary not to
educate my children or to choose what I
educate my children how and when
thank you like I said it was on the Fly
thank you for coming today yes are there
further questions from the county yes
representative Cornell
thank you thank you for all you do but
you said you don't accept any funds for
the homeschooling that you do for your
children no we bring our own stuff we
collaborate and we we choose as a group
what we're choosing to teach like
examples we're using the state program
moose on the loose for our history
program because it's one of those check
boxes that are required as a home
educator to subject our children to
State history which we totally agree
with so we use that we chose to do that
and we
are following the program but within our
own reason to gauge a multiple level
education following up yeah so so I may
be wrong but I don't think this would
apply to you because it says accepts it
would bleed in because I'm what if we
chose what if one of those parents chose
to accept the educational system
the funding none of them do I know they
don't but what if they change what if
something changed
and they needed to the economy is not
what it was a year ago
thank you representative miler
thank you Mr that and thanks for being
here I I have really three questions one
uh because I'm not familiar with Co-op
teaching so how many families are in
your Co-op six how many students are in
the 25 and and how do those do you
gather on a regular basis once a week
okay and and do like for the whole day
and you have different topics you talk
about we do history science uh
historical figure in a craft maybe a
little bit of English fun stuff like
teaching them what an advertisement
meant and how to apply one and do one
would be an example
um science we're doing solar system and
we've got a little program we're doing
we're doing some online videos and we've
got telescopes that we're trying to do
and do an off day program where we can
do that at night when the sky is done
we've got
um crafts that we just pulled from
online and we all agree
how we do that
um and when and when they're not there
then each parent is basically dealing
with their child in their own home
correct and so this is an oven and up
this would be another opportunity for
them to come and socialize okay correct
thanks for that clarification
representative did you have a question I
thought I saw you
okay represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony you actually you brought
up an interesting
point on the interpretation of the
language and I want to just look at this
just for a sec to see what you think of
this since you're the State Board of
Education she'll adopt rules pursuant to
the RSA relative to the approval of
alternate programs for granting credit
leading to graduation granting credit
leading graduation it doesn't say
anything specifically in there about
receiving any funding does it so is it
not clear to you that this wouldn't
apply to you this might apply to me
because if we're applying a certain
Cooperative teaching we're going to be
giving them some type of benefit because
we apply our own diploma if we choose to
continue through 12th grade thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you uh Ken
Rountree
foreign
I'm not great with public speeching
speaking which is why I prepared a
little something before I came in here
this morning but
um yeah can you start out please wait
just not your name and yep my name is
Kenneth
um
and I'm opposed to this bill
um I also agree that it's a slippery
slope
um this this bill doesn't really Define
homeschool program it doesn't reference
another build for the purposes of
defining homeschool program
um it's and
um there's some other language that's
vague
um
foreign
that allows that might allow this to
apply to homeschoolers
who participate in co-ops even if they
don't collect funds
um
uh
okay
if you have uh testimony on your
computer if you can get it up you can
come back up and read that would be
awesome yeah I think I could get it out
okay yeah take care all right KJ
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
must be Murphy's Law because I just got
something in my eye so if I start
blinking it's because I got something in
my eye so I seem to have a run a bad
luck here
um so um thank you for hearing me today
I'll be very brief and thank you for
bumping me up I have to head out to uh
do something with my child
um so I'm here to oppose this bill um
who am I I'm a mom of four children
um I have a special needs volunteer
educational advocate for children's
estate with special needs and also a
founder of a non-partisan advocacy team
in the state
um a group of moms that have gotten
together through our hard times and come
together to find solutions to help
ourselves and others I have two children
that are in Vlogs and pair that nicely
with Kai the kai program you may have
heard about I have two others in Brenda
we can't qualify for an EFA but we do
utilize educational scholarships
so as they thought about this bill it
really hung over me like a dark cloud
because if you knew the stories of the
people myself and others included that
have come here many times in front of
the education committee
to beg for options for our kids in the
state you'll know that you know like I
said it's it's a non-partisan matter
this transcends politics really it
should and to me this bill came across
with bad motivations and is sort of
tandemount to a bit of harassment and
you heard that from some of the prior
speakers
who does it impact uh use cases could
impact we heard from parents using our
vendors for learning loss such as
ourselves coming out of pandemic we were
able to get a scholarship
and after years of struggles in the
regular school system we had to look for
other options with three kids on an IEP
myself a single mom working full-time
with 200 blood pressure it was not an
option for me anymore to be stressing
myself and I had to find another
solution for them
um so we do utilize these options and
the the logic in this bill right now is
kind of all over the place I was pre-law
in school I have a major in that
although I'm an I.T now and I see this
as a proverbial slippery slope it's it's
an enormous slippery slope here
we've seen how even with background
checks in our schools
doesn't seem to do a liquor good right
you just heard it in the news Timberlane
Brentwood plastow I mean the articles
are almost in the news Every Day
background checks are not a complete
safety catch for this kind of behavior
by Bad actors
okay so this bill is not reasonable it
seems punitive and it seems ineffective
and it's adding a burden it's adding
expense and it's not answering questions
about who would administer it does there
need to be another branch of government
to administer all these background
checks and then what do you do with them
and who passes a background check who
doesn't pass a background check
the questions are endless here right
what I see is a big difference is that
regardless of the money the parent and
not the state is truly in charge here so
like you heard another example is if my
child at the park am I going to
background check everybody at the park
no my child's in a printer pot am I
going to background every everyone that
comes through the door no not
necessarily I take that responsibility
for my children my family
and are the people really asking for
this let's go back to my point about
this seems like it's in bad faith who's
asking for this who's behind us who
really wants this did the general public
want it because I can tell you or
represent both sides and in this
non-partisan group and they don't want
any of this no one's asking for it it's
not doing any good so this just begs a
lot of questions it's the proverbial
slippery slope again it doesn't seem
reasonable
it doesn't seem like we have a current
issue
we have other measures we have mandatory
reporting which we heard about we have
people getting put on a child predator
list right we've got those lists we know
who those people are I mean I know who
is around my neighborhood that's for
sure if there's anyone close by so it's
up to me the parent to put my child
somewhere safe at the end of the day so
it's unnecessary it's frivolous it's
burdensome
it won't go on but I urge you to oppose
this bill I mean my goodness what's the
next thing are we going to have a
Chinese balloon in our backyard you know
floating overhead honestly just it
doesn't stop right and when we start to
get into these gray mushy areas there's
no end so I ask you to oppose this bill
I thank you for your time I'll send you
my electronic testimony thank you all
thank you very much are there any
questions I know you're running it's
okay
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
very briefly I know you weren't law
pre-loved so maybe maybe you can answer
this
can you think of any any time in in
American history any other right in the
First Amendment such as speech assembly
has been burdened by the need to ask
government permission or get a
background check
I know it's been tried many times right
but no the answer is no we have those
rights are covered by overarching rights
that we live under in this country where
we're free so no I believe no
does that answer okay thank you thank
you thank you so much
foreign
thank you Mr chair hi Representatives my
name is Jenna padoni I am from
Manchester I homeschool for teenage
daughters thank you for your hard work
on the education committee I'm here to
urge you to vote no on this bill hb628
as criminal background checks are not
necessary for homeschool families
seeking educational tax credits
do parents need a criminal background
check to claim a child as an exemption
or deduction on their tax return no
our criminal background checks required
for any other parental tax advantage
nope having a child in one's home has a
profound impact on Ultimate tax
liability yet we never require a
background check
what is the logic for abruptly targeting
just this one tax credit there is none
please vote no on this Bill thank you
thank you very much any questions
let me know if I pronounce your last
name incorrectly Roar Bacher okay
get better
thank you for hearing me today my name
is Michelle rohrbacher and I am a
homeschooling mom in Barrington New
Hampshire we have five children and our
oldest graduated last year just before
her 18th birthday homeschooling from day
one
um I am here today as an independent
homeschooler we do not receive any
federal monies for our home education
program we do participate in the
education tax credit scholarship
that does not however affect our
homeschooling status and we are still
independent
um I choose the curriculum and service
providers that are best suited to meet
the educational needs and goals of each
of our children
over the last 12 and a half years some
subjects have been taught by me directly
While others have been broadened by
friends and professionals that we've
selected
as one presenter already said math is
not my strong suit but I have a very
good friend who has taught math in the
past and she has wonderfully helped in
that Realm
as a homeschooling family we have many
opportunities for activity and service
within our community
and over the last several years I have
myself participated in many of these
activities and in my capacities as a
volunteer with these organizations they
have required criminal background checks
of me which is perfectly reasonable
because they as an organization are the
oversight committee
I've served in my church nursery
in a nursery for another church in 4-H
in the Good News Club
at a family camp in the state
and most recently in my capacities with
American Heritage Girls
all of those programs have required a
criminal background check
each of those programs has provided that
criminal background check to satisfy
there is a no funding mechanism for this
bill
who is to say who will acquire the
background check
who is to say what the implications are
if a service provider or parent does not
satisfy the background check
this is an overreach
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions yes represent cordelli uh
thank you thank you for being here
um
your friend uh came in and taught you
math as I understand it or taught your
kids math I should say Yes
um maybe she should teach me some math
too
um
under your reading of this bill would it
require that you had your friend get a
background check or that somehow you
initiated a background check for your
friend under this bill I don't see a
mechanism that states that my friend
would be exempt we have also
participated in Co-op settings like
other families here today
and there is no mechanism to state that
those families would be exempt I have
taught other families children physics
would I be needing a background check to
do so
further questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony you brought up I think a
really really good point that I hadn't
thought about so
we live in a society obviously it's
imperfect sometimes people do bad things
sometimes they or debt to society they
pay it we give Grace
and sometimes those are parents
so what do you think would happen how
would the state enforce if a parent
failed the background check
for their own child
that's a very good question
thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much
thank you chair thank you committee
and thank you for all of your very
conscious questions they that's what's
made me so impassioned about spoke
speaking about this bill
um
I as you may know I am I do not have any
children currently in school but I did
have children that I wanted to
homeschool and I felt I was not capable
of homeschooling
um because I felt I was not capable of
homeschooling I had a child who was
physically abused in our public school
system by one of their teachers so I
chose to remove that child from the
school system and
pay for private education without Public
Funding because during my investigation
I found that this teacher had been moved
12 times within the last four years
because of parental's comp parents
complaints
she had a glowing history she had been a
teacher for over tomorrow's counselor or
whatever for a long time in our school
systems and she was physically abusing
multiple children
never had a problem with her background
check
so this bill does not address that
the bottom line is is we have we have
people
that for whatever reason choose to do
bad things and they will seek out places
that their victims most oftenly frequent
so we have a problem in the fact that
our public schools are ripe
for evil our our counseling systems our
after-school programs our coaching
programs we as parents need to have the
ability to to develop relationships with
people within all of these venues so
that we can trust them again because
that trust has been lost and that's very
clear
with regards to this bill I've heard a
lot of folks say that this is a slippery
slope I would say it's much more than a
slippery slope this is a discrimination
practice this bill is extremely
discriminatory the fact that this bill
would allow the government to withhold
funds because of someone's bad choices
before they had children unacceptable
what would this do I loved
representative belcher's comment what
would this do if if it came back that
the parents had a criminal background
would they have to report it to DHHS or
to dcyf let me tell you I worked for
dcyf and a lot of teachers a lot of
people in the school systems a lot of
Administrators if they got a bad
background checked on a parent I have no
doubt that they would file a report of
abuse and neglect and that would be not
appropriate
because we should not judge people by
their past we need to judge people by
what they are today isn't that what our
society is all about we've all made
mistakes
we can cut lit we can rise from those
mistakes this bill says if you made a
mistake when you were 18 years old and
and you um did your time and now you're
that background check could preclude you
from going on a field trip with your
child
that background check could preclude you
from being a coach for an honestly the
Mind program or a first program or even
driving you your children and their
friends to an after-school facility the
other thing that's very very very
concerning and it should be just
concerned as concerning for both sides
of the equation
if this bill were to happen
and it were to be
every single provider that were to come
in contact with a child in in whether it
be Public School whether it be private
school whether it be apprenda regardless
this should also include the curriculum
that's being taught should it not
maybe if a bill like this were to were
to actually pass maybe we should start
looking at the curriculum and those
authors
the authors that are being that our
children are being forced to read
these these after school programs that
our children are being encouraged to
attend
vaccine clinics they're during school
hours everything that every person every
person that comes in contact with those
children should they have a background
check that's the kind of thing that this
bill is talking about
and it's unacceptable bottom line is is
that we should not under any
circumstances allow the government to
control what goes on with our children
without parents permission and consent
there is nothing stopping any parent
from getting a criminal record check
done individually
the government coming into this and
saying well we're going to do it if you
want our money then we're going to
control you unacceptable completely and
totally unacceptable
this this actually targets are
underprivileged it targets our parents
who have special ed kids who may have
made a mistake during the during the
their tenure in their school system who
may have been overwhelmed and made a
mistake and has a child abuse and
neglect on their record
does that mean they're going to do it
again does that mean they're going to do
it 10 people make mistakes
this bill puts every single parent every
single person working with the children
in a position that says you will be
Unforgiven and that's unacceptable thank
you thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much
oh excuse me excuse me we got the
computer working or do we come on Ken
fortunately a lot of the points have
been made but some of the things
some of the things I I wanted to point
out is this also um descentifies is it
because it incentivizes people uh from
joining small co-ops so people can
afford necessarily to do these
background checks just small groups
um it's uh
um
uh it's discouraging homeschooling as a
whole
um
it eliminates those resources as an
option for those homeschooling parents
which is unacceptable
um
and many of the people that this would
Target are low-income families who rely
on these funds and specifically targets
them so it is discriminatory it's
discriminatory towards uh low-income
people
um the families
um
those are the people who who
would need those funds and and um
who might get ostracized from
communities that couldn't afford to
participate in that small co-ops just
two families or so three families or so
uh
um
uh the intent is supposedly to protect
children uh from potential criminals the
thing that comes to mind for me is sex
offenders but as has been pointed out is
we already have access to public
databases where we can determine if
someone's a sex offender or not or at
least a convicted sex offender or not
um so if this bill were intent on
protecting those children without
bringing harm to these co-ops it could
have been written that the co-ops simply
have to
run these people through it through the
background check and potentially report
it to the local police departments if
they find that some employee was
somewhere some uh prospective employee
was a sex offender
um
um so this could be written in a way
that doesn't require you know harm
against these co-ops
um
um there's also um
the financial incentive
um which is for
um the state is gonna is gonna see
revenue from background checks
um and
also discourage
um people from pursuing these
scholarships and potentially
homeschooling entirely which puts them
back into the public school system
potentially
um and that would be a way for them to
cut and expense so I can't ignore those
financial incentives
um
also who is considered a volunteer or
employee of the co-op if the co-op goes
to let's say a museum
um is the person giving lecture there
you know considered a a an employer or a
volunteer I mean the the co-op contracts
them to provide this resource for the
children
um it's kind of akin to the staple
scenario but it actually in this case
they would be providing instruction to
the children
um
and
I think that'll do it
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee Nancy thank
all righty so this will conclude
and we're going to stand up for a second
here and do some stretching
um
okay
but it's not
what
during school board meetings represent
Aaron
good afternoon education committee it's
such a pleasure to be here and I'm so
glad to see you guys working so hard
okay
[Laughter]
um so I'm Judy and representative Judy
Aaron representing Sullivan District 4
which is Acworth Goshen Langdon lemster
and Washington and I'm here today to
introduce my bill HB 427
this Bill establishes requirements for
public meetings held by school boards to
include a designated time period for
questions from the public and answers
from the school board
the bill also allows an attendee of a
meeting of the school board to get
answers regarding which New Hampshire
statute or administrative rule gives the
school board the authority to create a
school policy or operational procedure
while I understand that RSA 189 colon 74
was changed last year with SB 410
to allow for public comment periods and
sets up some rules for school boards to
accommodate public comment I believe it
still falls short of solving issues that
have Arisen regarding questions from the
public at these meetings
one such problem is the possible
inability of the public participants to
speak to issues that are not
specifically on the meeting agenda
another problem is in regard to school
board members not answering questions
directed to them
members of the public should be able to
ask any question regarding the education
of a child or school policy or any other
education issue at these school board
meetings they should also be able to ask
and get answers about which New
Hampshire statute or administrative rule
gives the school board The Authority
described in a school policy or
operational procedure one would assume
that if a school policy is instituted
but the school board would already know
where in statute it gives them the
authority to make such a policy
so I don't buy the idea that school
board members would not know what the
law requires them to do or not do
with the introduction of this bill to
your committee I want to First establish
that school board members are elected by
the voters in their District as per
statutes under RSA 671. elections are
defined under RSA 652 colon 1 and RSA
652 colon 9 because school board members
are elected officials they are therefore
answerable to the public that they serve
as elected officials
they are elected to craft policy for the
school district and represent their
constituents and they must be held
accountable to those constituents
part of that accountability is to answer
the questions posed to them and respond
to the concerns of the tax paying
constituents
Jeanette and sometimes ugly situations
that have happened in school board
meetings across the state in the past
some parents and members of the public
at large have essentially been shut out
of participating in school board
meetings have been summarily ignored at
these meetings and have not been given
their rightful chance to question
discuss or voice opinion regarding
School Board policy for the schools that
they pay for with their taxes
this is wrong this is a wrong that must
now be statutorily corrected we cannot
allow school boards to be
dictatorships they are elected to serve
the public not ignore them
members of the public must be given
their time to voice their concerns
question and give comment at these
school board meetings regarding school
policy procedures and any other function
the school board performs current law
establishes no less than 30 minutes for
public comment my bill doesn't establish
a time frame but requires sufficient
time to be given for public input
when questioned about school board
policy or the authority of school boards
to make certain policies they must also
provide an answer to the public
it is the right of the citizen to
question and receive an answer
especially since members of the school
board were elected to represent the
citizens and these citizens are funding
the schools with their tax dollars if an
answer is not known at the time of the
question then it is not unreasonable to
require the school board member or
administrator to follow up and provide
an answer within five business days
again as elected officials and policy
ation are in order the public should
also be made aware through school board
minutes which members of the school
board refuse to answer questions that is
a sure that is sure to be useful
information to the voters the next time
School Board elections come around but
it is also a matter of public record
also not unreasonable to ask school
board members what administrative rules
and state statutes give them the
authority to make certain school policy
this ensures that school boards are not
just doing what they want whenever they
want without the authority to do so an
elected official should not be giving
themselves power and authority where
none exists
this is a bill that makes good sense as
it requires that the public be heard
it also allows the public input into
important local policy making and holds
elected officials accountable
so I hope that you'll pass this bill out
of your committee with an OTP
recommendation and I'd be happy to
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your presentation and for taking my
question
with these regulations in in our areas
it is very difficult to get people to
run for public office particularly as
school board just speaking from my
experience
would this allow for people to be apt to
with their would this precipitate no
that's not the word I want would this
engage people to want to be on school
boards or would it deter them from it
I don't think it would deter them from
it I think that if you're going to run
for an office that you would be welcome
to
um
giving reasons why you make certain
policy decisions and that you would
welcome questions from the public and
that you would want to answer those
questions in the best way possible
sure thank you
for the questions
yes representative thank you Mr chair
and thank you for bringing this bill
forward
I love the intent I have a couple little
concerns and I'm hoping you can help
ease them about some of the specifics
um so when it says that the school board
is unable to respond affirmatively that
they should then immediately have to
withdraw the procedure or rule until
they can
um is it possible can you can you
imagine any scenario where something
small mundane even but necessary hasn't
been specifically delegated by this body
but it's something that could impact
operations
don't know that I could think of a of
anything in particular okay
um but
I would imagine that if if they're
putting a policy in place
they should know already whether or not
they have the authority to do so by what
is direct they how they are directed in
our state statutes and so
um if they're putting a policy in place
that
they have no authority to do then it
would make sense to me that they should
oh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
just a clarification uh on line 15 of
the bill it says during any public
meeting held by a school board and an
attendee May demand that goes on and
talk about what they could ask for
what is your definition of an attendee I
mean if I'm
right we've been conquered and I don't
like what's going on in Rochester I go
to the Rochester school board and I'm an
attendee and I can ask the Rochester
school board anything I want am I
I would imagine so
um I think
the reason why I put that in there is
because we have had instances where
people who live in the district
who do not have children in the district
are not allowed
to uh post questions or participate we
have seen instances of that
and
um that's why I'm saying not necessarily
a parent not necessarily uh
you know someone who has a grant or a
grandparent
but someone who is attending the meeting
who is a taxpayer
follow up Mr chair uh I guess my
specifically then my question goes to a
resident are we talking about residents
of whether they have children or they
don't have children they're residents of
that particular community
but does this cover people coming from a
community 60 miles away to ask questions
about that school board policy where
they have no connection
I don't know why anybody from 60 miles
away would go to a local school board
meeting though but I I can appreciate
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for being here today
can you define sufficient what's
well you know in current statute it
outlines 30 minutes
um and I I would imagine that you know
if you only had a few people one or two
people who were uh
it will encourage statute let me see
what I wanted to say was that in current
statute
it says the public comment period shall
be for no less than 30 minutes well so
if you only had maybe two people and it
took you less than 30 minutes to answer
those questions so are you going to sit
there and wait till for 30 minutes goes
by that's why I just sort of I didn't
want to outline a specific time frame
because I think you know there's common
sense that enters in here too that you'd
want to allow sufficient time for the
number of people that are asking
questions
okay
uh yeah thank you Mr chair and thank you
for answering my question and bringing
this forward
um this question might be better aimed
at the school boards Association who I'm
sure will testify but my question is do
you know of any school boards that
already have a practice in place that do
designated time is that a majority of
school boards maybe only a few that do
that just a sense of that I don't know
specifically but I know that there are
school boards that do and school boards
that don't okay thank you
I I have a question for you
um
on line 21
if any public question remains
unanswered
now we have a lot of issues going on
which are labor issues which are
confidential issues uh some funding
issues we don't have any information
relative to that question seeing that
the budget hasn't been designed yet
um so to me this wording is very very
ambiguous
how would you fix this
okay well you know an answer is an
answer is an answer and I mean you can
say uh we don't have that information
right now but we can get that to you
when it is available
um that's an answer we can they can but
but we have seen instances in school
board meetings where the there is no
answer they don't even give an answer
they summarily ignore what the question
is then and that's not right either I
think that as public officials uh people
should be
responsible to giving
an answer to a question from a parent or
taxpayer person in the district
regarding whatever the question has to
do
um so say you know you you say it's a
labor issue well I'm sorry that that's
confidential we can't give that
information out to you in the public
or you can give you can give an answer
that
explains why you can't give a specific
answer
and I think that that's
you know that's what I'm saying here
okay thank you further questions yes
representative
thank you Chevrolet good afternoon
representative thank you for uh taking
this question and waiting around till
Friday afternoon
um I have a couple first off do you
think there's a responsibility of of uh
people who are participating in school
board in public to be respectful to the
absolutely I mean people both both sides
must be respectful to each other that's
how we have good meetings Okay into my
fall
I was following I'd highlighted uh line
21 has had representative Vlad I mean
honest to me but I was thinking about in
my particular school districts we have
an ongoing uh dialogue about the closing
or not clothing of elementary school as
many schools out with recline enrollment
uh and there's no way that that the if
you asked me the school board member or
if you ask the superintendent to ask
anyone if they can be able to answer
that within that I'm eating because
they're still talking about it and they
will never be able to give you an answer
within five business days because there
isn't an answer yet but you're saying
there there remains an answer that
they're responsible for maintaining an
answer that's what it says you're
responsible for obtaining an answer
responding within five days that is a
topic that's that they can't
so I don't know what would happen in
that case well the response would be we
don't have that information right now
but when we get that information we can
supply that to you
so that no answer is the answer then
if you don't have the information to
supply then you can demon you can say we
we don't have that information right now
but we can give that to you okay that's
an answer okay and one more if I may yes
thank you chairman uh last one was three
times during your presentation you
talked about that the school board local
school board should be held accountable
which I agree but it seems to me that
the local election for school board the
way they hold people accountable if you
don't agree or the person hasn't
responded to you the next Global
election you don't elect them
so are you then is that a way to hold
them accountable just not re-elect them
that's one way but um
I think you know you have to would you
have to wait then two years for
uh for for them to be accountable to
what they're doing no no okay I think
that you know once you you're elected
you're accountable during the time that
you're in office aren't you
sometimes I guess thank you for the
questions representative Cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question line 25 says members of the
public May file a complaint to the
commissioner of the Department of
Education I I is it true that school
locally elected school board members are
answerable to the commissioner of
Education
to some to some extent they are
oh
okay I
I I'm assuming attorney Fenton is going
to testify or the School Board
Association to answer that
representative Balboni
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question on line 14 it says that uh
complaints shall not be limited to what
is on the school board agenda for the
meeting I think that school board
agendas tend to be pretty tight there's
a lot of business that needs to be done
during the meeting as well as having the
public comment and down further you say
that the board members should be
prepared to give the answer plus the RSA
and the policies if we don't know or if
a board member doesn't know what topics
are going to be asked don't you think
it's a little difficult for them to be
able to then also give them the policy
and the RSA
no because if you're a member of the
school board and you're making policies
you should know
what you're where you have uh authority
to make those policies from and
um whether something is on the agenda or
not I think it should be open to
discussion or at least question from the
yes go ahead
um a lot of school boards have a special
meeting suggests to special topics with
that uh alleviate the need to have an
open session for all topics at every
single school board meeting
thank you for the questions
thank you very much
all right thank you and I have written a
testimony that I'll pass along to you
thank you chair and committee my name is
uh representative Kelly patenza I
represent um Stratford District 19.
that's Rochester Awards one two three
and four and six
um I'm in support of this bill I have
literally attended I would have to say
probably
um more than a dozen school board
meetings over the last two years
throughout the state Derry Londonderry
Bedford Loudon Rochester
SAU 16 multiple Portsmouth New Market
this is so important and maybe there
needs to be a little cleaning up on the
language from some of the questions I I
can um an amendment put in I can
understand that but I'm just going to
give you an example of being there to
support friends of mine at a new market
school board meeting where they lock the
doors and let us sit outside and we had
to listen to the school board meeting on
zoom on the phone you couldn't hear
anything try people trying to give
testimony
so those four families have now pulled
their children out of that school
I can give
so many other examples uh Londonderry
school board meeting
which was they literally did they don't
answer questions there is no open Forum
it's a one-way operation usually and
um you know it's it's hard to
you don't want to legislate anything but
we're at that point and
um people should be respectful at
meetings definitely
um but but it definitely goes both ways
as well and I think just in regards with
what's happened during the pandemic
sorry
um pandemic
um
sorry
um we've had experienced a lot of
um this necessity to have a bill like
this so I appreciate uh representative
for putting this forward I'd be happy to
answer any questions
and most of these things are all covered
um you know in regards with rules and
all those different types of things in
in a in an RSA under education or
chapter 197 so
um that's it
thank you very much other questions from
the committee
yes representative miler thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here just
one question in those communities that
that were abusive that's my term not
your term to parents or to Citizens
where those school board members then
not elected again in the next election
uh I don't know actually
so if we just look at New Market
um and Londonderry no they're all
they're all back in thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much okay
Mr chairman committee members uh Aubry
Friedman Bridgewater private citizen I
am super in support of this bill and
I've been waiting for a bill like this
for a while I'd go to almost every
school board meeting and I always speak
and
they sit there with stone faces I mean
sometimes you just make comments so if
you make a comment uh then you don't
really expect an answer but I do ask
questions I will have to say for our
school board uh they will if it's an
easy question they will off either the
superintendent or the chair will just
answer right on the spot which is good
however
there are difficult questions and uh
they're stone-faced and that is totally
rude I mean if you ask me a question and
I just sat there with a stone face I
mean that is plain rude if nothing else
let alone not being accountable so I
think this bill is reasonable as you
know you don't have the answer you do
need to respond and we'll get back to
you or something like that or you know
if you don't have it in five days sorry
I tried but uh we just couldn't get that
information that's reasonable that's an
answer but to just sit there with a
stone phase and I know why they do it is
because the New Hampshire School Board
Association specifically advises school
board members to not say anything and
believe me I railed against that
organization so they just don't say
anything
um also this business about citing the
RSA or the uh rule that I think that's
reasonable if you're taking an action
that affects the public and public
dollars you should know what your
Authority is I think this will actually
Force they should know the rules if they
don't it could be a little burden on
them to make sure they know it but I
don't think that's unreasonable to know
what your Authority is and my only
problem with this bill is actually I
think it doesn't go far enough there
should be an actual penalty because it
says members of the public May file a
complaint well that's very nice to file
a complaint but honestly a bill without
teeth is is only a suggestion and they
can just ignore it I say give them a
fine it was a 50 bucks 100 bucks if
they're going to break the law we as
members of the public we have to follow
the law and we have consequences if we
don't uh do what we're supposed to so I
say put a penalty in it a fine and let
them answer for it
um
and that's it uh thank you thank you any
other questions representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
presentation
um I've worked for three different
school districts so I I'm not really
clear and understanding
what your experience can you give us an
example where someone
kind of was rude no they're out of
curiosity or do you know any specifics
they're not rude we in our SAU 4 like
was described earlier we're pretty good
now when they had the mask and all that
kind of commotion uh they did get the
police officers just in case but we
never had any trouble uh we are all
civil and I've and and so there we don't
have any of that problem it's just
sitting there stone-faced is
unacceptable it's it's plain rude so um
and I think this is that's why this bill
is necessary but we don't have any
trouble like that okay follow up just
for clarity so if a school board sits
like I'm I'm like am I sitting
stone-faced I mean I'm interested in
what you're saying but well is it
precipitated on just the way they're
presented no no sir well if you but
you've made a comment okay a comment you
don't need to say anything but if you've
asked a question you've raised your
voice at the end it was a question mark
uh somebody should answer it I don't see
why not
uh
you know somebody
I don't think it's outrageous to ask
somebody and even if you say well we
don't know right now I don't know but we
will get back to you that would be
acceptable and then they have to follow
up so it's not the way they look it's
just you ask the question
somebody please answer and I do ask hard
questions so I think an answer we will
get back to you we've got to research it
hard questions are asked and and I do
ask them but they're not unreasonable so
I just think it's common courtesy of
nothing else
further questions from the committee yes
representative Woodcock thank you
representative uh
as someone you being as someone who
attend school with me is regularly I
take from your from your dialogue which
is terrific it's good to have people
like you there
um I'm concerned thinking about the
other side of the table do you see that
any problem with that someone can just
come in and ask questions and have
comments of about issues that aren't
even on the school board agenda that
night or do you think that's going to
really be a problem
comments or not if it's a comment it's a
comment if you ask
um
you know like in ours we have the
30-minute thing and they announce it
right at the beginning it's a little
awkward what the 30 minutes thing to be
honest because something might come up
while they start maybe 15. okay I didn't
mean some of this on the agenda to talk
about that that's just any yours they
might bring up any old thing don't have
to be on the agenda so you can just come
in and start asking questions about
anything I think that's going to make
for an orderly meeting
I don't see why not
um I mean they're going to ask crazy
questions uh no I say I don't know or
okay thank you thank you chair you're
welcome further questions from the
committee
thank you committee chair thank you
committee man
um I am not going to bore you with my
story but again
um but I will tell you that I tried to
address it with the school board
um this was a long time ago
but um it did not it did not end well
for me the bottom line is is because of
my experience I've become a child parent
and in some instances even a teacher or
a parent's support so it is very
important that anyone should be able to
raise the question because there is a
chilling going on between parents and
our school board between teachers and
our school board it's it exists now if
you don't want to believe it
go to go to some school board meetings
and you'll feel it ask parents ask
children ask teachers and you'll feel it
in my town most of our school board
members are also on the Nea
they're members of the Nea for me that's
a pro National Education Association
I believe that's a conflict of interest
my school my school manager is not even
a member of my town
so as as a concerned citizen the only
Avenue I have a lot of times is through
this process
um our school
our our
School Board
I have been told
is run by a bully
our school board I have been told is
full of bullies
and that is why the few non-bullies that
they us they have identified themselves
as non-bullies and I don't know if
they're even still on the board but they
say that they go along to get along
because it's better than being bullied
so if we have school boards that even
the members are being chilled
it's a responsibility I am all for
smaller government but we have gotten to
the point that we have trusted in our
elected officials for so long
that it's time to start standing up it's
time to start being vocal
um I just wanted to make a couple of
comments with regards to the questions
that you folks said sufficient time you
folks here at the State House do a great
job in allowing people to be heard
even people that are very very
impassioned very uh upset you do a great
job you give them adequate time if if it
can't happen in that time frame you make
arrangements so it'll happen in the
future
why can't the school boards do that
aren't they elected too
aren't they held supposed to be held
accountable and responsible to the
people that elected them as far as a
defined attendee I think I've already
spoken to that is there are some
instances that the parents are so afraid
that their children may be singled out
and bullied and sent to certain
places during the school day because now
we can't find out where they are during
the school day that they don't want to
speak up
so sometimes they'll reach out to
someone who is not part of that
Community to speak on their behalf and
um
it's uh the address the issue they come
up with regards to uh remains unanswered
by the end of the public meeting
easy solution say I don't know but I'll
get back to you that's that shows
respect that shows accountability and
responsibility
and if it's not if it's an item you know
how they always have the agendas and
then they have new business if it's an
item of new business then new business
should be very limited in its comments
and new business may have to go on to a
forward agenda that is one way to keep
the uh meetings orderly
needs teeth with a fine I don't disagree
um at all I don't know if needs teeth
with a fine needs to be done at this
level or at the at the local level but I
do understand what's the point of having
rules if you don't have to follow them
um and voting people in and out of
office unfortunately at a local level at
a local level when we are voting for
people
unfortunately most people vote for
people they know
they're they oh he goes to the men's
club he's good oh she's part of the
Bedford Women's Club she's great
but they don't know their politics they
don't know how how they're going to
enact restrictions or limitations on
their on their
family
so I'm not opposed to the fine
um but and I do understand that it needs
teeth but a bill like this needs to be
done at the state level and then maybe
the fine we can work try and work out
individually at the local level
thank you very much are there any
questions represent Allison uh thank you
Mr chair just a clarify clarifying
question uh you made a comment about Nea
members are you in a position to decide
which labor organization Educators join
or don't join
absolutely not but my problem is is that
when you're a school member when you're
when you're a member of an association
okay unfortunately too many people re
too many people are beholden to that
organization now they sh if they're if
they're a school board member they
should be beholden to the constituents
first and that organization second what
I have seen in my town that is not the
case
and that is my issue
representative cordelli
um thank you thank you for being here
again
um I'm just wondering um we have to file
campaign disclosure forms
um I'm not aware that um local school
board candidates or members have to what
do you think about that proposition
I think I think local members filing is
an absolutely fantastic thing I think
that even
um taking it down we have in my town we
have people that change their party
before they run for a local position
because they know we have this many of
this party and we have that many of that
party and I'm going to change my party
because anyone who's going to do due
diligence will go to the town figure out
what party I am and vote for me
so I do believe that it should be that
transparent at this point are there
further questions from the committee
foreign
I have never done this before
uh first time last year I spoke at the
count city council here in Concord I
live here I've lived here for about two
and a half years and over time I have
seen it to where it's a bigger concern
than when I remember as a child
as a child the school was of the quality
of the education was always a concern
and it's only gotten worse
I have I'm not a parent myself but I am
on to 14 little kids
um all of my they're all like they call
me on but they're actually my cousins
but um
three of them are not in a public school
because of what is being taught as such
as CRT so uh but all parents have the
right to ask a question whether it is
the topic of the night at the school
board meeting it doesn't matter if you
are a school board member then you know
what the
the topic is about whether you are
researching it or whether you are quite
educated in it Bad pun intended
um so you are supposed to be able to
answer a question just as the president
does add any
public meeting he'll answer a question
and whether it's about the topic at hand
or not so why can't a school board
member do that we elect them to the
board whether they have whether we agree
with them or not they're still elected
and we pay their bill we pay their
um their pay so they should be able to
answer a question and so I also do not
agree that
um the meetings get heated and the cops
are called
with any
with any discussion has to become
civil and it has to be protective
because if you're going to start yelling
and screaming it's not productive and
nothing will get done and no opinion
will be getting across because there's a
lot of anger so
um whether it's the topic or not it
needs to be answered and I'm not talking
about an hour answering it I'm talking
30 minutes or little less so I don't see
the big deal in that so why is that
topic you coming up as a debate here at
this meeting today it should be obvious
answer the question and move on
and that's it thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you
thank you chairman good afternoon
members of the community bear Christina
New Hampshire school boards Association
we are opposed to House Bill 427 on my
way of background this bill was
introduced last year as House Bill 1169
it was voted in expedient to legislate
19-0 by this committee I don't know
what's changed in the last 12 months
since I'm in front of the education
committee I would like to know if
anybody on this community can tell me
is anybody gonna get back to me
representative cascadden your
superintendent can you tell me what
department of education enroll
304.0184 says
thank you
um
are we being asked questions now I'm not
sure what's going on I I think this is
not really a question directly if he's
making a point there are times I've
emailed members of this committee and
not gotten a response of times I've
emailed other legislators and have not
gotten a response
um
so uh the to the point of the bill aside
from some of the other absurdities there
are a handful policies school boards
don't have um I bet school boards have
on file that don't have a direct
correlation to any Department of
Education regulation or any state
statute I I thought of just holding up
my phone and showing like my testimony
from last year but we'll go through this
sample policy bbab roles and duties of
the board chairperson there's nothing in
law that allows a school board to elect
a chairperson or officers uniquely the
SAU statute
rsa194-c does does call for the election
of officers but nothing in RSA 189
relative to single District school
boards that have officers so I don't
know who's going to run the meeting
there's no provision to have a chair or
a vice chair or secretary or a clerk
bdg School attorney there's no statute
that specifically authorizes a school
board to hire an attorney
b-e-d-d-a board meeting rules of
procedure there's no statute that
specifically allows a school board to
adopt rules of procedures such as
Robert's Rules or some amended rules or
procedure
Bia new board new board member
orientation there's nothing a law that
allows a new school board member to
undergo some sort of orientation with
their local school board
jfab foreign exchange students I could
be wrong maybe there's a state statute
that allows for school boards to accept
foreign exchange students if there is
I'm not aware of it I presume it would
be in the education statute so if there
is I would appreciate if somebody could
let me know what that is
jiba student government there's nothing
in law that allows um high schools to
have sort of a student government
process or system
KD School District social media websites
or something a lot that allows the
school district to have a website
KDC website publishing same thing here's
one that's near and dear to our hearts
we discussed this the other day sample
policy kec reconsideration of
instructional materials there's nothing
in statute that specifically allows or
requires a school board to review
instructional course materials with a
parent complains about them so I guess
we don't need to listen to those
complaints until representative
cordelli's Bill maybe has some
amendments and gets through KF use of
school buildings and Facilities there's
nothing in law that allows the school
board to rent out space in its facility
to the town for the basketball the youth
basketball program the Bible Club wants
to come in uh you know some other
outside organization wants to come in
and run space so we'll stop doing that
since there's no law that specifically
authorizes us to do that the other
aspect a couple of Provisions relative
to the law specifically paragraphs line
25 paragraph
um five members of the public May file a
complaint with the commissioner of the
Department of Education of Education
parents are already doing that if
there's a statute that allows them to do
that currently I'd like to know what
that is too if that's again an education
statute I know Miss Fenton is here maybe
she she can answer some of these for me
um the uh the the other point a question
was asked and response was given our
elected school board members accountable
to the commissioner again show me that
statute because I'm not aware of any if
they are so again this is the same bill
that was introduced last year that was
unanimous out of committee and expedient
to legislate I don't understand what's
changed we have the law last year Senate
Bill 410 that requires public comment
periods we've amended our sample policy
school boards are implementing that uh
we oppose the bill I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you very much
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here once
again do you have a ballpark about maybe
how many scoreboards across the state
already Implement a best practice
perhaps of allowing time for Testimony
comments questions Etc sure thank you
very much for the question
representative current Law requires this
was adopted last year it's RSA
189 colon 74. and if you look at your
local school board sample policies it
will be policy
not sample policies or just to go
circuit wouldn't have sample policies I
have sample policies it should be that
the call letters should be b as in boy
E's and elephant d as in David H's and
Henry
b-e-d-h- that's the code that we use for
our sample policies
um uh so our our sample policy has some
optional Provisions in it so I don't
know exactly what the Salem school board
has adopted but I know your board
usually been pretty good on on policy
work so I would imagine that they're in
compliance with the law relative to that
all right thank you thank you I'm going
to answer the this of your question how
many well every school board should have
the policy relative to public comments
30 minutes for a public comment period
is typical in terms of the Q a back and
forth I mean part of that depends on the
nature of the question part of that
depends on the number of people that are
at the school board meeting you know
I've been to school board meetings where
the the gentleman I believe tested by
that if it's a simple easy question yeah
they'll give an answer I've also been to
informal school board meetings where you
know depending on the flow of the of the
meeting and how much time they have and
what else is on the agenda they'll sit
there and have a conversation with it
with the person it's not even a formal q
a right they're sending somebody they're
talking about a budget or a policy and
there's one person in the audience they
say hey excuse me Mr chair can you
repeat that can you I didn't quite hear
you or I didn't see where you're going
with that or can you give me that number
again and they and they do it informally
you know the reasons we had to put in
some some stringent rules relative to
public comments as we I talked about
this last year on a couple bills because
in 2021 and 2022 we had hundreds of
people showing up a lot of them not even
from that Community you want to talk
about why you travel 60 miles to come to
a school board that meeting that is in
your community because you want to
complain about masks and be disruptive
that's why that happened so but anyway
we had to put parameters around public
comment meetings because we had 200
people at the meetings yelling screaming
being disruptive threatening school
board members who had no interest in
letting the board get his business done
and no no interest in actually asking
legitimate questions that's why we had
to do that
and now we have a public comment period
to address that issue from Pam from from
from the pandemic we have a statute
requiring public comments how many
people go to the right Europe school
board meetings now we're back down to
two or three people at the regular
school board meetings correct I see
United representative so we went through
that rigging rule two bills last year I
wrote the amendment we got it in place
and now we're back to two people with
any school board meetings again because
covert is over and we're asking people
to to mask or you know get some fresh
air or whatnot so
Barrett I have a question for you
um the bill starts out on line four with
during any public meeting I'd like to
discuss this just that terminology alone
um having been on a school board select
board city council this right here
there's a number of meetings which we
have are for training purpose of new
Personnel or it can be a work session
um is is it your understanding that by
reading this that if we have a special
meeting set up for the purpose of
training and bringing folks in to do the
training of new school board members
that we would have to have this comment
period
thank you for the question Mr chair yes
according to RSA 18974 even even if it's
even if the board is not working through
its quote-unquote regular business
you're onboarding new school board
members you're meeting with the the
teachers
um or some school board will have what
they call a budget Workshop where it's
not a regular board meeting but tonight
they're only spending two or three hours
working on the budget
um whether you call it a workshop
whether you call it an informal meeting
it's a meeting under the under the right
to know law and so the language of
189.74 the school board public comment
period Bill School Board shall provide
the opportunity for public to comment on
School District matters at a meeting of
the school board held under RSA 91a2 so
it's still a meeting under the school
board even if you're just having your
budget hearing tonight we're only
working on the budget it's still a
public meeting under RSA 91a2 and you do
have to allow for and provide public
comment
I I understand the you know public right
public rights right to know and be there
we had an orientation for this group
right here
over at
Granite State College that's a public
meeting yes I would I would argue it is
yes well I would that was in the
calendar it was noticed in the accounts
however that is for doe to present to us
no action was taken
is it necessary then that we you know
you know acknowledge all these different
questions at that meeting which has a
whole different purpose right right so I
mean you know I I mean yeah I would
argue that that was a public meeting of
this body House Education committee but
you know and that should also be
distinguished what we're doing right now
is not a meeting this is a hearing yes
there's a distinction between the two a
meeting is when the public body whether
or not it's your school board your
select board your city council the Water
Commission the library trustees
um are doing their business adopting
policies adopting the budget receiving
reports a hearing implies that the
public has the right to speak such as
your budget hearing under RSA 32 colon 5
I believe it is if one person shows up
at your public hearing or your budget
hearing you just let them speak if 500
people show up at your budget hearing
you have to let them speak the same way
we had with you know some of the the the
firearms bills yesterday and some of the
voucher bills we get 200 people that
sign up you have to let them speak
that's the difference between a hearing
and a meeting
um but you know relative to what I just
said why is this just being directed at
school boards I've you know brought this
forward before with the public comment
Bill last year a handful of other bills
that are aimed solely at school
districts in school boards if this is
such a good idea why don't we extend it
to city council select board Library
trustees and any of the other thousands
how about how about the State Board of
Education as well too I'd like to be
able to stand up and ask Mr Mr Klein the
commissioner a handful of questions and
demand answers on the spot how's that
going to fly state agencies Library
trustees so on and so forth
further questions representative uh
right try excuse me thank you Mr
chairman thank you I I don't want more
to go I mean to be facetious I was
trying to to be Clerk and listen at the
same time but that list of
alphabetes policies I didn't get why you
were doing that list the list of
policies
um the the the the coded policies that I
was reading
those policies don't have any there's no
statute or Department of Education
regulation that authorizes or allows the
school board to have a policy on those
topics and the bill says you can only
have a policy that is tied back to a
state regulation or a state statute it
says
let me find it real quickly please
representative
[Music]
um
this is paragraph three line 15 during
any public meeting held by a school
board an attendee made the man which New
Hampshire statute or administrative rule
gives the depart School Board The
Authority described in their school
policy or operational procedure the
school board shall immediately respond
with the citation to its Authority if
the school board is unable to respond
affirmatively that there is such a New
Hampshire statute or administrative rule
the school policy or operational
procedure shall be immediately withdrawn
until such time that the school board
can show it does have such Authority the
policies that I read off don't have any
basis they're a matter of common law and
practice and allowances of public bodies
so that's why we have policies that
don't have any tie back to a specific
statute or regulation the implication is
that through this bill is that you can't
have policies that don't have a basis in
statute or administrative rule okay can
I have just a quick follow-up yes all
right so administrative rule is
different than regulation the rule
regulation is used interchangeably
representative thank you for clearing
yes
yes representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair and thank you for that testimony
it did clear it up as far as my earlier
question about
some of these mundane things that might
not be existing but I wanted to go back
because you had mentioned specifically
masking policies and I'm trying to
remember because I wasn't obviously here
in this committee there was a period in
time in which this the things such as
masking policies were in fact
disseminated down to school boards to
make decisions about is that right thank
you for the question representative the
commissioner and the uh commissioner
Edward blue and the governor both said
that there will be no mandate from the
state and that it was a matter of local
decision the local school board and each
local community could decide whether or
not to mandate or allow masking
if I may just real briefly so
obviously being of a matter for local
control on that one
parents showing up and asking questions
about them those are obviously
legitimate questions right certainly
thank you thank you
representative cordelli thank you thank
you um for being here
um first of all just a correction we we
don't have any vouchers in New Hampshire
secondly
um I'm sorry but it's a fact all right
we're talking facts here wouldn't you
agree that maybe this bill and other
similar were put forward on a basis of
frustration because there were incidents
where
um maybe things got heated in school
board meetings during that period of
time
um and so this is a response to to that
and frustrations
during that period
um
on both sides because I know of a local
situation where parents were threatened
and being reported to the Attorney
General's office for requesting
curriculum materials so I wouldn't you
agree that it's a two-way street in
terms of
um respect between parents and board
members thank you for the question
representative there are thousands of
school board meetings every single year
across the state thousands of public
meetings by thousands of public bodies
across the state we've heard of a couple
people that don't specifically like a
response from their particular school
board and we also heard responses that
in some of those communities the same
people keep getting elected to the
further questions
not yes represent Woodcock thank you
chairman I just want uh Mr Crusader can
can you uh imagine any problems that may
arise if if people are allowed to come
and question or complain about anything
the start of the school board agenda
thanks for the question I mean it's
School Board School Board public comment
um uh uh Provisions are dictated by
local school board policies there are a
lot of variations in there I mean you
can do I as I mentioned last year you
can do a full day seminar on First
Amendment laws it relates to public
comment periods most School Board
policies have have most school boards
whether or not it's in New Hampshire or
nationally have policies that restrict
or otherwise a limit an ability of a of
a the ability of a member of the public
to come and publicly disparage employees
our right to no law requires that
um staff student matters are all
discussed in non-public session so our
sample policies reflect that that we're
not allowed to come and and disclose
personally identifiable information or
ironically you know disparage a second
grade teacher because with an allegation
about something that happened in the
class when that teacher is not allowed
by law to respond because they have an
obligation to protect child privacy
under FERPA and other various
information uh you know privacy laws
thank you
further questions of the school boards
Association
thank you very much thank you yeah
uh we have one card left on this bill
the department are there any questions
may I
um yeah yes go ahead so I I still had
the question about line
25 of the public May file a complaint to
the commissioner of the Department of
Education about the school board because
I I just don't think that locally
elected school board members are
answerable to the commissioner of
Education are they
for the record Diana Fenton with the
department and you were correct thank
you that is one of the technical issues
the department has a concern about on
this bill the department does not have
any oversight over school board
officials they are elected officials
when you look at how that is written on
line 25
um the public
can call the department and file a
complaint
they are not prohibited from doing so
currently the question is what action
can the department take in this
particular paragraph does not address
that so again I reiterate and this
question was brought up a few
legislative sessions ago when a bill was
brought forward to impose a code of
conduct or code of ethics on school
board members the department does not
have any oversight we don't issue them A
license they are elected officials and
so we are we the department are limited
as to what action we can take and
representative Cornell you are
absolutely correct
further questions for the Department
so this closes that I think I see here
629 yeah
okay this closes this hearing we have
this last one we're going to open up
Mr chair I'm Linda Tanner uh Sullivan
five the representing the towns of
Sunapee in Springfield and I realize
um and that I am the last so I will try
to make this uh fairly quickly my intent
in bringing this bill forward is to
bring our Focus back on students
um and uh to bring some discourse
um and and uh focus on their rights it's
an attempt to centralize in one place
the rights of students as guaranteed by
our federal and state constitutions and
statutes it's not intended to create any
new rights
and I'd like to
um just read a paragraph of one of my
constituents sent me
um and I've I've turned it in as part of
the testimony but she said education is
the Bedrock of our democracy teaching
students that they are respected members
of our school
that their voice is worth listening to
that their ideas may have Merit that
they have rights guaranteed in the U.S
and New Hampshire constitutions
help them to become active members of
their school and communities and then to
become active citizens as adults our
democracy needs a citizenry which
understands our rights and
responsibility understands our
government how our government works and
the system of checks and balances
between the three branches of government
will vote and participate in our
government
those who have been learning this
knowledge and practicing the skills of
speaking out and voting in their schools
respecting their classmates and their
teachers will become the adults who will
serve in our communities and government
and will stand up for the rights of all
people
they will be our Defenders and
practitioners of democracy I thought
that was worth talking about
um and I think you know we we have been
dealing with a lot of bills in this
committee already more to come uh summer
meant uh to disrupt the system others to
force methods or parts of the curriculum
offering or technical bills on funding
or special education we work on bills
that try to Define funding adequacy and
guard rails for academic standards uh
bills that focus on high what how what
and what not to teach and a bill will be
introducing to the house on parents
rights that list the rights already in
law
and adds a required reporting of all
conversations or actions of students to
their parents these bills are about
adult concerns and again
the purpose of this bill is to bring
Focus back on our students
when I sent this bill to OLS
and got it back at the at the last hour
they had omitted
the Preamble or the opening statement
for the bill which I have as and the
only way I could get it back in was an
amendment which when we're in executive
session I will be offering it to put it
back in but I'd like to read it to you
now so you have an understanding of why
it's important it sets sets up why this
bill is is what it is so it starts out
the general court here by fines public
education as a Cornerstone of a healthy
diverse and productive Society is
instrumental in helping to chart the
course of progress of our nation's
future
the transformative impact of public
education upon our nation's history
Civic institutions colleges and
universities and the economy is well
documented
students who rightly enjoy Privileges
and protections under the Constitutions
and laws of the United States in the
state of New Hampshire
will benefit from a deeper awareness and
knowledge of those rights including
their evolution and interpretation and
how they may be subject to extension or
elimination through executive
legislative or judicial actions
students who have a fuller understanding
of their legal rights and the Wellspring
of associated societal benefits are
likely to be more active in exercising
those rights and more Resolute into
forcing their proper Administration and
protections
whether in the matter of free speech
privacy equal protection under the law
or voting rights the engagement of an
active citizenry is critical to our
nation and its democratic ideals
in recognition of the role that public
education can play in providing students
with information about their rights both
as students and as minors and their
employment for their betterment of
education and Society intends to require
each public school to incorporate a
statement of students rights into
current policy and practice
that's the that's the introduction to
this bill so as you notice in the bill
um it lists
um as it says as I said before it lists
the the
um
it lists the rights uh that are already
guaranteed by our federal and state
constitution statutes and it's not
so there you go questions representative
cardelli uh thank you thank you
representative
um I'm just a curious
um I guess this is a bill of student
rights but only for public school
students is am I correct
the intention is to have this yes as um
public school students yes
thank you
um I'm curious about the bottom of the
first page lines 21 to there's 29 to 31
in particular
um and it says that public school
students in a have the right to seek and
obtain happiness I'm just wondering how
we're going to make sure they obtain
happiness
um that's in the state constitution part
so it's it's already listed and
um you know there's been much written
about obtaining happiness and what
creates happiness and and um
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair I have several questions but I'll
start off with one you mind if I just
take a moment I forgot to bring the
initial bill up and right when you're
okay
sorry about that
defines a few papers today
okay I'm ready okay so I guess the first
question I'll see if afterwards if I
could ask another the first thing you
mentioned that your intent is to bring
the focus back on students yes but
nowhere in your introduction did you
include anything from students in terms
of testimony so I'd like to know what
was your method of contacting students
to ask for their input on this
and how is that done
this this was a a bill that um what we
did was uh compile uh just going through
the New Hampshire constitution U.S
Constitution and and figuring out what
rights they had there and in the statues
it was not particularly to ask as I said
it's not anything to create new so it
wasn't to ask students what they think
their rights are or to get their input
it was more to enumerate them so you did
not contact any students about a student
Bill of Rights is that correct okay
thank you
you have another question or are you
related if that's all right well you
said you had a couple questions right so
yeah you might as well
um you did mention
um that a lot of this has to do with the
United States Constitution I have that
in front of me and also the New
Hampshire state constitution I'm looking
specifically at lines 14 through 20 on
the first page and you noted different
sections that are in the First Amendment
Fourth Amendment 14th Amendment I'm
curious why you picked these to include
because there are 27 amendments in the
U.S Constitution so I'm curious why
specifically these listed if this is not
to create new brights why are you
drawing attention to just certain rights
and not others I think it it was
pointing out the rights that that we
felt um students would would be more
subjected to uh and should learn about
them that they they were running for
example the freedom of speech and
publication I know that there's been in
the past a lot of issues around student
publication student newsletters what's
allowed what's not and what rights they
have and also about their protests there
were a lot of students that protested
about climate change and and how that
you know how that worked out through the
system okay thank you can I have one
final question yes you may yes I'd like
to draw our attention back to line 31 on
the first page as representative
cordelli noted it said the right to seek
and obtain happiness I believe that
might be misquoted I know at least in
the Federal Constitution it's the
pursuit of happiness because it's
impossible for anyone to guarantee
happiness to another individual so could
you just remind us what you said a
moment ago where in the New Hampshire
Constitution it says obtain happiness so
I can just check part one article two
all right thank you
that'll be it for me
for the question mark representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair
um I won't lie I could have a lot of
questions but I'm gonna try to keep this
focused and narrow so if I could direct
our attention to the second page
um starting here with line
where are we at
line four it says the right to absolute
freedom of conscience in all matters of
religious sentiment belief and worship
so my concern here is if for instance if
a 10 year old has absolute freedom of
conscience
does that mean his parents can't help
I think that's a
that's that's taking that sentence
totally and making it irrelevant to the
question
um I don't see that that's something to
respond to at this point well if I may
I'll continue on that same line on
another on another line
um if we go down just a few lines here
to let's see
line 11 the right to countenance and
implication of the principles of
humanity and general benevolence
that seems less of a student right than
a state power
to inculcate in a student
ideological values so taken together is
that not actually taking those two items
together is that not shifting the
responsibility and right of a parent to
direct the religious faith and values
upbringing of their children to the to
the government to the state you know
none of this is is trying to supersede
parental rights as I said in the
beginning it's a way to numerate to
focus on students
and give them rights out of our
Constitution and the U.S Constitution
benevolence as as a definition means
communication that conveys a sense of
compassion or commiseration emanating
from Humane impulses so benevolence
means empathy and we hope that that
that's one thing that that students will
and if I may just one one more quick one
um I noticed again that this goes to a
question uh rep McDonnell asked that the
manner of selecting certain rights but
leaving others out I didn't notice any
references to the rights to obtaining
seeking or enjoying property nor to
enjoying or defending life or Liberty is
there a reason that those were not
included I believe I believe
um well certainly you can check that out
with um lawyers or other Law Services
but I I believe that wouldn't be
applicable to a lot of students because
of the age
thank you I got a question for you right
here um I guess I'm questioning why
we're even seeing this bill or why this
bill is needed
these are students who are residents of
our country
they have the same rights to the
Constitutions of the United States and
the state of New Hampshire
as adults do
so why are we trying to pick and choose
some of these rights and throw in here
when they already have these rights by
way the Constitution and both
constitutions
uh to bring the focus back on students
we have as as I said we last year and
this year we're hearing a parental Bill
of Rights that enumerates
the rights that are in this Constitution
and also in statutes and and uh adds a
few and this one simply says that
students have rights as well
and pick and choose well some rights are
more applicable to minors and to um you
know they don't have the same right of
that that adults do uh and certainly not
in school sometimes so
further questions
yes
go ahead
what's the fiscal note for
the physical note I don't know they
didn't put one
yeah
yeah that's uh they said they didn't
couldn't surprise I had no idea what
they thought unless it was the part
about
um that schools needed to uh post it
um
you know that would that was one of the
parts but that was in the part they cut
out
when all of us
did it they cut out that part but in the
opening statement you know it has about
that the schools should should display
it and I think that's probably where it
came from
for the questions
yes
forgive me if you said this already and
I missed it but are there any other
states that have enacted a student Bill
of Rights I think there are a couple
um
I was reading uh ncls uh and they were
talking about some states that actually
had started this project to try to
enumerate the bill you know the student
representative cordelli thank you thank
you I just wanted to go back
um if these are all existing
um rights per the U.S or New Hampshire
Constitution uh I'm still not sure why
it's limited to just public school
students who don't non-public school
students and home school students have
these same rights as well well I think
just like the parental Bill of Rights
only affect public schools and public
school students and parents I certainly
uh you know these rights are in the
Constitution both the US and and New
Hampshire constitutions and certainly
apply like I said the purpose of this
was not to add any new ones but simply
simply to enumerate the ones that exist
further discussion
let me see I'm going to hand this to
representative dry if you're okay with
foreign
so in all honesty I was going to make a
joke about coming in today to check on
my representative that I was doing a
wellness check to make sure that at 4 15
on a Friday afternoon she was handling
things okay but she looks good so I'll
just uh I'll just proceed thank you uh
Mr chair and chair people for having me
today
um I have often heard members of House
Education
reference the fact that somebody needs
to continuously advocate for the kids
when we consider changes to New
Hampshire law we'd be that additions or
deletions and today is no exception
House Bill 629 the student Bill of
Rights looks to me to be centered around
the concept that children have the same
right to respect and autonomy as the
rest of us
it reminds us that both the federal and
state constitutions as well as the
corresponding statutes seek to defend an
individual's rights to formulate
and act upon their thoughts and beliefs
without fear of reprisal
it protects the vulnerable and reaffirms
public schools as a Cornerstone of the
foundation upon which Live Free or Die
proudly stands
again HB 629 appears to me to be The
Offspring of principles that have stood
the test of time
all people have the right to pursue
happiness yes representative I did say
pursue
the essential freedoms of speech
petition the Press peaceful assembly
privacy conscience and representation
are to be cherished
modeling benevolence is a worthy and
shared Duty that speaks to the best in
US
we are all created equally and deserve
to exercise our commitment towards being
contributing members of our communities
without judgment
HB 629 points out that the fact that
these rights extend to minors as well as
to adults
it does not attempt to create an
exhaustive list of Rights but rather
appears to frame some of the core
principles that such a list might be
based upon
advocating for student rights requires
an understanding of the importance of
relationships
it highlights trust and the necessity
for authentic communication
reading this bill I was reminded of the
countless times I was grateful for the
opportunities my own children had to
question
to learn to evaluate and adopt their own
standards and project their own values
into the world as it is
even as we all struggled as parents of
adolescents to get through it
I urge you to support 629 as a safeguard
to the ideals that we all hold dear
in our imperfect Union it stands as a
statement of support for New Hampshire's
children thank you
thank you very much other questions for
our honorable moments
uh good afternoon
um I was just curious as to
um what you meant by students have the
right to autonomy when I told my kids to
do their homework or go to bed I'm not
sure how much autonomy I was really
giving them uh
companion
representative to court cordelli to you
don't always have to say what you think
I I when I meant when I said autonomy I
did not mean uh Independence and all
decision making but rather
that kids have a right to have their own
thoughts and feelings without judgment
reps in the god
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony on this in
in addition to representative cordelli's
comment that some lines could be
misconstrued by students who are
children such as the autonomy measure
would you agree that it might be better
to teach students about their civic
rights and their rights as people in
this country within the state and maybe
a civics class or Civics instruction
within school that might be the better
place for something like this I'm sure
you probably already know this because
you've experienced it yourself
representative but that is already a
requirement in New Hampshire that
students must study Civics yes do you
think that that should be expanded it's
not required that it's a specific course
as it is during the course required
maybe as a graduation requirement you
know I would have to see the specifics
of that before I commented on it but I
certainly believe that Civics education
ought to be embedded in everything that
we do
thank you
for the questions
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony I just wanted to ask are you
are you aware generally that there's a a
Litany of Supreme Court precedent on a
number of items that are on here that
would seem to directly go against
a number of the items that are on here
if I was they probably would not be in
front of you right now okay if I'm not
just just to offer an example to get a
specific on for instance the right to
peaceably assemble the Supreme Court has
ruled that children do not essentially
have right to peaceably assemble
Outdoors during chemistry
it's
they have more limitations on them than
adults do and this has been repeatedly
upheld they don't have the right to
publish anything they want through the
school newspaper
um
is that can I respond to the
representative
um are you indicating to me that context
um I mean you said they don't have the
right to be supportive they don't have
the right to peaceably assemble during
chemistry class or whatever that's a
context yes that it doesn't mean that
children don't have the right to
peaceably assemble it means that there
may be parameters around appropriate
time and places that what you're
intimating I was I was merely suggesting
that compared to adult rights there is
more limitations placed on children's
rights and especially in the context of
being in in a school environment
um right I don't think anything I don't
think anything in this bill uh supposes
that orderliness of a school would be in
violation with with the rights of their
students thank you
further questions
I got one for you sure um
obviously this is about our children in
schools has there been any thought to
try to involve the process we have in
place right now uh the student
legislative
advisory Council which we have we have a
group uh is it possible that you know by
ramming something like this through
without seeking that input and
help from the students themselves maybe
we're missing a real learning
opportunity here
I don't disagree with you on that
representative
um I don't know whether or not lyak has
identified one of these bills
um
but I certainly think that they would
have valid input thank you further
questions
thank you very much you're welcome have
a good weekend
Mr chair committee members Aubrey
Friedman Bridgewater well this is an odd
one
um I'm going to oppose it but it has
actually some some good things in it
that I really like
um I think if they had just stuck to the
things that were in the Constitution
which I went through and you know
article two and that is right that one
about obtain happiness I said how can
that be and it really is in the New
Hampshire Constitution that's incredible
but it is so in general is pretty good
but it seems to me they've added a
couple things in here that are
problematic that uh to me look like
going into entitlements for example uh
if you look under section two there's a
couple here section two
uh let's see a the right so the right of
students
and these are especially which Patriots
oh well sorry I printed it out
differently so for me too but so it
might not match your lines but it's
under section two
um there's a couple there's about five
places in here to me these involve money
and so I'm wondering and also because
there's not a fiscal note I wonder if
these kind of things became law would
the taxpayers be on the hook for
providing more services for example and
they're kind of vague too so this is
under Section 2A it's a right mind you
free and appropriate education
free and appropriate that's a little we
already know about adequate education or
the Claremont decision 20 years ago so
that's a little problem here then look
at c section 2C again it's a right uh
and then it's offered by a recipient a
federal financial assistance so we're
getting into money areas here and these
are not in the Constitution so there's
there's about five of them here the
weirdest one of all uh okay okay now in
section three
um the right to attend public school
excuse me three F the right to attend
public schools that are funded that is
consistent and then they say ample so
this is getting Beyond you know Civics
type of things
um the and I'm worried that this you
know if you hit the financial note and
all that and they oh we actually have to
give more money so and the weirdest one
of all look at this one section three
G I read this about 10 times does it
what look at the wording on here the
right to have schools that are
maintained holy or partially by public
funds free from sectarian control or
influence
that the words maintain holy or
partially by public funds that's
disturbing why not just say just take
out those words and just say the right
to have schools that are free from
sectarian uh sectarian control or
influence in other words to have schools
you know so there are schools that are
not religious schools to have the option
that's reasonable why would they put
that in there that's it to me looks like
infringing on maybe any uh anybody that
takes public funds maybe an independent
school or efas or who knows it's that's
weird
um then this is section four a again
right it's a right to access without
tuition so
these mentions of tuition and money and
funding is concerning to me that we're
going we're going into entitlements now
and has been brought up before
what problem is this bill trying to
solve
um and what proof is there that this
bill will actually solve a problem and
was as was mentioned
maybe should be taught
um when I was growing up we had in
eighth grade I believe it was the
Constitution and it was a big project
everybody knew when you got to eighth
grade so that would be the time to
really get into these issues and it I
think they're not doing it these days to
be honest so that would be rather than
passing a law with a vague language and
stuff
um and then my last thought uh oh and by
the way why it only mentioned Public
Schools that's problematic too that's
discriminatory kids who don't go to
public schools they don't have the
rights so that's really was a a boo-boo
there as far as I'm concerned but my
last thought on this so
student Bill of Rights I grew up you
just went to school with that and we
didn't have rights you're a student
you're a minor and that's the end of
then my son I'm a parent now I mean he's
grown now but it was the same thing you
don't have the same rights as adults so
but now it's a different day and time
student what is it so let me do a little
research because this bill interested me
and I went online to look and I actually
found one and I I'll pass it around as
the uh my backup here and it's actually
from the National Youth Rights
Association and it's uh six pages is
pretty good of course I don't agree with
everything in here but that's a real The
Real McCoy talking about students like
you're really people and I mean it
includes some things that parents would
freak out for example uh the right well
some of them are okay I really agree
with most of it the right to view your
own school records I don't think the
right the right to refuse assistance
schools where do you hear that then at
school policies like zero and tolerance
and then find another one right to
refuse education citing the 13th
Amendment as involuntary servitude so
that's quite uh there's quite a bit
there it's pretty good I mean there was
one thing in here about like the budget
that they get to vote on the budget no
you don't get to vote on the budget if
you're not paying for it sorry kids you
don't but it's pretty good so when it
comes around maybe you'll take that is a
real student I mean it's too much but
that's the kind of thing that's pretty
good would bring up a lot of discussion
and you know that'd be uh pretty good
but I I really think this bill as it is
is not needed and uh brings up some
issues maybe with financing I think
we're spending like plenty of money on
the school so we I don't have to force
anymore and
I think that's it yeah thank you thank
you very much are there questions yes
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony I
appreciate that you brought up the money
side of things because that caught my
eye a little bit too and I wanted to ask
you if you were to look at uh Article 2
here section A it says the right of
students with identified disabilities to
receive a free appropriate education
that addresses their individual needs do
you see anything in there that would
identify what disabilities or what
schooling this is limited to is this do
you think this might include college
grad school I mean I yeah well it's true
I mean what is it any child enrolled in
a New Hampshire public or or chartered
school and now since they're getting up
to age 22 in in a public schools and
stuff it really could
and so I don't know I
this is a can of worms as far as I'm
concerned and I don't think it's a good
idea
further questions
reps and whitcock thank you
excuse me here um
looking at the thank you for identifying
those sections in in item two I I
clearly don't agree with you for most of
that but I would ask you on C that
you're talking about the the free from
discrimination
um it seems to me that says the people
who receive any financial assistance uh
should be allowed to access education
without being discriminated against
did you read that differently well I
think we should discriminate free from
discrimination I'm okay with that part
okay uh
when they get into recipient and federal
financial assistance I'm either getting
some type of Aid so it's freaking
survive
could be food stamps could be anything
housing
um well I really don't like free
programs from the federal government
okay but that's fine that's the answer
but thank you further questions
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony once again it's good to have
you back
do you see within this bill a
stipulation or a practice in place to
talk to students who might misconstrue
this and say maybe oh my tuition should
be paid for or I should be able to
peaceably assemble it to get out of
class what's the method in place to tell
those students that's not how this
well that's a problem when you start
with a student Bill of Rights you know
it's kind of oh wow I have I didn't know
I had these I better exercise them or
especially that obtain happiness and
which is in the New Hampshire
Constitution so I actually think
students should be aware of these rights
absolutely because when they become an
adult they really will get them but as a
student they kind of get them but I
think yeah it could uh could create an
illusion of oh wow we're like an adult
now we can we can do all these things so
it could be a problem
yes so by that cause you would say this
bill as is is lacking a protocol and
could create disillusionment in students
as is good it could yeah I think and
yeah
foreign
questions
thank you very much
and it's going to be very very quick
thank you committee chair thank you
committee man thank you
um so just a couple of points on here it
says pre-exercise of religion and I am
taking no position on this okay I see a
lot of good in it I see a lot of
opportunity but I know the way kids work
okay and the bottom line is when you say
you have your you have the free choice
to exercise your religion we're going to
see
wwjd t-shirts we're going to see satanic
t-shirts we're going to see because
Satanism is a form of religion it's a
recognized form of religion uh we're
going to see you know who knows what and
that's going to be a problem
because we've already we've already
found problems in our school through
litigation where people have worn
um proudly warn their position on
religion or a political candidate or
whatever and it has become a problem so
there I see it the other one I think is
beautifully expressed and how what a
slippery slope this could be is freedom
of speech
you're in a classroom and you decide
that you don't like what's going on or
it's a test and everyone's supposed to
be quiet I'm exercising my freedom of
speech
doesn't matter whether it's appropriate
or not I'm exercising it it says right
here in my Bill of Rights
slippery slope especially when we're
dealing with children who have not
developed the full sense of of
consequences for choices made
um I chose to look up if we had any
um
Bill of Rights for students here in our
country what I got is a quote no country
in North America has yet to adopt a
national student Bill of Rights
it's a good reason for that most likely
um interestingly enough
many well I don't know if many but I
hope if this committee supports this
bill that they will be as quickly to
support a parent's Bill of Rights
because what I heard today in defense of
this was exactly what I heard opposing
last session for the parents bills of
Rights it's not needed it's not
necessary it's all in here or it's all
in here
that's it thank you thank you very much
and I'll take any questions
McDonald thank you once again and thank
you you mentioned that you were in
support of a parent's Bill of Rights as
well and I see these two things as
standing in stark contrast to each other
but regardless of that what other group
or entity do you believe deserves a Bill
of Rights is this just Limitless in
every group every organization should
get its own Bill of Rights
with regards to the parents Bill of
Rights the the parents Bill of Rights
unfortunately parents rights have been
violated in our school systems in our
state in our in our schools in our
school boards in our state in our nation
so that's why we need a parent's Bill of
Rights unfortunately in our state in my
opinion
um
because parents don't have the ability
to bring litigation in yes there's a
process but that process has a huge
financial burden
um students on the other hand all of
their Bill of Rights are protected
through their parents and through
through the Constitution but also
through their parents because the
parents bottom line is is that every
right that a student holds every right
that a child holds that ultimate
responsibility is the parents if the
parent does If the child does something
that is against the law or that is
against someone else's right that parent
is held accountable
if the parent does something wrong is
this if the school does something wrong
is the school held accountable to the
parent is the school held accountable to
the child
that's why we need a parent's Bill of
Right versus a child's bill right thank
it'll be two seconds I swear that's what
I said representative Potenza I wasn't
going to speak
foreign
representative Kelly Potenza again
Rochester's Stratford District 19
Rochester one through four and six
um so of course I uh strongly oppose the
spill
um for a number of different reasons
that were already covered but I'd just
love to say this because
where were all of these people that put
this bill in when the child that was
from the Exeter Middle School
or a Thin Blue Line flag shirt to school
one said anything no one was coming out
these parents have now had to take this
on themselves hiring an attorney in
litigation and fees it's ridiculous they
allow the American flag they allow the
rainbow flag
but a student wears a flag that looks
like the American flag that has The Thin
Blue Line because his parent was in law
enforcement
and he's literally taken out of the
class and put in a room
until his parents could come and change
his shirt so that's where we're at I
just don't understand how
we just um
it's good for one group it's not good
for other there's just a lot of
hypocrisy here I really I like it I
think we should say this bill
establishes a parent student Bill of
Rights and then we'll have to still
amend a ton of it but I think then we
cover all bases right
um because that's these are minors that
we're talking about here so uh but I
strongly oppose this bill and uh please
IDL thank you thank you very much
questions
see the young one it's okay though
I appreciate you taking my question in
this build do you see anything that
would stipulate this to just k for 12 or
is this extended to college students
such as myself do these student Bill of
Rights apply to me and my peers
I agree I think this is very open-ended
in so many ways and it is
um like rasan stated a slippery slope uh
with a lot of different things
um you know I love some stuff that's in
here the freedom exercise of religion I
think we desperately need that in
schools so if you're telling me that a
student is going to be able to put up a
whole big billboard of everything that
they believe about Jesus Christ and all
of that let's see if the school is going
to let that happen like this is
unfortunately
um you know really only I believe uh
helping one-sided view of things thank
you further questions not seeing thank
you very much and that will close this
hearing